[Music]
e
for
[Music]
the drama on the board has never been
more intense as the 2023 Champions chess
tour moves to the semifinals and these
two guys will be making moves on the
board and yet it's sure to be another
epic battle and a long rivalry can
Fabiano Carana finally overtake Magnus
Carlson in a high stakes rapid match
he'll have to bring his best chess
because the king is on form here in
Toronto can Notre Beck abaturov maintain
his form after sending hikaro Nakamura
home the youngster wants to prove these
guys are no longer his Heroes they are
his Rivals and speaking of Rivals Wesley
so seems to have none in Toronto he
feels the flow he's ready to go it's
time to hit the road the Champions chess
tour semifinals starts
[Music]
now you've heard the sayings The Road
Less Traveled rubber meets the road I'm
on the road to nowhere that need to get
up and go to just shut up and drive the
parts Unknown it's in our DNA but this
road has an end and the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid got in
store he
might one move Checkmate there's been
curves Hills corn and even a breakdown
or two the game is over that's a w we
see a reaction Magnus Magnus Mouse
slipped oh my gosh look at y's face some
have pulled over but some oh what is he
doing slammed that foot to the floor and
just kept going any second Nakamura is
the winner not a of Maxim vajra the
Frenchman he wins the AI cup after six
stops along the way it's time for the
greatest proven ground and online chess
to drop that final pin in the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove with the one true king of
online chess really is I think this is
the strongest final there's ever been I
know that it will not be easy it's nice
to play in top tournament Magnus will
want revenge it's my last tournament of
the year I'm a bit desperate to ended
well having the opportunity to play
against the best players in the world
it's always a challenge and I enjoy it
it's going to be a very close F it's
going to be very exciting live from
Toronto Canada this is the 2023
Champions chess tour finals and it
starts
[Music]
now
indeed we are live from Toronto Canada
once again what a beautiful wide shot of
this amazing City Toronto Canada has
become one of the capitals to the Chess
World over the last couple years and we
welcome you back in here where we've
been for the last couple years the
chess.com Global Championship now the
Champions chess tour final Danny rench
alongside James KY Levy Rosman looking
fresh over there in that suit and I
think I'm going to throw to you Levy but
because the Clos demand it you get to
have our opening thoughts here we sit
four players left four players went home
yesterday man that happened fast your
thoughts well that's the format right um
yeah I mean we've got some familiar
names in our semi-final which is going
to start today we've also got names like
nir Abdus satov who is familiar but also
very cool to see the 19-year-old on this
Grand stage has a chance to compete for
200,000 so I'm pumped guys I mean
yesterday was wild we almost had the
craziest comeback story and Hikaru but
unfortunately his journey was cut short
I'm pumped for today's games though are
you surprised that comeback story
stopped right there we know he's your
guy but really where we sit now how
surprised are you about that I am very
surprised in I mean you see him win
everything from title Tuesdays to Fisher
randoms to all qualifying for candidates
like he wins everything so when he
doesn't it's like what's going on like
is the sky red type thing right but I
mean it just tells you how strong the
field is especially in the order back or
abdor right now too yeah well you saw
hik Caro's thoughts too he felt that
given how he started where he ended
wasn't so bad and of course maybe he
just ran out of steam a little bit
obviously Notre Beck of duur off is the
name still here along with the big three
in Magnus Wesley and Fabby but okay we
could talk for a long time about what an
epic day it was yesterday it was 8 hours
of a broadcast but we tried to boil it
down for you in this roughly two-minute
highlight recap in case you missed
it everything was at stake for some
players in the final round of the round
robin for others the their fate was
already sealed Wesley so and Magnus
Carlson's performance had guaranteed
them the first and second spot
regardless of the rounds results Fabiano
kowana and notc Abdus satarov had
clinched spots in the survival stage
everyone else was playing for their life
Hikaru Nakamura won his match against
17-year-old Dennis lavic but his place
in the rest of the tournament was still
not guaranteed if Ali Rea fuja won his
match against Magnus Hikaru would no
longer qualify Ali Reza was on track to
do do just that starting with a win with
the black pieces the second game
simplified down to a rook and Bishop for
Magnus against a rook for Ali Reza with
seconds on the clock Ali Resa blundered
and allowed bangnus to set up a mating
net sending the match to Armageddon
white king could be in a mating
net [__] he's losing now he's in the net
he's in the net he walks right into the
net Bishop can even and they know it
they know it Magnus Carlson gets the job
done takes it to Armageddon with the
black pieces and 9 minutes on the clock
Ali RZA survived an up and down middle
game but eventually lost on time
hikaru's survival was all thanks to his
longtime rival Magnus squeaking by in
sixth place Hikaru faced off against
fifth place finisher mvl after the pair
traded wins with the white pieces their
Armageddon game was a wild one despite
missing a puzzle rushlike tactic Hikaru
simplified to an easy draw with the
black pieces winning the match and
staying alive he's pretty much
pre-moving at this point he knows he's
safe he gets the draw luris through
meanwhile Fabiano and Notre back played
for the right to a spot in the
semi-finals the loser to face hakaru for
the other spot just like the hikaro mvl
match the player with the white pieces
won in both games setting the stage once
again for Armageddon Notre back had a
great position out of the opening but
his Advantage withered away until a
blunder allowed Fabiano to play a
beautiful mating pattern Hikaru faced
off against Notre backck in the last
match of a long day at the office
relatively conservative chess led to two
draws and it was time for one more
Armageddon Notre Beck won the Black
pieces with an aggressive bid of 9
minutes 35 seconds the young former
World rapid Champion maintained his
composure through a complex game
managing his time well and leveraging
his draw odds playing all the way to
King versus King to win the match as the
top finisher of the round robin Wesley
so was given the choice of opponents in
the semi-final and he chose Notre backck
this means that Fabiana will face a
familiar foe in Magnus in the other
semi-final
it's hard not to feel heartbroken for
the players who were sent home it's hard
not to feel exhausted after watching
that recap video of what we know in live
fashion was was many many hours but
there you have it Guys Wesley so chose
Notre Becka duur off we're going to get
to that in a second but first that meant
Magnus Carlson is stuck quote unquote
air air quotes here against his longtime
rival Fabiano Carana and let's let's
Dive Right In There Levy and talk first
about Magnus Carlson and his thoughts
versus Fabiano Carana yeah this is a an
age-old matchup really since
2018 uh that was the only world
championship match where Magnus Carlson
could not beat his opponent in the
classical portion they played out 12
draws and that was also the only time it
was ever that close at the top of the
leaderboard In classical rating they
were about three or four rating points
apart only but this is rapid this is not
classical yeah and in Rapid chess Magnus
has had Fabiano's number that really is
the story and this is rapid we are not
playing classical Fabiano has had an
unbelievable year in classical it's
rapid now it's very different format for
the third time it's rapid how do you
build on that how do you build on your
classical your mindset going into rapid
here versus Magnus honestly I mean a lot
of times I'll ask the questions or to to
the players hey what do you need to do
like how do you get yourself as mindset
a lot of times they just say hey it's a
lot about consistency and experience
I've been here many times before
hopefully I can get a better chance
today even he Carlo says today I'm just
going to play a little bit chess if I
feel good I play good type thing and
that's exactly what F's going to have to
bring especially with these four games
he's going to have to play Magnus today
well we've talked about Magnus Carlson
dominance over his generation including
Fabiano Carana but let's talk about his
dominance as far as accuracy goes here
at the Champions chess tour final Levy
95% I would be shocked if he wasn't
ranked one on that list
uh obviously when you get into the tiny
details of Abdu satov at 91 versus
Karana at 90 it's all about the same but
we do have to remember Magnus does have
a tendency to play some provocative
chess and in his match against Fabiano
which was in the round robin stage
Magnus won that match not in the
Armageddon so he won that match in game
two when he played with the black pieces
played an offbeat opening got a very
provocative position and outmaneuvered
Fabiano so right now all advantages in
their head-to-head match today and
tomorrow point to Magnus yeah well and
as the players said and all agreed
hikaro made those comments first in his
sort of exit interview Wesley so doubl
down that the more games tends to mean
more Magnus and no one has dominated
highl chess more than Magnus Carlson
actually in the history of the game we
had some fun putting this together for
everyone here are the longest streaks
the longest uninterrupted streaks as
world number one in history you see him
there 1 2 3 4 or 4321 depending on how
you want to break it down that's right
we're in Toronto we're talking about the
Maple Leaves congrats on their win last
night by the way number four was Bobby
Fischer couple of Astros here guys they
didn't track this stat for very long
with Bobby fiser and then of course he
retired early so we should probably not
hold 54 months against him but an toldi
carpov coming in at number three Gary
Kasparov 117 months there and 96 months
that's two streets pretty that's pretty
crazy and then you've got Magnus Carlson
at 150 months as of this year of in
December he is the
Undisputed uh well if you go by ratings
and the thing we just put together there
he is the Undisputed uninterrupted Goat
as far as being the highest rated chess
player in the world um I don't think
those stats surprise you guys but what
you think about that when you see it
really in front of you 150 months as
world number one why why why' they do
that why didn't they just say like 1500
days that was like what are we we
measuring babies like my baby 28 months
old like 150 why can't we combine
Kasparov you know just like
well he had 200 total it actually really
when you see it that way Gary kasparov's
two streaks that's pretty crazy that is
pretty crazy there in fact I think about
it as like you know in the superhero
movies when like you got like Captain
America and you're like what does he
actually do he's a man he's super but
he's not really that super when you got
Superman on your team type thing right
so of course that being said that's a
lot of months but I mean Casper off
having two I mean that's that's real
close that was you know he he's kind of
like Tom Cruz in the second top gun
Maverick movie it's like he was number
one and retired then they went and got
him again have you seen the second Top
Gun movie yeah okay if not I'm spoiling
it for you was a good movie I think
that's a pretty good reference well it's
a great reference thank you Gary
Kasparov is Tom Cruz but all right we've
talked a lot about Magnus Carlson and
now Gary kasar let's talk about the
opponent here Levy you take it away go
let how does Fabiano Carana forget about
that 19 to8 decisive score head-to-head
record and come in here I don't think he
has to forget it cuz I don't think he
even knows uh remember we're the
commentators right we got to talk about
well it's 19 and8 with 15 DRS cuz we can
pull the stats from the internet these
guys don't know they know that obviously
Magnus has the head tohe head advantage
that's what they know they know it from
the world championship match in 2018
when Magnus won 3 nothing it was
convincing uh but even to this day he's
had an advantage he had an advantage in
this particular event winning with the
black pieces I think Fabiano is going to
have to see what kind of Magnus shows up
is Magnus going to be provocative with
his openings and provoke Fabiano into
fights considering it worked out well in
the round robin stage or is Magnus going
to sit back and let Fabiano come to him
we both know that we we know they're
stubborn they're both stubborn in their
world championship match they played the
same openings over and over and nobody
could break through so I'm really
curious to see what's going to happen
today provocative Magnus or solid Magnus
making Fabby bring a positional
long-term fight to him about to find out
yeah I think uh fabbi actually has a
more consistency and playing Magnus than
anyone else I mean played him 12
classical games there played him you
know uh however many rapid games 198
there right having all the games playing
there a lot of consistency and knowing
what Magnus likes what he doesn't like
doesn't mean that you know oh this is
what he is on paper this what we going
to do doesn't mean it's going to be
easier for you but at least he has a
little bit of more consistency and
experience facing Magnus so sometimes as
you said you know what kind of Magnus
shows up can definitely dictate how
Fabby plays today hopefully he's ready
for it I think it's a good point that we
talk about Fabby losing these matches
against Magnus he's also played a lot of
high stakes matches against Magnus he's
got to get credit for that it's it
wouldn't be a storyline otherwise but
all right it's time to move to the other
story line back to our bracket reminding
you that Wesley so he chose his opponent
he gave his reasoning it just doesn't
make sense to choose a world number one
or world number two no matter how
dangerous the young abduc turov might be
but let's head over to that matchup and
I want to start first with you KY
actually on the mindset of the youngster
getting chosen to play against wesle so
how how you dealing with that I'm hated
I'm like would you going to pick me now
of course you only had two one other
person to pick but at the same time you
take it personal and I'm taking it
personal all the way through I last lost
my first two matches then I made it
through and you going to pick me West
hly yeah you might be the top right now
but I'm going to beat you is what my
mindset is Levy your thoughts I agree
you have to choose one or two right it's
like when you're picking the teams in in
in kickball or dodgeball in school
you're going to pick the person you
think is going to serve your team better
in this case Wesley chose the person he
thinks has a higher chance of defeating
over two games of Rapid chess it's not
disrespect it's just the reality of the
situation very curious by the way had
hearu made it I know he's out like
who but I beat him tce somewhere in the
Multiverse that's happening right now
yes in in one other dimension but he's
not here so he picked no well okay so
why do you why does Wesley think he has
an advantage experience right he's he's
he's a decade older if not slightly more
right so he probably thinks he has
slightly better opening repertoire to
angle and kind of deviate and and things
of that nature so I don't know we'll
find out if he's right or wrong NRE
obviously going to come with a chip on
his shoulder try to prove Wesley
Incorrect and if nobe wins it'll be a
sensation and we also heard from Wesley
yesterday you made a great point the top
level chess is changing Wesley likes
Notre Beck he's like we're boys right we
just spent a bunch of time together in a
team event right and he didn't say too
much about what happened in their casual
Blitz Games maybe there's even more to
that right Wesley beat Notre Beck in the
round robin it did go to Armageddon but
he beat him right and maybe Wesley just
recency by us even just feels more
confident against Notre backck but all
right we're we're excited here and uh we
we are late to get to our our fourth
team member she's here Ka we know you're
out there in the hall somewhere tune in
with what you got for
us hey Danny yeah that's right you guys
in there where the action is happening
I'm out here in the lounge where the
relaxing is happening this is where the
players chill out in between games and
before games we just saw Fabiano Carana
first player to arrive here for the
semi-finals actually the only player so
far to arrive and I actually met Fabby
at breakfast today as well I can give
you some inside information he was
having eggs and bacon and also listen to
this he had both tea and coffee so he
will be energized today when he faces
Magnus Carlson who yesterday he was so
relaxed he didn't have a lot of pressure
on him yesterday so Magnus Carlson in
this Lounge was in such a good mood and
for the first time in my life following
Magnus craws around for nine years now I
heard him doing small talk not going to
reveal to who he was talking but he was
talking about the weather just loving
that the sun now is out in Toronto now
it's going to be a lot less packed here
today because obviously four players
left the tournament only four players
left Hikaru Nakamura has left the
premises so has Ali Resa Ruan no longer
in Canada but I hear rumors Maxim vajra
and Dennis lazovic are still here so
hopefully they will come down to hang
out with us today and I am keeping an
eye on this base because more players
might be coming in the big day the
semi-finals about to start
Denny it's fun to hear Magnus engaging
in small talk I was out there you also
see the pillow behind you K that's
that's Magnus pillow talk right there I
if you want to show that real quick that
was a white elephant gift that Ali Resa
fua snatched after our white elephant
video and then gave it to me on his way
out and someone drew a heart around it I
don't know who did that I love
it there you go that's Magnus Carlson
he'll be there on the couch all day
might be snuggling up with that later
when we get a little tired but all right
shocking ala did I said it's shocking
ala did not want to take that home to
it's shocking no he almost did but he
said he couldn't fit in his bag I don't
know if that was an excuse either way K
just went through the pleasant
experiences that the players are having
when they're chilling with us but the
next video we're going to throw right
before games get underway here in our
semi-finals is is something that maybe
goes into the unpleasant conversation of
fair play and we know that players don't
necessarily enjoy it but they've all
been super cooperative and embracing the
need for us to invest and take it
seriously and so I want to take everyone
through a behind the scenes tour to
answer the question can you really
secure over theboard chest tournaments
can you make sure that human play and
clean play is happening the answer is
yes and hopefully you enjoy this walk
through well hey everyone we're here at
the chess.com Champions chess tour
finals and of course Fair Play is a huge
topic for everyone around the world as
it should be including questions like
can you actually keep a venue secure can
you actually stop cheating even if it's
some of the most advanced spyware level
stuff out there the answer is yes you
can and where I just entered is where
the players enter they can go directly
to their rooms and back from here but
now we're going to walk through as if
we're a regular person this guy's gonna
say you don't belong here but okay Jokes
Aside all right now we're going to get
into the real stuff all right players
are brought down into this area before
games at a scheduled time so that they
have enough time to be fully checked for
fair play this right here is the private
Lounge area where only staff are allowed
to have Electronics the players are not
allowed to have any Electronics with
them once they've entered this area but
when they come early they do so because
they need plenty of time time to get
fully checked by our fair play Tech I'll
try to talk a little softer cuz they're
actually playing their games right now
but okay at some point here a player
will come over and they'll wait in this
line before being asked to enter the
private fairplace screening area once
we're in this private Fairplay screening
area the players wait only one player in
here at a time I'm standing here right
next to a sir who looks like he has a
fancy device what's your name sir my
name is George I work with the fair play
Department my job is to uh detect
cheaters is to find out if anyone is
trying to get a gadget that helps him
win the game that's not going to happen
on my watch not going to happen on his
watch okay all right this is a little
bit fancier than the normal kind of
thing you see an RF scanner what exactly
is this is this doing that's different
it's called a nonlinear Junction
detector its job is to detect any signal
signals transmitted from another device
outside or transmitted from a device
that is on a player who's trying to
cheat outside to a uh foreign sender it
can only be acquired from specific
countries it's not like a normal metal
detector that you just buy on eBay and
I'm going to add a little bit more to
that this device was actually
recommended to us specifically by a firm
that we hired to audit this entire
process this recommendation came to us
as a device that is capable of detecting
not just active signals being sent I.E
what rft scanners can do but also detect
signals that are sort of enclosed within
the device which would allow more
advanced spy to potentially communicate
on a person's body directly to them even
if there isn't a signal actively being
sent this device is capable of picking
it up I'm going to put this down we know
I'm full of Technology here I'm going to
hand this to a cameraman who you don't
know it's a microphone I guess I don't
even know why we're doing this I'm full
of the things that are going to get
detected I didn't actually hide anything
here which is good to know maybe I
should have but okay we're going to find
out we'll see that's right don't assume
anything it's pretty phenomenal stuff
thank you George this is pretty much
just a bunch of cameras for the show we
do have cameras everywhere so we're
watching The Players no matter what now
after they've been scanned they are not
allowed to leave this area like period
during active gameplay so you're talking
about an area that is maybe more secure
than any over theboard chess tournament
that has ever been secured that's what
you're talking about right let's say
they come out here again they're also
watch closely by staff the entire time
out here in addition to the cameras one
of those staff is this guy over here his
name is Greg we are also randomly
scanning not just this area George
George in there and Greg are also
scanning the bathroom on a regular basis
to pick up any type of device George is
making sure that anyone who would get
anything out here is being scanned by
this which would pick up all of the I
guess the more basic stuffs no other
obvious slips happen once they've been
fully detected by spyware and again we
are observing them every step of the way
and Greg's job is to make sure that if
anyone enters the bathroom or leaves the
area they are fully then re-entered with
security so that we keep keep them under
lock and key I guess if that's something
you can say that you're doing to a human
being without getting canceled so we're
keeping the players under lock and key
you can mark that down and I hope that
watching this video showed you what
we're doing I hope you appreciate it
it's some pretty high level stuff I
definitely am making a call to every
over theboard organizer to invest in
their own nonlinear Junction detection
devices cuz at this point if you're not
doing that you're not doing it good
enough and we hope that you will
consider investing in the same way the
chess.com has we
out
I didn't actually drop the microphone on
the floor I caught it with the other
hand that was off camera that's that's
movie Magic very Nimble I got a question
yeah I know we're going to have a show
here I know also we we're we're always
jovial entertaining I have a serious
question two serious questions number
one how much does large scale
anti-che device and capability and
catching like we have here how much does
that cost great question yeah George
said this off camera but it was it's not
available everywhere and depending on
where you get them and some of the
details between $4 to $60,000 for
something American to really put the
whole package together yeah so as we as
we grow all of this production we have
bigger events this becomes the norm as
we try to build chess into a media
product around the top players and
competitions like this we're going to
have to seriously invest in it which is
very difficult because there's over
theboard tournaments around the world
that are like actively losing money like
the organizers in a tournament somewhere
in Europe can't spend this amount of
money so and it's a problem we've never
chess's always operated on an honor
System and devices that we never thought
could actually assist you that we're
microscopic right so it's an issue no
but that that is the key to that device
is it's capable of picking up
microscopic things hidden in anywhere
anywhere in anywhere that would be but
all right we're getting set for chess we
see some of the players coming in here
Wesley's already chilling Notre backck
is pacing so we're going to throw it
across the pond and uh well you guys
watch the video David Robert and tell
you David I'm going to start with you we
are establishing that humans are playing
clean chess here have you ever felt more
human or or more clean well uh Danny
frankly I'd love to be accused it means
that I would be playing great chess
superhuman chess which some of the
players out there are capable of doing
uh but I just want to give you uh Kudos
there for doing everything possible not
just for ensuring everything's clean but
for ensuring there's zero paranoia
another thing we want to get rid uh of
from the game and I want to give a shout
out to Rita because I'm feeling extra
clean makeup hair everything so thank
you to Rita who's doing such hard work
behind the
scenes we love you Rita I know Rita
shout out to Rita but all right hey Rita
shout out to everyone shout out to you
guys we can't wait to hear your
commentary we'll be joining you at some
point in the middle of these games going
to be an epic day so Tanya we'll let you
take it from here take it away hey guys
well cheating has always been a concern
but I think now more than ever where
chess is where we are transparency and
fair play is more important than ever
and that was some really really cool
stuff that we saw and it's time to get
to some even more cool stuff as the
chess is about to begin it is is the day
it is day one of the semi-finals two big
clashes coming up two big fights coming
up what are you most looking forward to
from the players today everything we got
the semifinals we're down to our final
four people and with that being the case
Wesley so he's taking on notbe abusar
Fabiano Carana Magnus Carlson what is
the world championship no it's a
Champions chest tour finals but two
excellent matchups absolutely Wesley so
against nck nck made it very clear with
his win over over hiar Nakamura that he
is here to stay at Top Class chess it's
not a one day thing we're going to be
seeing the best of nbe for many many
years to come David yeah you don't knock
out Nakamura and not go on to have a
fantastic future in chess he's already
up there with the best mingling with the
best such a tender age but uh he's one
to watch he could be the Dark Horse only
four players left with a bit of luck if
he continues showing the aggression he's
uh displayed at this event he's
definitely capable it's going to be a
fun fight and of course the other big
one Magnus versus Fabby that is going to
be super exciting to watch and Ka caught
up with Fabby earlier today to check in
with his
mindset it's a big day semi-finals and
Fabiano Carana placed the semi-finals
against Magnus Carlson what should we
expect Fabby I think it will be a very
tough match for sure and um I I don't
know really what to expect I am ready to
play I'm just in a good mood to be here
to to be in the semi-finals it's already
been a you know a very tough tournament
and I I went through the gauntlet I
played uh all the players and it's so
far been going okay I had one bad day
but besides the second day I actually
won all my matches so if we don't count
out if I don't count the matches I lost
then I I'm doing very well you face him
so many times Magnus Carlson what seems
to be the key to be able to beat him in
a match well you have to play at a very
high quality it's uh I don't think that
there's any like Secret um know strategy
or anything he's uh he's a player who
plays very well almost always he of
course doesn't make mistakes like
everyone and uh that's that's the only
thing you just have to be at a playing
at a high level playing at your best to
be able to exploit those mistakes yes
yes and as you say the accuracy I think
he's at 95% here in the tour finals how
difficult is it to play against that oh
of course it's difficult I mean it's
nobody expected it would be easy to play
Magnus uh I have to say I didn't have
any easy matches here so it's not like I
wasn't without Challenge and uh some
matches do give me quite quite a bit of
confidence um for example well
especially yesterday I mean I felt like
I was in a good mood yesterday and
things went well despite maybe some
minor hiccups and um I feel like if I
play like I did yesterday then I'll have
a decent shot right well best of luck
today Fabby thank you thank you for
joining us fabbiano Carana against
Magnus Carlson today back to you
guys Fabby is ready to go and we are
ready with some odds for the clashes
that are coming up uh Robert what stands
out to you in this one I always say it
when Magnus Carlson plays he is the odds
on favorite this is proven True by this
chess.com stats team but that Wesley
narbeck match up 60% Wesley 40% ner
abatar will it be four out of 10 in this
match to send abatar of the young usbeck
Phenom to the finals 71 to 29 David to
me that feels a bit High yeah might feel
harsh on Fabiano kowana but it is based
on recent history even in this event
alone Magnus did defeat Fabiano in the
round robin so it's about Fabiano just
upping his game he needs to catch Magnus
on off day but he also has to bring his
best we have to trust the stats team we
do but when it comes to sports you can
take the numbers and throw them out of
the window because what matters is what
form the players show up in today and
one thing's been very clear that while
Magnus is Excellence himself Fabby has
been redefining Excellence all year
Fabby has been the player of 2023 In
classical chess and in their world
championship matchup it was 12 draws but
Magnus did take him down in Rapid
history it does speak and it has been
Magnus dominating their heads head
matchup and in just a few moments uh the
2018 World Championship Fighters will be
on the board fighting for that spot into
the finals of the Champions chesta and
it's handshakes it's go time the big
question
what is magnus's approach and he starts
with the kingspawn opening we haven't
seen seen him employ one E4 so often
during the finals yeah Magnus has been
mixing it up freestyling a bit but I can
remember so many clashes between these
two in E4 E5 it's the main line of the
Spanish the RO Lopez opening here and
Fabiano he's backing up his chess ofal
course Robert he did so much research he
put so much heart and soul into that
ches course and no this is not an
advertisement it's just knowing Fabiano
he trusts this opening weapon and he's
playing it against Magnus Carlson so
much talk in the opening stage when they
played in the world champion match was
about the Sicilian Defense the rasal Lio
but from the black side Fabiano he trust
this as a big weapon and Magnus seem
surprised and this early Bishop C5 this
development it's the archangels you
pointed it out it is the big course by
Fabby untestable and I was at the St
Louis rapid and Blitz calling the action
and Fabby had so many OPP OPP unities to
play this but he didn't and we asked him
why are you not playing your course and
at that moment Fabby was like you know
what everyone studied it I'm not ready
to employ it yet he chooses the most
important moment to go and it is an
important moment for these two players
as well nck versus Wesley go time what
are we expecting in this one I expect
serious business Wesley plays the Kings
pun opening but he also took his glasses
off after the handshake it's what Wesley
does I don't know what that ritual is
all about I need to see I use my glasses
for that but he puts them down kind of
getting into that boss mode and we have
another Spanish yeah all these top
players they have their own mannerisms
glasses down clearing the throat
business time a replica of the other
battle will we see another Archangel or
the dark Archangel as uh Fabby termed
his course Moment of Truth Bishop comes
out just one square so uh this one has
deviated from the other semi-final uh
but also a slower Spanish here with
Wesley so just pushing his one square to
D3 slow build up here all the pieces on
the board maximum tension tends to favor
Abdu satoro I would say as he showed
yesterday in many of his matches yeah
Nock always brings the fight but he does
have a solid style at his core He's just
never afraid to get into a mess and now
he strikes in the center and look at
Wesley doing the same this is getting
very concrete right now with all four
Pawns in the center staring at one
another and it's Notre on the clock he
can capture in either direction yeah
this is a big move from Wesley so it
shows he's been doing preparation as
well because until this last turn it was
the game Nakamura against Abdu satov
from yesterday so clearly Wesley while
he wasn't playing he was admiring uh the
action maybe watching our show Even and
he was studying he was preparing look
how he's landed as surprise Abdu satoro
clearly wasn't ready for this porn push
whether it's strong or not clearly there
will be some poison attached and the
youngster now has to deal with the shock
recover and then react and we're seeing
Fresh open ideas on both our semi-finals
match up they start in the same manner
with the kingspawn opening we see the
Spanish on the board with different
approaches by black uh in these ones
nbec opting for the bishop E7 while
Fabby sticks to his course of getting
the bishop to a more active Square
definitely tension on the board right
now tension in the center of the board
right now who blinks first what captures
are we expecting here the difficulty for
nirc right now is he may capture a pawn
and Wesley probably will not recapture
on that square so for nordbeck there are
actually quite a lot of tactics to work
through and I have to say Wesley so has
changed his style in Toronto typically
he's considered very solid playing for
small positional pluses he's bringing
the fight to NC and he doesn't actually
capture a pawn I actually believe Bishop
G4 is the best move he's saying Wesley
now it's your turn what capture are you
going to make wow and Wesley shielding
his face from the camera shielding it
from his opponent he just pushes a pawn
to H3 so much tension in the center it's
very rare to see all four Pawns in the
middle of the board staring off at each
other like this without either side
clarifying the situation and now again
big moment for uh black right now he
needs to decide what to do with his
light squar Bishop trade off for a
knight which you don't normally want to
do or Retreat uh the one thing in favor
of trading off right now is that it does
gain time for black black would then be
the first to trade off Pawns in the
center but it's definitely a clash of
home cooking of Home preparation here
one major downside I would say of
trading that Bishop for the night is
this position about to open up and in
open positions we prefer Bishops
overnight so n he knows that he's got
the principles down but he now has to
calculate concretely because if he does
slide his Bishop back there's the
possibility for Wesley to push Pawns in
front of his King to break a pin it
could get really wild on that side of
the board at the minimum nbec has to
consider that concrete calculation
moment here for nbec Abdu satra and it
might be a good moment to actually do a
little Deep dive as well David because
there are these options which allow
white to capture the pawn if black was
to move back with the bishop we can
express we can expect some aggressive
play from White on the king side taking
the Knight is never a happy choice to
part with the bishop beir as well uh a
big moment and we do see nbec going into
quite a think right now it requires it
yeah critical moment and uh I did uh for
a moment see Abdus satarov give the
trademark death stair to Wesley maybe
just trying to read uh his mind there
trying to figure out how deep the
preparation goes normally when you're
shocked like this you smell a rat and
you try to dodge your opponent's
preparation but the problem is when it's
this concrete this forcing uh you have
to enter a really concrete quite a
linear variation here and you ask for a
deep dive Tanya maybe it's time to do
that let's check out what to do he
Retreats his Bishop one of uh I think
the most logical options the desirable
option and O wow aggression from Wesley
so and Wesley's doing this so quickly
that he must be in his preparation
because you don't throw p in front of
your king forward unless you know what
you're doing it creates air in front of
your king vulnerable squares pawns and
squares left behind but look at how
concrete he's getting we are about to
see some Liquidation in the center but
the EVR slightly prefers white at this
stage although the E4 Pawn's about to
drop and it does drop I must admit this
is scary stuff this is risky stuff from
Wesley so but clearly he's analyzed it
with uh engines and again a big decision
a dilemma for black to take with the
porn sorry my arrows are messed up here
to take with the porn or to take with
the bishop normally you want to get as
many pieces off the board as possible if
you want to play for safety but then you
look at the white king and you realize
it is a bit open so maybe taking back
with a pawn would be my choice the most
natural and he goes for it uh really
really interesting preparation here from
Wesley so he's banking on the fact that
his uh kind of Target here on e4 is just
stuck Behind Enemy Lines and he might be
able to pick it off in the near future I
think the black Pawn on e4 weaker than
its counterpart the white Pawn on E5
right now and wy's got a decision to
make now does he trade the Queens does
he sidestep with his own Queen putting
pressure on the black E4 Pawn that
you're talking about Queen E2 would be a
move that comes to mind here n back also
eyeing the D5 Square for his own Queen
if White's Queen was to Sid step
defending his Pawn not just that also
putting pressure on Whit spawn on E5 we
will keep an eye out in this one whether
Wesley decides to go for an endgame or
keep the tension on but let's head over
to Magnus Carlson versus Fabiano Carana
and this started with fabby's opening of
the archangels and I have no doubt that
Magnus has looked at that course he
probably has but I'm looking at his
clock he's the one investing more time
is that because he trusts Fabby knowing
that he is perhaps the world's leading
expert in this opening that must be a
part of it but I'm looking at this
position and it's completely different
from the other game not a single piece
not even a pawn has been traded at this
stage and for Fabby he knows the main
ideas and I think one of those is to
push Pawns in the center and it's not
the D Pawn it's not the E Pawn but the C
Pawn as a standard in the Spanish you
might move your knight out to the rim to
attack the light Square bishop and then
push your C Pawn but wow he makes this
kind of quiet Rook move that catches me
off guard but I have to say I trust
Fabby even if I don't understand it he
probably does yeah he is the expert U as
uh I think 43 hours plus of uh video
footage on chessable uh confirms on this
opening
right now uh Magnus has the pawn Center
visually I like his position but what
next is again this standoff in the
center and I should mention there's
history between these two in this exact
opening they faced off in the Isle of
Man in this opening before uh with some
crazy uh tactics there a bit later on um
it's just the two foremost experts on
the Spanish opening right now facing off
against each other we're guaranteed to
learn uh especially from the next few
moves yeah absolutely going to be a
masterclass in these structures in
opening and this mysterious move this uh
shift of The Rook from the e file to B8
is sort of preemptive of Black's further
expansion on the queen side eventually
what black wants to do is start pushing
that a pawn down the board somewhere in
the future maybe the Knight moves
forward to A5 and the C pawn moves ahead
as well eventually trying to break on
the queen side and when that happens you
want your Rook on the open Line you want
it on the B line so even though right
now it looks a little mysterious it
starts making a lot of sense once those
pawns moves forward yeah Magnus is
playing playing a bit of a waiting game
himself because in a previous game
against Fabiano I'm pretty sure he
pushed that Aon instead of the A3 to A4
earli on and even got it to A5 um if I'm
remember correctly or actually maybe
that was Fabby with the white pieces
against Magnus am I have my colors
revers right now David I think you're
right Robert either way we have memories
we have very fun memories of that
dramatic game from is of man I believe
it was
2018 uh a long long time ago but uh the
one thing that's surprising me is that
Magnus has spend a lot of time on the
clock Magnus has spent more than 5
minutes as Tanya's plan uh on the board
now black throwing pawns forward on the
queen side uh so Magnus has burned this
time but it was predictable this opening
after all you know what your opponent's
famous for you research your opponent's
games he would have known I mean
chessable it's a tool that all the top
players use these days he would have
known that Fabiano has produced this
course spent months and months
researching it and then to not have
prepared deeply in this uh relatively
predictable position a bit of bit of a
surprise to me I must say and while you
were talking I did verify it was Fabiano
on the white side of that game against
Magnus Carlson Magnus won with black it
was Island Man 2017 so our memories they
were a bit hazy but we're in the general
direction and look at that Aon it's
Black's Aon going up to A4 T you were
advocating for white doing this it looks
like Fabby got there first no I love it
I love this because now the knight from
C6 can actually find itself on the
Square that has been vacated and the C
Pawn would have moved forward but right
now Magnus putting pressure and what
you're talking about these opening
Dynamics expecting the predictable line
which your opponent has taken out of
course on maybe it's some sort of a meta
situation here where Magnus feels that
it's too predictable for Fabby to play
this so you know what he's not going to
play it at all in all these mind games
this is true normally when players
publish books or publish video courses
on an opening they stop playing the
opening because they know everyone has
access to their notes their files their
knowledge uh so they think okay I'm
going to make a quick Buck from uh
producing kind of publishing everything
and then I'm going to turn away and
learn something new but not Fabby he's
loyal to uh his beloved Archangel here
and before publishing the course Fabby
played thousands and thousands of games
and this is the point that I was making
earlier the St Louis rapid and Blitz
which he won he never employed the
archangels and then he comes for the
most important match against the world
number one and finally plays this
opening doesn't that show that he really
believes in it because if he's saving it
for some of the biggest moments in his
career like playing against Magnus
Carlson and if any of these players make
it to the finals minimum $100,000 prize
going into their bank account so Fabby
he trust this weapon and he actually
just did something very clever he
defended his pawn it doesn't look like
it but tactics allow him defend this B5
Pawn White's light score Bishop went to
attack it Bishop D7 says once piece is
clear the diagonal and the B file if you
take that pawn I'm actually going to
gather back my material and be a happy
camper yeah you can tell the expertise
that Fabiano has here just the calmness
as well he's displaying and frustrating
for Magnus Carson a lot of maneuvering
right now a lot of time burnt on the
clock he needs to decide when to change
the pace when to declare his intentions
in the center it just feels to KY right
now and Fabiano's in his comfort zone
for black that is a psychological
Victory and Magnus Carlson needs to be
energetic right now he has to take some
critical decisions either on the queen
side or try and put pressure on the
center because it just feels that Fab's
next moves are easy to make if if white
was to make a waiting move well this one
attacks the B5 Pawn but I see it still
might be possible I was going to say
that black just wants to jump with that
knight from C6 to A5 that's really the
dream not only eyeing the light square
holes the weaknesses in the position on
the queen side but what you really want
is to get the C Pawn up the board you
want to play C5 to force a decision in
the center it's a wonderful position
where it looks like white is
overpowering Black's extended pawns on
the queen side but black continues to
defend tactic I love your knight jump to
the rim it's not looking dim it's
actually looking quite intelligent here
because black has carved out important
space and controll of key squares over
on that flank so jumping the Knight to
the rim here seems smart you are
protecting the B5 Pawn First with your
light Square bishop and that Rook on B8
once pieces land on B5 it's staring
through the dark Square Bishop that
Bishop May sacrifice itself in order to
win a piece that lands on B5 so Magnus
Fabby they have to calculate what is
happening with all those pieces staring
at that vulnerable Pawn on B5 I'm going
to put you both on the spot who would
you prefer here and why all pieces still
on the board still very tense I actually
played these positions from black and I
quite like them actually I really like
the expansion on the queen side uh I
agree Robert I don't think black needs
to pause to try and defend the B5 Pawn
With The Rook I think Knight A5 would be
the first move on my radar I'm picking
black here I also like Black's position
but I like his time more I like the way
that fabbi seems to be in Rhythm and
Magnus is the one not just because of
how he's holding his head at times and
uh just moving about in his chair I do
feel like Fabby he really trust his
position I don't want to read the body
language but just he feels sturdy just
by position by look and I think that he
is the one who Tred out his main
repertoire what about you David uh I'll
go white just to be different after all
Magnus has built a career on the white
side of the Roy Lopez the Spanish this
is pretty much how he rose through the
ranks and uh won some World
Championships against Anand based on his
expertise on the Spanish uh so despite
the fact I'm surprised Magnus has
invested so much time in uh what could
have been a position that he'd studied
beforehand um yeah I'll still choose
white I believe in the pawn Center all
right well so far in the balance but
Magnus with his messy hair expecting a
messy position in just a few moves uh
right now this one a lot more clarified
in the senta and Wesley did take the
decision to sidestep the queen trade
moves with the queen putting pressure on
the E4 Pawn not much has happened David
since we left it last uh and it's going
to be a fight about who get to those
Central pawns first yeah uh the big
question is why is Wesley so thinking
over 4 minutes on this last move it must
be because he's finally out of
preparation and uh his opening notes
there must have run out so Abdu sator of
huge relief for him as black that he's
finally sidest stepped uh this kind of
bullet that was heading for him with
opening prep and uh I see some forcing
lines from it maybe we can check them
out yeah because it you look at the E4
Pawn think that's the most vulnerable
but a move like Rook e one making your
intentions very clear I think black
responds with Pawn to F5 temporarily
defending the pawn on e4 and if you take
aasan oh Oh no you're opening up the f
file I can take back on F6 and your F2
Square it's really vulnerable and black
pieces are Super Active yeah and uh okay
I thought I heard a clock I think that
might have been in the other board but
uh right now I'm also wondering Rook to
D4 F5 might be the answer anyway uh just
you cannot allow this Pawn to drop for
no compensation so why not open lines
this is after all where the white king
uh is weakest this is the main
compensation and yeah Black's Bishops
look far superior to their counterparts
right now far more active and because
you guys have pointed out Black's idea
to go F5 try and open up the F line and
Target White's King the G4 Pawn using
that as a hook can black uh can white
try to get prophylactic about it try to
stop it with that Bishop from C2 going
back to where it came from and uh not
just that I want to get Bishop D5 if
you're a little careless yeah I really
like that idea Tanya a really nasty
threat and you stop the opponent's main
idea psychologically again really uh
really nice move I guess black would be
obliged to prevent your threat of Bishop
into D5 the one downside I guess would
be that this Pawn is no longer Under
Fire but uh maybe this is the best way
to at least stop an attack against the
white king if F5 is not possible then
White's King is a bit safer he instead
decides to plant his Bishop on F4 so
still maneuvering for now still in the
balance and uh we'll check back a bit
later and we are going toh check in with
our other board as this one is slow to
develop both players very symmetrical
position and there are these small small
edges about trying to get a Tempo in to
the attack to that Central pawns and
before we Deep dive into this one I
think Dany has been missing uh he's been
getting some formo about the action the
chess action and we're going to check in
with him Dany what do you think about
the positions and this opening approach
by Fabby playing the arang
archangels I love the approach by Fab
and the Archangel we know he knows these
positions incredibly well he's
comfortable I think you can see it and
not just cuz sometimes we read the
player's body language uh but I think he
I think he knows exactly what he's doing
in these positions he's right at home
and uh the eval bar of course says we're
still at a 50/50 position and of course
we are but I'm with David and Robert if
I was interpreting their commentary uh
correctly that I think this is a really
good start especially with the black
pieces for for
Carana absolutely and uh he definitely
understands and knows these positions
I've also been looking at Magnus uh
Danny he's been wearing the same hoodie
sweatshirt shirt whatever it is since
day one what's going on uh with that uh
also looking really sleepy and messy
hair do you think he managed to freshen
up before the game or he just woke up
like he usually
does I think the Bed Head uh speaks for
itself I guess sometimes the chest
speaks for itself I think the Bed Head
speaks for itself in terms of how
quickly Magnus got down here we know he
had a he had a good time last night
hanging out with some of his friends
here in in Toronto I don't know what
they got up to uh but he was on stream
there for a little bit but either way I
know Magnus changed into the green shirt
at some point so I'm not I'm not going
to read too much into the to the
lifestyle at this point I think we're
still pretty early on um but I think
most importantly for Fabiano is is his
uh his clock management also speaks to
his comfort and and yeah so um I don't I
don't know I mean I'm I'm kind of
waiting to see what develops here
because I look at those odds that we
have on screen a lot of the top players
even said they thought that Magnus might
be a 70% odds favorite before uh the the
semi-finals back in the round robin
stage but if he loses a single game here
especially with the white pieces I I
think uh I think things could change
pretty quickly there as far as our stats
go and Danny if I remember correctly
Fabby was out by you when he was filming
his chessable cor so this position is a
bit deep down the line but how confident
is Fabiano in that repertoire he's
playing as the world champion but do you
have any Insider knowledge about his
preparation and his feeling about this
opening yeah we talked about it every
single day actually um he was spending
long hours in the studio where people
often see me and you Robert there in our
in our headquarters but he was filming
and he said one how much he
underestimated the the difficulty of
building a chessable course because he
put so much information down but he also
said how much he appreciated reviewing
it and you see how quickly he's playing
he's equalized easily and again don't
bet against Magnus this is a 50-50
position but yeah as far as as Fabiano
goes if Magnus is going to be willing to
go into the Archangel you probably
couldn't choose an opening that is more
fresh in carvana's brain right
now absolutely Danny and uh before we
let you go you mentioned Magnus has got
some friends that have arrived at the
venue and I have to ask you because
we've got a lot of foro sitting here in
Oslo uh Eric Aman are the chess bras in
the
house well Eric and Aman were at their
house last night and that's where Magnus
went and visited them again probably
someone can find find Clips on the
internet but yeah Eric and Aman are
around um I'll actually be be catching
up with them tonight I don't want to
spoil any other plans I don't want to I
don't want to dox anybody as far as
things that they're going to be doing
but I will say that they will be at the
fan zone of course on Friday and
Saturday unfortunately for anyone
hearing of that for the first time uh
it's completely sold out so um you may
try to show up at the door and try to
get in I wouldn't blame you um chess is
a pretty hot ticket these days but you
will be turned away most likely unless
people don't show up and uh and yeah
we've uh we're we're looking forward to
it so oh I like this view look at that
we got two boards going sorry I just got
really excited here in Toronto I love
what I'm
seeing yeah that's uh that's a really
really cool shot that we've got Danny
thanks a lot we'll be checking in with
you later and there are some very cool
decisions on the board we see on the
left side Magnus going all out in the
center with that move E5 definitely will
need the Deep dive and meanwhile on the
right side we've got Wesley updates with
Rooks being challenged on the D line
yeah I must agree with Danny I love this
angle all of the action all packed onto
one screen and uh yeah a bit of symmetry
here with both uh games having white
pawns on E5 very far Advanced Magnus on
the left board going for it now with
this last move finally pushing forward
trying to attack in the center things
heating up there as the clocks are
completely level on the right board I'm
looking at the Times Wesley so's only
got four minutes left ticking under four
minutes even still very symmetrical and
uh it feels like Abdu satoro might start
becoming a favorite if that uh momentum
continues I'm looking at the clock I'm
looking at the position on the right
hand side and Wesley starts to trade off
pieces and he's trading off all the
Rooks you see on the right hand board
Wesley so traded one pair goes the open
file with the second and nir can't be
unhappy about that meanwhile on the left
hand side we see Magnus and Fabby
they're making some quick moves because
Magnus took a KN with his Bishop to ruin
Fab's kingside Pawn structure then drops
his own Knight in the center that Knight
is getting very active on the left board
on your screen here so the time's about
even on the left hand side but the
position is quite messy yeah the
position is messy and uh actually two
very different types of position one
heading straight for the end game uh
that's the right board left board it's
going to be chaos I think Magnus he's
pressed that button now he is ready to
start fighting and big questions asked
of Fabiano the evaluation Bar says level
but suddenly the margin for error is
Tiny both players need to show accuracy
just to hold the balance and uh wow I
don't even know where the advantage lies
on either side
both of these kind of matches right now
just displaying top top quality chess
everyone on form at this stage and look
at that Rook that nck has just flaunted
on D3 He says you want to trade sure but
you trade on my terms because if you
capture on D3 that gives nck a really
really strong pass Pawn with the pawn
and uh we will wait for Wesley's
decision but big decisions to be made by
Magnus Carlson right now as Fabiano on
that left side of the screen has just
hinted at a potential
sacrifice on F3 Rook takes Knight always
in the air meanwhile the D6 Pawn is
hanging I was expecting this to get
messy but not this quick yeah just
within the space of two or three moves
when we had Danny with us uh it looked
like Fabiano was in full control no
problems at all now suddenly it is pure
chaos and I think we have to dive deep
as the players now tick down to the
4-minute mark Black's last move was Rook
to f8 I just want to recap that last
three move flurry it was here with
everything roughly balanced Magnus
decided to motor forward with his Pawn
if this Pawn was captured then he would
flick in the move he actually played in
the game removing this Knight before
then taking a pawn in the center either
with his Knight or with a pawn instead
Fabiano said okay I don't want to allow
you to get active I'm going to plant a
strong Knight in the middle and uh after
this capture White's Knight coming
forward I am shocked that Fabiano had
the calmness the incredible calmness to
ignore this porn's attack and Magnus
says I'm calling your bluff Rook to f8
hints at the sacrifice that Tanya
mentioned Magnus just takes a pawn and
now White's King is about to be blown
open take that Knight sacrifice The
Exchange right now because if the Rook
takes Knight Pawn takes Rook Queen out
to H4 The Rook on B8 will about to swing
to f8 hit the F3 Pawn the H3 Pawn's
under attack there are so many black
pieces heading in the direction of the
white king so I don't know what Magnus
sees here but it's looking very scary
for his King I think Magnus sees Fab's
clock because this means that Fabi has
to make some critical decisions and he
starts with the sacrifice but the evalar
say it's the wrong one wow this is a
very human approach not yet investing so
much material not giving up the exchange
like we were advocating I think it was
pretty much a two forked Road there and
he went for the other option now Rook
takes Knight is a threat because the
bishop is actually pinning a pawn to the
Queen the idea is that this porn on G2 I
was going to say was overloaded now the
black Bishop has dropped but so is the
White Knight and now he has a dilemma
The Rook is attacked this Pawn is
attacked Fabiano needs to justify his
recent decision this is really getting
can he sack they exchanged a second time
now Rook takes Bishop because if Pawn
takes the Knight hops in there forking
the queen and the Rook this is getting
extremely sharp thin margins for both
players I think unfortunately for
Fabiano his position is a little bit
more precarious he actually takes on E3
with the Knight and the eal bar is going
up even more it loves mag's position he
was able to push that pawn E5 open the
board up and his pieces have been
flowing yeah just compare compare this
white knight a beautiful stallion there
to this black Bishop on the edge of the
board which isn't really part
participating Magnus has it again two
Choice uh position right now take the
brook take the Knight which one are you
going to capture maybe taking the Knight
because this black Rook could well find
itself trapped a bit later on and uh I
mean this is still a crazy position
White's King is slightly Airy here I've
got a favor white just because of the
beautiful night but still anyone's game
and that G6 Pawn always hanging Magnus
Carlson with the committal decision the
Knight takes Pawn giving Fabiano a big
opportunity missed by Fabby and now
looks like Magnus is in a driver's seat
but he goes for a different approach
instead of capturing on E1 he gives The
Rook back Still Loving that Knight on D6
threats with the queen penetrating on F7
C6 Pawn is hanging right now still
trouble for Fabby if you put that white
Pawn on the G file I think fabbi is
pretty much lost but considering the
white king is open that is going to give
fabbi sufficient counterplay I'm looking
the clocks Faby a little bit ahead but
it's about to be even on time I think
it's anyone's game at this point the 96
that's a stallion it's beautiful up in
there but the white king it is exposed
the D4 pawns on a dark square and a
black pie is a queen on H4 Rook on f8
things of that nature there could be a
Counterattack yeah and sooner or later
at least the Knight is on a dark Square
so you will be able to remove it Fabiano
he needs to be accurate it feels like
black is the one trying to save this
game Magnus is the one trying to make
things happen meanwhile still in the
balance but uh yeah Fabiano needs to
play quickly and accurately to hold that
equilibrium and that's one of the
hardest things to do in chess to be fast
and precise in a chaotic position like
the one that we have in front of us and
this is the approach that has to be
there right to get the wins in where you
might not be playing objectively the
best moves but posing the biggest
practical questions to your opponent
giving them the opportunity to go wrong
and honestly that's a great description
of what's happening in the other game as
well where no deir beaar we see the eval
bar on the bottom right hand side of the
screen better for him all of a sudden it
was a position earlier on where we were
talking about like Wesley he's playing
really quickly that pawn for black was
loose Nock has allowed Wesley to go
wrong doesn't happen very often but he
is better in that game yeah they're in
the end game over there and we all know
nock's skill his expertise in the end
game meanwhile this one Fabiano does
immediately drop back with his Bishop to
challenge that stallion the White Knight
on D6 on that Outpost it is giving up a
pawn but he's saying who cares that
black C6 Pawn is weak anyway if White's
Queen goes and captures it it's more
important more urgent to get rid of the
Knight I think a very good practical
decision especially with clocks ticking
down Black's King I should mention has a
nice safe hiding spot on H7 wh's King
going to be out in the open for the rest
of the
game very very interesting uh chess
being played here combative play by both
Fabby and Magnus Magnus does take the
pawn on C6 Fabby will get rid of that
stallion on D6 if Magnus was to
recapture and with the queen and trade
the Queens off I think that would just
end in a draw with Black's Rook sliding
onto d8 and picking up that pass Pawn if
Magnus wants more he has has to
recapture with the pawn is he thinking
of throwing in a check and does that
check really achieve anything in The
Possession yeah the only good thing I
see about giving a check right now for
white is that if the White Queen slides
back to D5 check and then next move
wherever the black king goes takes the
bishop with the pawn then White's Queen
on D5 actually stops the black queen
from jumping out with checks herself so
he does throw in uh that move as you
predicted Tanya uh really nice spot
there and suddenly Fabiano has an issue
he has to deal with those two uh kind of
past white Depot
one of them is weak luckily and he will
shortly go for it with the black Rook if
Magnus can maintain the dewn he'll win
if not it should still be a draw and the
H3 Pawn also Under Fire right now but
Fab's big idea is to slide that Rook to
d8 double down look at the traffic jam
as you like to call it on the defil
Robert does white have enough time to
activate his own rook in the position
with the open E line I'm not a traffic
cop but I do think I'm going to clear
traffic on the defile you're going to
take that pawn on D6 we might see some
trades and there will not be too many
pieces remaining the problem for white
is yes you can free up your own Rook but
that H3 Pawn is loose as well and there
may be a series of checks that the white
king cannot Escape it won't be a
Checkmate necessarily but we could see a
draw by endless checks and so the black
queen perfectly placed in front of a
pass Pawn Rook joining the party I just
don't see it for Magnus and he's down to
40 seconds he's under that at the moment
he plays King G2 he's giving up the D6
Pawn without that pawn I don't see any
woodney chances whatsoever for white but
black may have some yeah look at this
last move IO chooses the correct Square
for his Rook I actually think black
should be keeping the Queens on the
board so bringing the Rook to d8 would
have been fine too but would have led to
a potential Queen trade Magnus is so
strong in these end games Magnus has the
pass pawns who has the safer King it's
black so keeping Queens on gives you
attacking uh potential longterm and I do
remember Fabiano uh didn't he win a game
against alera fua with a very similar
Dynamic just the heavy pieces the major
pieces queens and Rooks where the
opponent had a pass D Pawn but the
opponent also had a weak King he won
that one with black in similar
circumstances he did and this one that's
why Magnus is trying to use his pass
Pawn saying that black can't go all in
for an attack that D Pawn is a passer
hard to stop so I think black needs to
plant his own forces on that D6 square
and I don't think there will be any
progress for either side yeah looking
very balanced now it feels like black
found all the accurate moves maybe black
can put some pressure on but ultimately
this last turn by Magnus Rook lift as we
like to say uh showing off with these
Rooks now he does have one guard of the
king white can always slide across on
the third rank to block if necessary act
as a bodyguard this one should be a draw
due to the reduced material the only uh
chance for Magnus here is to try to get
the Deep on moving but for that you need
the queen to assist it from that Central
E5 square but whenever you plant it
there fabby's Rook will find activity on
the fifth rank with a Tempo so very
difficult to imagine either side making
progress here now though Queen E5 is a
possibility making sure that blacks Rook
gets tied down and it is on the board uh
if Faby was to move that Rook now the
dwn moves forward and there's a lot
happening on the right side of the board
as the players are down to seconds yeah
Wesley so against Abdu satov black is a
pawn up black has four versus two on the
king side white has two versus one on
the queen side but yeah just a bit of
basic arithmetic and Abdu sator surely
is the only one with winning chances
Wesley so maybe one of the players of
the tournament so far fighting for his
life and abars up almost a minute on the
clock on the right hand side of your
screen on the left hand side Magnus
Carlson down to 9 seconds Fabiano with
35 he's putting pressure on Magnus on
the clock in more of the board oh my
gosh Magnus has to move Magnus really
cutting it fine he needs to just escape
this game he needs to try and bail out
with a draw he's trying to repeat right
now second time we've seen this position
can Fabiano create winning chances
hustle Magnus on the clock and there was
in the round robin where Fabiano did
decline the repetition and went on to
lose the that game with the white pieces
he for the second time in the Champions
chest off finals declines a repetition
against Magnus Magnus pokes his King out
of its hiding place there pokes it out
staring uh down in the center and okay
Fabiano dancing around with his Queen
and look at the line of uh the totem
pole on the defile right now Black's
Queen is doing a great dance coming all
the way around but White's King is
seeking shelter on the queen side what a
journey what an adventure and if we look
at the board on the left hand side all
of magnus's pieces are protected kid he
made sure that if you take this Pawn F3
I'm going to get the pass Pawn so Fabby
is stuck playing a waiting game
preventing that D5 Pawn on the left hand
side of your screen from advancing he
places his Queen he blockades it but
Magna is doing an amazing job getting
his own King to safety so now it's not
like the white King's in danger but
great active play from Fabiano these
players are so strong Magnus how did he
imagine that how did he find that
creative idea but Fabiano is trying to
blow open the new shelter of the white
king it's getting really dramatic on
that left board uh Wesley so meanwhile
still in a bit of trouble against adoro
but still within the Realms of safety uh
on the other semi-final
clash it's hard to predict what do we
think is going to happen will we see a
winner in one of the semi-finals I'm
just amazed to watch the King march by
Magnus Carlson and then Fabiano kaana
striking on that side of the board not
wasting any time to get to it and he's
also eyeing a potential awn push at some
moment and I see Robert that something
catches your attention yeah that a pawn
push for Fabiano but both players down
near 10 seconds and that one the right
hand ins side the advantage is going for
black no near back up dusara in that
Bishop me up the pawn like David said
but yeah I have to be focused on Magnus
Carlson's King he goes after Fab's King
Fabby says no so whose pawns are weaker
whose King is safer it's the ultimate
question yeah it feels like magnus's
King has been in trouble for so long but
no way through uh the moves are coming
thick and fast on both boards right now
can you go a valuation bars dropped
Fabiano is he winning oh my God the
black Rook can land on the second rank
oh Rook F2 it's a good start but that
Queen on C3 it covers all the bases wow
it feels like there's tactics in the air
Magnus offering a trade of queens now
Fabiano will say no look at that white
king it's naked all on its own wow
coming in and behind can he take another
pawn and get some passage of his own but
that D Pawn will start que for a check
it's a deadly threat well Fabiano's now
two pawns to the good surely he's going
to turn this material advantage into
Victory and if he does start pushing the
pawn there was a threat of A3 and
finally it does arrive on the or
offering a queen trade he will reject it
because it's all about getting to
magnus's King right now so he gives away
a pawn to open the F on the left hand
side of your screen the white king is
lacking shelter so mag is doing
everything he can to put his pieces in
front of it but Fab is going after the
D5 pawn and he's got passers of his own
at some point Fabian can start pushing
his pawns but some nervous moves from
both players real nerves now showing
Fabiano giving a check with the black
Rook the problem is Black's pawns act as
shelter he doesn't really want to push
them until necessary but big threat the
black Rook threat to go to F3 with a
nasty pin on the White Queen all the
checks look at that white king though
just too be no protection around it
Fabiano needs to pounce needs to win
this game he's outplayed Magnus whoa and
there's a check on B2 is that uh super
dangerous for white king forcing it on
the a file so the king can run the
question is can it hide and it's hiding
in front of that pawn on B4 on the left
hand side of your screen you see
magnus's King there aren't too many
pieces remaining he's out in the open
can that de Pawn suddenly become a queen
is Magnus actually the one with the
upper hand it's really possibly turning
around right now all three results
possible a few checks the position
repeating itself will Fabiano bail out
with a draw this position's been seen
already if he keeps checking the white
king he wants more he wants more he's
playing for the win no safe squares for
magnus's King you have to go onto the C
file you have to step forward you have
to run forward with the white king but I
think it's losing you go up to C7 and go
daging the black queen steps up one
square to A7 with check and I think he
an a mating net The Rook will slide over
the end I think that Magnus is about to
get checkmated and Magnus he slows down
but he's got six 6 seconds to decide now
The Rook can go onto the SE file and win
the queen he gives up his Queen Magnus
Caron surely Fabian is going to take it
but look at the white Pawn the remaining
white Pawn is so far Advanced still not
over yet Magnus has lost his Queen but
he's still fighting he's fighting
because it's all relying on these two
pawns moving ahead and Fabiano caran on
seconds can he convert this with Just 4
seconds on the clock I think he made
those quick moves to gain the reminder
to everybody 3 seconds added every
single move you make so a quick check go
block that pawn and then push your own
pawns Fabby can win this game even if he
loses Queen for those two pawns then he
can push the Pawns of his own a rook
can't stop but he give away with check
wow he just blundered the pawn with
check he should have pushed the other
one the G Pawn wrong choice there and
Magnus is alive look at those white
pawns paralyzing the black queen and
this can be scary for black because now
the queen can't move anywhere with the
check without allowing the Deon to
promote and Magnus is does he have have
enough to hold this well the problem for
Magnus is that g Pawn will be a decoy
it's about to sacrifice itself The Rook
on D3 can't move because in the D7 Pawn
in front of the queen will be captured
both sides they're struggling a bit here
F doesn't know where to go but now it's
winning for Magnus he brings his Rook
all the way down Rook it he chooses the
wrong Square he trapped his own Queen
and it's handshakes Magnus Carson does
the unbelievable he wins down a queen
wow miracles do happen that was crazy
stuff and we will break it down in more
detail later Magus Carlson on the brink
of defeat turns it around and wins
unbelievable turn around Fabiano
completely outplayed Magnus Carlson but
by fa's own words Magnus is so resilient
that you may get a winning position but
actually securing the full point super
difficult and he can't believe it
himself without that headshake what a
finish that was but we've got to quickly
jump into this one with the players
playing on seconds does nbak have a
chance to take this he has decent
chances although pawns are disappearing
actually suddenly Wesley sews a pawn up
if we count and uh it's just about how
passive White's pieces are White's King
not really playing a role here wh's
Bishop on D1 the light Square Bishop
stuck this should still be a draw it's
looked drawish for a long time but after
toor maybe he's been pressing too hard
he's got to be careful indecision there
putting his King on a bit of a wrong
Square he almost put his King way too
far because he put his King all the way
uh down on the aile he might not have
been able to get back so look at Wesley
suddenly the tables have turned and
Wesley could play for a win without any
risk on Advantage Wesley push the push
the PA push the pawn he's neglected to
cover his opponent's pass Pawn he could
have even taken it off the board
suddenly a new Queen is incoming Bishop
D4 you could just play your Bishop out
to challenge the dark SC Bishop he goes
Bishop F6 he wants the G Pawn instead oh
my gosh Wesley so's taking it abor was a
pawn up with black he had all the
winning chances zero losing chances
until he pressed too hard but now
Wesley's given up a keep on in the
position does this give nardack hopes to
hold this this one it's going to be
tough White's G Pawn is so strong simply
uh that pawn is going to March up the
board and look at how the white Bishops
control the black king cut off the black
king and this bishop trade surely can
just trade off yeah oh he's trading off
all the Bishops brilliant and back he's
resigned because all the Bishops are
coming off the board and this will be a
lost King Pawn ending and nbec Abdu
satro gives up Wesley so wins takes the
lead in their best of four what a
dramatic fight
both players with the white pieces won
their game and both players with the
white pieces were in trouble but Wesley
so he is not going to lose a game
without an epic fight Magnus Carlson did
the same against Fabiano Carana these
players are so hard to take down Magnus
Carlson doesn't only have uh the biggest
ability to convert flawlessly winning
positions but it's impossible to beat
him even when he is uh busted and we see
Magnus wins with the white beastes
Wesley as well from a difficult end game
survives and takes the lead what a
dramatic finish that was just absolute
incredible chess played in those last
few seconds David wow just crazy uh I'm
struggling to uh collect my thoughts
here to catch some breath because that
was fast that was Furious blunders in
the end deciding them but the nerves
jangling it could have gone either way
after to toov on the brink of Victory
kowana on the brink of Victory both
ended up losing and Robert Fabby
declined that reput I and went on to get
such a big Advantage he he pursued
magnus's King until Magnus lost his
Queen how does Magnus manage to still do
this chess can be absolutely brutal
there's only one winner and loser if the
game's not a draw if F been play way
better than Magnus did in that game he
completely outplayed the number one
player start to finish from the opening
he outplayed Magnus Carlson yet he is a
zero next to his name that's the evil of
time pressure you need to have time in
your clock to make the best
moves and there was some best moves made
David on both these games what got your
attention I just want to break down that
Carlson against caruana craziness uh
from the first game of today Karana did
work his magic he tracked down he hunted
down White's King and on the brink of
Victory he slipped up played the right
idea in the wrong move order and it was
here where the drama began here magnus's
King has been living a Charmed Life it
did get checked now this wins the White
Queen but this is only the beginning and
after the king dropped back we saw a
crazy position with White's far Advanced
Pawn suddenly trapping The Black Queen
forcing it to hide on a passive square
but if we fast forward just a few moves
as both sides started pushing their
pawns it was this moment Fabiano let it
slip he chose the right idea as I
mentioned but first he should have
pushed the G Pawn H3 he simply forgot
that Rook takes Pawn came with a check
no time for Black's Queen to take this
Pawn this is not a deflection and once
the black king moved away the white
Brook slid back suddenly from a winning
position Fabiano went to a drawish
position but it was more heartbreak to
come a few moves down the line after
this check from White he simply put his
King on the wrong Square King to F7
still holds the balance because after
The Rook slides up black queen has a
checking square a safe square instead he
blocked the Queen's escape and allowed
Rook to E8 nothing to be done white will
make a new Queen next move absolutely
heartbreaking because he had the right
conversion the right technique in mind
but he just forgot that white can
actually capture the pawn with a check
one move is all it takes to turn a chess
game around he put his Pawn on pre with
check Magus took it and then it was even
according to the engines but much easier
for white to play because black was
completely stuck wrong Square chosen for
the king he had to topple his King
Magnus Carlson remains King and wins
game one oh wow and the world number two
has to strike back now against Magnus
Carlson and he almost took the lead in
his match some beautiful chess being
played and we've got some beautiful Beau
functional metal posters for all of you
there are so many chess themed uh
displates and you will find a fantastic
gift fantastic holiday gift I do assure
you go to displate.com
some really cool ways to decorate your
walls and you get a very cool
33% off use the code chess to get your
33% off and right now fabi's got to be
in a bit of an off mood but he has to
leave that aside as he plays Magnus
Carlson in game two can he get the job
[Music]
done all right next one I'm this a t
what's your take on him he show that
always a fighter when he's uh when he's
done I would say fighter that's that's a
word I would I would give for Notre back
always goes for uncompromising stuff and
is not afraid of anyone I think Notre
Beck is probably the player who runs
sort of the hottest and coldest he'll
either play really well or really badly
I don't think there's any in between and
um if he's hot he he someone to watch
he's just like always fighting and
putting up resistance and he's really
tough to beat so that's that's the word
i' use for him just of will do well cuz
he has such great sporting qualities um
I don't think he can win the tournament
he will be a difficult oppon for
everybody a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major your pieces on
unique metal posters from displate now
with the official collection from
chess.com Mount them in seconds with a
toolfree magnet kit and swap them
whenever you like make your move get an
exclusive discount on all metal posters
shop now with the code Chess at
displate.com
[Music]
uh so first of all what is your take on
Magnus calls growing up he was my idol
because when I I started playing chess
he became World Champion 2013 it's
always pretty cool I play against him
and I'm happy that I managed to be
quickly in the top so I could compete
against him so he's really exceptional
player
and amazing Champion I mean he still is
the best player by far I would say uh I
don't think he's as motivated in chess
as he once used to be marus Carlson is
of course he has incredibly strong very
hard to play against him well Magnus
Carson um could definitely be considered
the greatest player of all time or at
least in a close battle with uh with
Gary Kasper yeah it'll be interesting to
play against him see his form um and
hopefully at least some of us can put up
a good fight and maybe maybe be uh the
difference between me and Magnus was uh
like 300 tour points so it means uh it
means a lot so I think that speaks for
itself uh as people like to
say
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
[Music]
things
yeah
[Music]
the mud store is better and bigger than
ever get a great gift for all the chess
lovers in your life Maybe a plushy
mittens we all know how mean mittens can
be actually but that is a very very cute
plushy right there go to chess.com
do shop buy as much as you can for the
holiday season and to celebrate chess
and the holiday season we are in Toronto
right now where all the great chess is
happening we started with eight players
it's getting lonely as we are down to
just four and it gets lonelier at the
top when only two will be left and uh
what what an action we had in game one
of the semi-finals we saw two big
turnaround moments and Kaa caught up
with Magnus after his miraculous
win just wow is what we have to say
about that game Magnus what will you say
yeah
um I don't know it seemed at some point
we were both playing for for win there
uh I mean of course a lot of things
happened before that but we were both
playing for a win then he was out
playing me at some point I was down to
seconds and then I don't know I don't
know what happened but uh I mean at some
point I started pushing my pawns I even
lost my queen but um somehow I managed
to to win I have no idea what is the
secret there to to stay I guess calm
when you lose your queen there and
eventually
win I don't know uh
I at least I had a clear plan which was
to push my pawns
and but it was um yeah it was a mess
what what was the emotions there in the
final
minutes
um I don't know I mean at Dan it was
just disbelief cuz um he was about to
put his King on the right square and
then he put it on the wrong square and
lost on the spot so was a bit bit
surprising how good is it to win a fight
like this no no of course it feels great
so um and for the match it's it's huge
heart rate at the end there what was
it
I don't know mine is usually not that
high but I would guess higher than usual
probably congrats and good luck at next
one thank you wow yeah just wow you guys
what a fight between them in the first
game back to you guys a crazy game there
Ka I mean how do you explain this Magnus
shows up messy hair looking like he just
woke up and then he loses a queen dead
loss position goes on to beat the world
number two he looks like he was ready
for a game just like that it was messy
it was not what you woke up and wanted
but it's what you got and it's what he
made out of it that was quite the wake
up call for Magnus Carlson for Fabby
it's not the score line but
psychologically getting over the
position that he lost David yeah it's
going to be tough but luckily there's
not that long a break luckily the chess
is about to begin again and Fabiano will
want to bounce back and for wesle so as
well surviving a big scare he starts
with the black beast say nbak has some
positive takeaways from that game one
where he did get a good position there
are some positive takeaways but he also
maybe learned a valuable lesson of
pushing too hard because that is what
happens to all of the best players in
the world Magnus Carlson included that
sometimes you push a little bit too hard
it can backfire and we can see on the
screen the opening moves are being
played and yeah there they are I see the
dark sore Bishop pins the Knight on F6
there will be pressure on the D5 Pawn
but this is Mainline Theory from both
players Mainline Theory it's the Queen's
Gambit declined uh both players clearly
well versed in their Queen's Gambit law
because uh look at the way they're just
slowly just uh calmly finessing the way
they move the pieces and uh okay a trade
of Bishop for Knight um maybe some
aggressive intentions behind I'm
wondering if Abdu sattorov will move the
White Queen out the way Castle on the
queen side I've seen him do that type of
thing before in online Blitz but in
Rapid against such a strong opponent
like Wesley so how much risk do you want
to take after a heavy defeat do you just
try to get on the scoreboard make a draw
uh postpone the tension to later in the
match or do you try and strike back
immediately he trades off Pawns in the
center now angling for a really quiet
game but Queen out to B3 putting
pressure on black Central Pawn early
days but uh yeah strange stuff
interesting stuff from Abdu satov
fascinating opening right here and for
Abdu satov it is a white right you have
to make the most of these chances you
probably don't have those many
opportunities to try to balance out
level out the score line but losing game
one and we see a different format here
from the one we've been seeing it's a
best of four are Fabby and N back happy
now that it is a best of four because it
gives them more margin to strike back
not only is it best of four it's best of
two sets so even if they lose the match
today there's another match tomorrow
that they can take hold of but this is a
good start to the game for notb he has
an imbalance already and we'll see if
Fabby can get off to a good start
because he gets the white pieces and
we're about to have liftoff here as they
shake hands the 2018 World Championship
match between these two was epic let's
see if Fabby can get an epic comeback
started right now the sweater is off
Fabiano means business it's no more
Spanish torture it's the Sicilian
Defense instead and wow this is really
Hawking back to 2018 Robert flashbacks
of uh the opening debate consistently uh
discussing this exact opening uh in that
world championship match and okay a
trade of Bishop for Knight right now
Magnus Carson playing the moves quickly
this is yeah I mean so many memories
that was one of the tensest world
championship matches I've ever seen and
uh we're arguing that uh this opening
again uh it's at the Forefront of both
players mind but A4 there now Magnus
pause so in the first game we were
talking about the Archangel that was
really Fabiano Carana main weapon here
this at both of their wheelhouses
because 2018 all of their games when Fab
was white headed into this line but it's
Magnus who's really he's taking his time
at these stages you saw a flank pawn
move for Fabiano the knight jump behind
it that Knight's going to reroute into
the center and perhaps Magnus is saying
this idea is unfamiliar to me I haven't
studied it either recently or ever and
Fabiano perhaps outsmarting his opponent
the night developing on the edge is when
Magnus takes a pause uh perhaps not the
most topical most popular move in this
position uh you do see the night jumping
towards the center of the border the
Deep on moving forward opening up the
Bish sh how much of a surprise is this
for Magnus Knight to A3 uh it definitely
is a surprise it's forced him to pause
for the first time in this game but it's
not the scariest surprise yes White's
Knight might relocate towards the center
to a really nice square but uh there's
no concrete threats and there's no kind
of tactics no calculation to be done yet
Magnus I think he's pausing because he
just wants to figure out how to set up
the black pieces firstly to fight
against White's Knight coming into C4
next move but uh also just maybe coming
to terms compar pairing with the ideas
that he actually does know that he was
more familiar with and uh we soon see
him bring his Bishop out this is a clear
reaction to White's plan the White
Knight at least temporarily was
prevented from using C4 but Fabiano
replies quickly as far as I know Pawn to
A4 this whole plan with white was
advocated by Alpha zero and all these
neural network engines so modern chess
uh played and uh yeah mirroring this
2018 World Championship that we've been
discussing and another pawn move by uh
Magnus Carlson here which to me is
interesting because he supports the E5
Pawn but also vacates a square a
potential Square for his Knight to land
on where it can get to the edge of the
board from H6 and to F7 is are those the
kind of opening setups that Magnus is
aiming for bring your knight to F7 and a
potential kingside Castle absolutely and
the pawn on E5 is now extra well
defended and you put your knight on F6 a
turn ago that pawn was a bit loose so
look at Fabiano he brings his own Knight
towards the center and that Bishop on E6
that Magnus put there it's his Bishop's
Advantage he's the only one with a light
score Bishop he can take this Knight
doubling Fabiano's pawns we'll have a
wall of Pawns on the sea file all of
them doubled but look at Fabiano's
development compared to Magus he's ahead
in development he does not mind this
capture one bit Yeah Magnus he has a big
decision if he does take that Knight as
you mentioned Robert it pretty much
means he's happy with the draw he just
wants to lock things down trade off his
long-term advantage of the bishop pair
uh just to shatter wh Pawn structure
balance out uh kind of make things more
symmetrical there if he refrains from
taking the White Knight it means that he
wants to play more dynamically more
ambitiously and I think Tanya's plan of
developing blacks pieces first of all
that black knight um that is the most
likely option um interesting here but it
is a slower maneuvering type of position
not sure that's exactly what Fabiano
wanted from the opening I'd be surprised
if Magnus decides to take that Knight on
C4 I hear you that you know it's a good
way to shut down the position but I
think Fabby can still try to push there
because look at the pieces that remain
white would have a dark Squad Bishop
which would find itself easy Targets on
black spawns on C5 and as I say it
Magnus does take it but I don't think
this is without poison for black we can
imagine White's Bishop developing to
either E3 or A3 targeting that C5 the
double pawns that Magnus has eventually
the a pawn can move it start moving up
the board Magnus develops but how much
of an equality is this really I think
that Fabo might actually take this KN
because then black is left with a bad
dark score Bishop staring the air and
that A4 move that Fabiano played early
on Rook lift time take that Knight away
bring your own Rook up to A3 slide it on
over to the D3 scare with your queen try
to take over the only open file on the
board I'm not exactly sure where the
white knight will end up but if he takes
that Knight and reroutes his Rook I feel
like he may have the long-term
chances all right things are building up
in this one and we're going to check in
with our gang in Toronto it's Danny and
and James joining us guys what a crazy
game one that
was yeah CH it wasn't as hype when I
intruded in the middle of game one but
the energy was electric here as both
those games came down to the wire we
were out there with Levy Maxim is
hanging out with us that's MV we've got
Cy and all of us were just on the edge
of our seats and I think Robert said it
well and I want to just throw to you you
saw Notre Beck just learn a super
valuable lesson about going up against
so yeah of course I mean you go up
against the top dog like that you best
not Miss right and of course you pushed
in a in a position that he was drawn in
he wanted to push he wanted to play for
more and that's just his fighting Spirit
Notre backck loves to fight but you got
to take those draws you got to take what
you have and not just push I mean he's
not Magnus there obviously Magnus was
able to push a little bit he got away
with it but Wesley you're not going to
get away with that as solid as he is
Wesley so solid Flex Ley Serrano you're
not going to get away with that notb he
doesn't beat himself yeah he doesn't
beat himself and I just want to add
something an anecdote that Christian
Trill gave me obviously catching up with
his friend Fabiano and a heartbreaking
moment but just I call it Magnus bias
itis often telling you but it's like
hypnosis you had this game where Fabby
he pushed and he went for the win he
played A3 to open up magnus's King but
then in the critical moments it was
giving up the H Pawn with Czech Fabby
would never do that playing King F6
instead of King F7 Fabby would never do
that and biggest of all instead of Rook
C6 Fabby was winning on the spot with
Queen C6 and Rook F like it's over and
it's one of those moments where you
don't understand the hypnosis right the
the the bias and the dominance that
Magnus has over his peer group until you
see things like that and it's just Fabby
obviously needs to forget it in Focus
now but the energy in the room was
insane and then just like what did we
just watch with both those guys Wesley
and Magnus winning games they had no
business winning Danny we've been
talking about the exact same thing in
the studio about Magnus just living
rentree in his opponent's head and I
think it just felt like that the the
last few moments now with such short
turnaround time between the player
between the games
and everything that we just witnessed
what is it like what are the players
doing between game one and game
two honestly I mean Fabiano was was
stoic out there it's one of the best
parts about him he has short-term memory
like we say but he also didn't look
super happy right that's that's one of
those gut-wrenching ones you almost
would rather have gotten blown off the
board than have literally been a move
away probably from Magnus resigning like
Queen C6 instead of Rook C6 so I know
you saw it too but it it was a hard one
to shake off if you're it was definitely
a hard one to shake off but I do like as
I mentioned before Fabby just got the he
came and talked to mvl real quick he was
like what about this A4 they just said a
few moves couldn't hear it too much but
I knew they were talking moves he was
like ah okay all right cool said
something smile grabbed a snack and went
right back in like nothing happened like
I didn't was about to just beat Magnus
and lost very quickly love his mindset
and his psychology there yeah and I'll
say Notre Beck similarly was clearly not
happy but also these guys have the
ability to shake it off so anyway crazy
stuff if we're in for that all day I
don't know that um I'm gonna I'm gon to
be able to make it but hope you guys are
enjoying the tension as much as we are
over there we're loving the action uh
Dan we're still getting over all that we
just witnessed but of course game two is
on we will check in with you guys later
on Wow uh just I can imagine for Fabby
getting over what just happened and for
nbec as well to bounce back to try to
get it to get it together in game to
it's not easy the biggest wow of
everything that they just said was that
when Fabby won the queen for Rook he
could have won the queen for free I
wasn't even thinking in that direction
but if he' gone Queen C6 and a rook C6 a
less intuitive move but one that if you
give him even five more seconds on the
clock to actually sit and think he would
have found it instantly so that's going
to be one that hurts Fabiano it clearly
has given Magnus a reason to smile we
saw his interview with Kaa and this
position should also give Magnus a
reason to smile there's only one open
file not much is happening here I don't
think Fabby even believes there no
chances in this game yeah the players
just calming their nerves after what we
just witnessed in game one Crazy Action
all around let's check in with nbec
Abdus satov he also suffered a defeat in
game one from a really good position so
again for him it's important does he
manage to create chances or will he play
Slow try to just stop the bleeding it's
a long match two set three sets to play
out uh he is though going for those dark
Square weaknesses that we see in Black's
Camp a csb structure Knight A4 to me
this looks like like nck doesn't need
time to calm down from what has just
happened he is ambitious in this one
definitely the other semi-final kowana
against Carlson looks like the C after
the storm that looks likely to fizzle
out towards a draw as Fabiano recovers
and uh kind of gathers himself after
that heartbreak of the first game Abdu
sator also heartbreak for him but he
doesn't care he wants to fight that's
the kind of Mantra for him throughout
the entire tournament yes he's lost a
couple of games here and there but he
always seems to bounce back and he's
chosen a really uh kind of interesting
opening idea I must admit it's brand new
to me what he's done giving up White's
dark Square Bishop trading it off very
early on and installing a very powerful
White Knight in the center and this
White Knight on the rim as tany mentions
is heading into fresher pastures it's
coming into C5 as well it looks like
White's got stability of course it's a
slower position this cpad structure that
arises from the Queen's Gambit like this
one um it does mean that normally you
need a lot of maneuvering it's very very
slow but he's trying to play it as
energetically as possible Pawn to F4 not
really uh launching an attack yet it
just looks like a very nice controlling
type of move but uh it's definitely
pressure on Wesley so to break out of
what looks like a bind right now it's
those positions where white can play on
both sides of the board we see the KN in
Queen binding down the Queen's side
meanwhile white also hinting at Pawn
expansion on the king side for Wesley
where does he find his breaks well he
went Rook C8 just now he may be
intending to play C5 but that's not easy
to accomplished with the White Knight
The Pawn in the center and the queen all
lined up I love these positions for
white in quicker time controls this
isn't quite a Blitz game I think in a
Blitz game honestly black gets Blitz off
the board quite often but it's just not
a comfortable situation to be in for the
black side because your Pawn breaks the
C5 one hard to accomplish white on the
other end can start throwing even more
Pawns of the I wouldn't be H3 Follow by
Pawn G4 let's storm pawns up the
kingside and go for a deadly attack I
love it Robert that's where white is
strongest that's where white has placed
his Rooks after all uh yes there's one
long-term deficiency in White's position
that's the backward E Pawn it will never
really step forward safely without being
traded off or simply one uh so you're
kind of playing around this Pawn but
this is the side you've committed you
have the beautiful statue uh the granite
statue here there Knight on E5 and uh
your Rooks of pois so why not open lines
and I think we'll see that it's nybeck
style uh Pawn to H3 it does take a while
to set it up but once you get a pawn
forward you can slide the White Queen
across as well then start pushing
everything towards this black king and
uh meanwhile Wesley has to bank on the
fact he can break out on the queen side
but not so simple yeah it's a very good
position for Abdu sattorov right now
it's good air quality as well it looks
like he's uh loving life in this game as
he aims to bounce back and he does need
to bounce back and he's done it before
against Hikaru he did lose the first
game then won the second one then won
the Armageddon and once again we see
nbak at least hinting at a position
that's going to be extremely balance
once those pawns start moving Wesley
will be under pressure and will have to
find play on the other side of the board
and it's traditional wisdom your
opponent goes for the flank attack you
strike in the center I think it's going
to be a race about G4 and C5 well you're
talking about a race you're talking
about time I'm looking at Wesley's clock
6 minutes and 34 seconds compared to
over 10 for no dearbeck he plays with
this speed that's actually quite
imposing it's hard to deal with and I
look at this position we're talking
about Pawn H3 Pawn for you can put your
King on the H file put a rook behind the
G Pawn things like that are going to be
scary and even now I feel like Nock he
can put his Knight on C5 if he wants he
plays A3 maybe he'll play Pawn to B4
just to clamp down on the queen side
that C5 idea that break in the center
it's not happening anytime soon yeah I
love it we talked about great air
quality this is just great chess in
general NC I mean I'm going to go study
this one because it looks like he's put
Wesley so out of his comfort zone and
that is such a difficult thing to do
it's very rare to see Wesley after 17
moves of what is a very well established
opening uh the most classical historic
of openings the Queen's Gambit and black
struggling for moves struggling for a
clearcut plan white has full control in
the center Queen side I'm normally a
proponent of Black's positions uh in
this type of opening but yeah here I'm
just really struggling it's just really
beautiful for white the last two moves
is a perfect example of playing against
your opponent's ideas for nbec he pushes
the pawn to A3 he was hinting at
expanding the B Pawn forward just make
making sure that Wesley never gets that
Central Breakin remember if Wesley
doesn't get a central Breakin it gives
nbec a free hand on the king side to
start pushing his own pawns up the board
and Wesley on his own turn stops that
idea so he stopped the advance of B4 but
every pawn move has its own set of
consequences and that pawn on A5 it
takes away a key Square from Black's
Queen where it could have helped that c
pawn move forward to C5 so with no Queen
A5 coming up does that make it more diff
difficult for Wesley to strike in the
center if I'm not I'm just playing for
that King set attack I know that's
sometimes called you tunneling but I
don't see what black does to stop it
very easily and it's actually just a
decent move pushing your Pawn to H3 it
supports that pawn push and I'm not
seeing how Wesley accomplishes his ideas
and one really annoying thing for Wesley
that Knight on E5 it's such a nasty
piece there because even if black tries
to take it there will be uh some
problems in that scenario for example if
you bring your let's say I go H3 go
Knight D7 let me get that Knight off the
board Pawn to F5 just use the pawn as a
battering Rim that Bishop is trapped and
you're just in grave danger at this
stage this is one of those situations
where I would be deeply uncomfortable as
Wesley so so after H3 David maybe I have
to throw it to you like what should
black do to stop these obvious ideas
that white is about to unleash yeah it's
difficult Robert I think H3
psychologically would have been a great
move as well he's actually played Rook
to C1 so maybe saving that one for later
but H3 and uh it's not just the fact
that it does uh kind of scare the oppon
oent but it also forces Wesley to burn a
lot of time like is this a threat first
of all if it is how do you guard against
it Wesley would have been in the tank
for a long long time Rook C1 is a
controlling type of move so I don't hate
it but uh it does bring the Rook away
from what could have been a nice uh
Square maybe supporting the E Pawn later
he I think he's just trying to shut down
on this Square clamp down on C5 as long
as black cannot push the pawn on this
flank he can play H3 G4 at will later on
it might be time to at least hint at
removing this Knight maybe with the
bishop and you just sit at the right
moment you might be able to capture or
throw a knight into E4 even at the cost
of a pawn he does play this move but I
think we all still prefer white here in
the studio we're all loving what nck has
done in the early sages no question
about that and nck style it is one where
he if he gets the opportunity to play
for the initiative he doesn't back down
so definitely H3 is on his radar it is
on his mind but I like that move Rook to
C1 because it really makes sure that
blacks B Pawn never really gets moving
because of the pressure on the SE file
if we just from a broader picture zoom
out and think about the last few moves
that nbec has played it looks like he's
playing on the king's side as well as
the queen side he's not only thinking
about his own attack but he's making
sure that Wesley's counterplay on the
other side of the board is stopped and
there you have it so he's combining
ideas full board awareness he's showing
restraint and I think that is a sign of
maturity that he's able to recover from
that first game get a nice plus and play
on his own terms
yeah all right well this one will
definitely be put be putting uh Wesley
so Under Pressure but let's move on to
our other game where Fabiano Carana on
the score line is a little bit under
pressure uh and we see an end game
pieces have been traded off only a rook
and Knight remaining but is white can
white try for more simply given that the
pawn on A5 is up the board you've got F4
ideas but it's black who strikes first
in the center yeah and maybe this was
out of necessity I actually a feeling
that Magnus is a bit complacent or he
has been in the last few moves because
it was dead level it should still be
roughly level but he's been forced to
take concrete action when he would
rather have just been sitting and uh
pretty much just setting up this
defensive formation and uh look at this
now white does have a big threat on the
board White's Knight after this Pawn
trade is coming coming to D3 next move
where it would attack two pawns Black's
E Pawn is undefended in the sense there
now isolated as well and the head of
Black's Pawn chain on the queen side the
black C5 Life Born also
undefended suddenly I think Magnus might
be starting to feel a bit uncomfortable
if he'd put the Black Knight on a
different Square perhaps he would have
shut down all of these ideas for good
and there's something misleading here
the black Rook is obviously on an open
file White's Rook is actually on an open
file you may think I'm crazy what is
Robert talking about what's happening
here is that when the White Knight steps
forward out to D3 to attack that head
Pawn the one on C5 black will be forced
to play the move B6 and when you play B6
white can take that pawn on B6 and now
that Rook A1 sitting on what would seem
like a starting Square it's open it can
Venture into enemy territory A6 or A7
and start poking and prodding so that
Rook A1 idea from Fabiano he kept his
Rook there very clever play by him yeah
and uh Magnus the problem is how does he
stop this idea um I was going to say
earlier if you he had simply put the
Black Knight on E6 he would have guarded
this Pawn he would never have had to
touch anything on the queen side and it
should have been a simple draw but
Black's Knight just just unable for the
moment to find any nice squares again
Magnus would love to kind of teleport it
over to an outpost but too slow white is
getting there first with a beautiful
night jump and suddenly pressure on the
world number one Magnus Carlson um it
looked like a draw should still be a
draw with best play but some questions
to answer and if we follow that line
through I think the most logical
continuation as Robert mentioned this is
certainly uncomfortable with the white
Rook coming in uh suddenly big big
threat coming uh behind the c Pawn
coming behind the G Pawn it's only a two
result game black is the one defending
white can apply pressure with zero risk
and ideally black could trade off the
Rooks but the king is doing an important
job for black as well Rook D7 loses on
the spot because I trade Rooks steal
your e- Pawn steal your G pawn and
that's game over so it's one of these
things where you want to cure your
problems in the seventh rank but the
solution and da you would say could be
worse than
disease wow Magnus cson on the defense
in an end game not something that you
get to see every day uh but in my head
it's hard to imagine any reality any
world where Magnus gets outplayed in an
end game we know that he is one of the
best players of all times when it comes
to this stage of Chess but Fabiano kwana
not only putting pressure on the board
but the clock as well ahead by almost 3
minutes now Magnus on a think so perhaps
the clock difference will increase on
this move Magnus realizes that he is uh
going to have to defend this for a very
long time yeah there's something in the
air in Toronto we're not used to seeing
Magnus get outplayed in an end game but
we're not used to seeing Fabiano blunder
tactically and just feels like everyone
is just reeling from uh kind of the
drama that's unfolding and talking of
drama that's unfolding Robert White's
Advantage has massively increased just
in the last few moves since we were last
here and it's White's turn right now so
that Queen on C2 can just steal a Pawn
on e4 and white has both massive pawns
on E5 and F5 that can push forward in
the near future Wesley so blundered just
a couple turns ago so if we can dive in
and analyze the last few moves Wesley
had a difficult decision we were talking
about this for a while that he was a bit
passive that the ideas were easier to
execute from the white side but if we
just go back a few turns when um NC was
able to push his Pawn up to F5 Wesley
tried to sacrifice a pawn in the center
and after F5 here I think black has to
go F6 a really really difficult move to
play challenging that pesky Knight in
the center still holds in Black's
position you don't need to even take
this bishop on E6 if you don't want it
white should have a superior position
but what he did in the game he retreated
back to D7 and after the Knight was
captured on e4 this is all of a sudden
just an extra Pawn for white and it's a
great position winning chances for
nyback yeah I think what he might have
missed is that he cannot capture this
bishop now if he had simply taken back
the bishop then series of captures a
series of takes takes takes and whoops
there's a double attack a simple KN Fork
would have won material for white so he
was obliged to take the White Knight off
in the center but this is how he's
established these powerful pawns now
here at nobec and yeah simply a pawn
Advantage these two pawns are glorious
the White Knight is clearly Superior to
its counterpart especially if it jumps
in and I don't know how you even try and
save this game if you try to go for this
Pawn then white can simply move the
knight in yet again the problem is this
bishop is attacked pressure there so the
black queen has no time to go and
capture and Wesley's desperate now he's
throwing even more pawns away to try and
free up his Bishop a good try but uh
White can simply capture if he wants to
yeah and N backck this is move number 23
getting such a big advantage against the
hardest to play beat player on the
circuit definitely a big achievement I
think the score line in this match is
not reflective of the quality nck was
also ahead in game one and there are
already a lot of tactical ideas you're
pointing out that the C5 Pawn is hanging
uh David I'm also looking at trying to
open up Black's King side I'm not sure
what I want to start with whether it's
the F Pawn moving forward or sacrificing
the E Pawn I'm actually I really want to
discuss this with you guys give up the
ewn force black I like that Robert uh
nodding his head in approval so E6 you
take that pawn and now I'm not I don't
want to capture that back I just want to
blow open your king side I want to go F6
I want my queen on G6 and this is the
kind of Chess that we expect out of nbec
as well is this something that's on his
radar definitely I mean uh the greedy
player in me is saying take a porn play
on try to uh just collect and uh win
long term but why win longterm when you
can win on the spot and pawn to E6 as
you mentioned Tanya would be a dagger
blow to Wesley so's position here I
don't even see how to try and fight on
yes you can move the bishop that's
attacked I think the variation you
pointed out is just too strong this
battering ram blows open the black
position Pawn takes Pawn for example a
check and everything drops with Tempo uh
White's Rook will soon come in to end
the game uh so this is just Unthinkable
and if you cannot take this Pawn you
have to move your Bishop what do you
play do you attack the White Queen uh I
mean this looks just too powerful you at
the very minimum maybe there's even
stronger but you can uh ask the black
king to step out into the open now you
can deliver a bunch of checks pawns
aren't going anywhere you're actually
material up this just looks terminal E6
might be the strongest of them
all and uh this is a big moment for nck
does he go Pawn hunting will he be
materialistic right now will he play
more will he play for Wesley's King and
E6 is on the board it's a move that nir
backck could have played in a second but
I think after that first game he's
binding his time a little more making
certain that his ideas are good but this
is clearly strong as we're just showing
if you take that pawn it's kind of a
removing the guard tactic it allows the
queen to venture into the G6 Square
later that F7 Pawn the golden Pawn
Central to the king's defense and that
pawn on E6 Pawn on F5 all the pawns are
going forward the black king I don't
think is surviving yeah really thematic
really typical sacrifice to blow up in
the opponent's king remember this one at
home and uh AB storf using it to great
effect and how critical is the clock
situation right now given the position a
big task ahead of Wesley to defend it
piece is falling down while he does
trade uh a pair of minor pieces and now
he's taking does white still go F6 yeah
do it clearly that's his plan Abdus
satoro if he doesn't play F6 now then uh
it would be less consistent and actually
material is suddenly level but it's all
about the black king and it's about the
white Rooks The Rook on F1 is perfectly
placed that other Rook is going to hit
the queen on the defile then Barrel on
down to the seventh Rank and this is
what NCA is doing he's clearing the
seventh the rank of black pawns that
means the King has no shelter and I
think actually this is a very quick
knockout if you take that pawn Rook D1
Rook D7 it looks over yeah look at
Wesley so on the camera he looks already
defeated pretty much he just went to
pick up a piece to fiddle with but he's
only got two minutes defending is harder
than attacking he's going to have to
watch out for the White Queen to switch
those Rook slides as Robert mentions it
is another heavy piece position and we
saw how dangerous those can be in the
previous clash between Carlson and
kowana and when it's just the major
pieces Rooks and queens it's all about
King safety black is about to have none
of that at all and uh you can simply
take on G7 if you want to uh maybe
there's even stronger but just rid the
black king of its shelter and long-term
white is winning excellent play by n
Abdus satov he's up a pawn he sacrifices
two Pawns in return to blow open
Wesley's King he's going for blood in
this one look at the determination on
him on the screen as well uh he's got
some pleasant choices to make but
sometimes having choices is the biggest
problem in chess he can slide that Rook
to the open file with Tempo hit that
Queen he can also further go on to pick
up the G7 Pawn but both looking very
pleasant he decides to bring the final
Rook into the attack looking strong
looking good Abdu satoro also in terms
of style of the position it's right up
his Ali loving to attack loving the
initiative Magnus said himself in that
interview we saw earlier uh he loves to
pounce when given an opportunity Wesley
normally likes a bit more stability than
this one he wants kind of stable
positions where he can outmaneuver his
opponents here he's clearly just getting
attacked look at Black's pieces all
planted on their back rank Queen trade
offered white is definitely going to say
no White's Queen likely to slide across
now repurpose herself she's so agile
this White Queen is likely going to be
the piece that delivers the killer blow
and Checkmate in one threatened this is
a pin on the G file Queen takes porn you
have to guard against it Wesley is
forced into ugly defensive moves Rook to
F7 he's holding but maybe not for long
that's what it looks like you don't even
have time to pick up the F6 Pawn because
the G Pawn was pinned Wesley so is in
big trouble and you mentioned it David
that uh nck loves to play for the
initiative and it's something that
Magnus has spoken about nck as well uh
there was this interview and I'm going
to butcher the name of this but David I
need some help for you on this podcast
is it the shack Snack Shack snack means
basically what does it mean chess talk
chess talk okay so on Shack snack uh
Magnus mentioned that Abdus satov he's
not the the biggest talent amongst the
youngsters but he's the one who's got
the most sportsmanlike qualities give
him the opportunity to get the
initiative he takes it with both hands
he's always in the gym Pumping Iron very
serious and well prepared is that the
nck we're seeing it absolutely is but I
heard the word snack not only am I
hungry it looks like Fabiano is too he
stole he snacked on the C5 Pawn on the
right hand side of our screen if we do a
quick count of material Fabiano is a
pawn ahead against Magnus Carlson I know
Magnus leads this match Fabiano has
played better than mag
and on the left hand side of our screen
nordbeck and Wesley they're about to
enter that time trouble territory down
to a minute left and you see the eval
bar no longer does n debeck have the
advantage so maybe he let his pressure
linger a little too long and W's able to
escape yeah we cursed him the
commentators curse we were talking about
how great those sporting qualities are
how ambitious he is always jumping on
the initiative Abdu satov he's still
better I really still like White's
position in that one but Wesley so
suddenly defending and suddenly holding
things together and really really
impressive tenacious stuff there so both
games in the balance it looks like
Karana is a favorite Abdu sator still a
slight favorite in his one as well uh
both players with white with the winning
chances but it's not going to be easy to
convert and Magnus makes his move he
brings King the bar is going up and up
and up so it seems like Magnus has gone
wrong on numerous occasions already two
games into this match and the left hand
side of a screen Wesley he's Frozen he's
about to make a move with 40 seconds
left he brings his Rook on over to f8
and the bar starts creeping up it's such
a natural move defending a rook but now
is the time for no dearb the left hand
side of your screen everybody Pawn takes
Pawn right next to the black king you
rip to shreds Black's defensive
resources there are not many pawns there
it looks really tough to defend for
Wesley I'm going to point out one trick
on that left side of our screen where if
white does take Pawn takes spawn black
will have the time to recapture with the
Rook because you might think black's
Rook on f8 is hanging but watch out they
can be there's a checkm in one on G2 and
look at that big move that is big chess
by nbec Abdus satov a rook sacrifice
impressive stuff there Abdu satarov we
mentioned he loves to attack and he
overworks the black Rooks right now the
two black Rooks are tied defending each
other Tethered to each other and he's
trying to deflect one away so the White
Queen can go and capture the black Rook
on F7 out of the blue out of nowhere a
shot in the dark suddenly Wesley so in
trouble look at the clock as well the
evaluation bar shot up Checkmate again
threatened he's panicked Wes Leo he did
not react well to this but incredible
tactical awareness from aboro the
tenacity from abusar it's reminiscent of
Carana fuja with a rook sacrifice in the
final rank Wesley down to 5 seconds he
needs to make a move he does give a
check the white kick can escape and
meetting one was threaten he brings his
Rook back you can take the rook and you
can go F7 isn't that just winning game
over if he sacrifices his Queen right
now Abdu satov he does it it's on the
board Abdu satov finds the finishing
touch you're also threatening to promote
to a knight with a nice Fork on the
black king and black queen this is
simply game over Wesley so resigns Abdus
satra of the comeback kids strikes again
leveling the game and in what style
amazing performance that sacrifices the
queen in the end with a win wow it's
good that the players don't see the Evo
bar swing up and down because for not
Beck he was always on the prow he gets
the dub evens up the score and Fabiano
Carana right now is looking to nybeck
for some wisdom some advice hey can I
Channel your spirit here and nb's
looking at that very game and as we see
nybeck storm off he should be feeling
proud of himself and Fabiano wants to
join nck back in a 1-1 score yeah
fantastic game there one of the games of
the tournament so far and Meanwhile
we're left with this semi-final car
kowana has still this extra porn we
talked about Magnus Carson had to give
up a pawn uh just to prolong the fight
and it's not just that but it's a
massive strategic Advantage Magnus you
can tell the body language there not
confident at all right now we're at move
44 and Fabiano with a bit of time
thinking he needs to land the killer
punch he does not want to let Magnus
Slither away survive like he did in the
previous game it's looking great for
Fabo Carana he is the time to think just
a game ago when he had the black pieces
he had a winning position but he was
down to those final seconds so great
time management from Fabiano he's
controlled the board he's controlled the
clock and I think he's just a couple
moves away from sealing the deal we
actually can see a white knight on C6 he
putting pressure both on the far left
Pawn on A7 you see the clock for the
players and for Fabiano I think it's now
time for him to bring his Rook into the
action a knight it can't work operate by
itself it's not a lone wolf help with
the Rook yeah and that's a juicy Square
I was going to say the center of the
board but he chooses another one also
attacking Black's weakness and you can
see that Black's Pawn so much more
vulnerable right now The Rook the Knight
that Magnus has tied down to defense
right now now uh and it is uh all Fabby
in this end game but will it be enough
the Knight is jumping you've got to be a
little careful of not getting trapped
but there's that B7 Square defended
guarded by that pawn on A6 that keeps
the Knight safe yeah and that's the key
Pawn just next to the clock White's Pawn
over on A6 next to magnus's clock is
holding everything together but also a
potential Queen two squares away from
touchdown from promotion Magnus is
chasing this night desperately around
the board but it does have one Safe
Haven anchored by that pawn and we'll
see it drop back black spawns just weak
he needs to move quickly though Magnus
Carlson no time but how much of a
psychological moment is this well I was
going to say does he come back with the
night bit Fabby is not repeating this
position he knows that he's close to
this one brings The Rook to defend that
Knight on d8 no checks on C6 black stops
it is it time to jump in with the Rook
to the Central Square now it absolutely
is he should have done it before but
he's given a second chance bring your
Rook forward your knight can always
escape to that B7 Square might still be
a good move here but with the Rook
either joining on D5 or d8 I think that
magnus's forces are overwhelmed and
Fabby he's spending quite a lot of time
here he's getting himself into that time
trouble that he needs to avoid yeah
that's the only thing that can save
Magnus Carlson now the clock as we saw
in the previous game and Fabiano does
bring his rook in still no threat but
the realization that black has barely
any moves will make him more confident
right now Black's Knight is stuck if it
ever moves the White Knight comes into
C6 with a check Black's King maybe MO
okay he checks with the Rook but this is
only helping the white king come around
the white king is actually going to
March up the board via the H file this
infiltration white K is going to step up
up and in and magnus's defenses are
crumbling he tries counterplay with his
Rook but this allows the White Knight
FREE and that break out A7 Pawn so that
one is going to fall that white Rook
goes to the final rank kicks that KN on
out of there A7 drops that pawn that was
thrust all the way up to A6 it was early
on where he went A4 it went to A5 it has
not stopped moving the pressure
continues and I think it's about to be a
winning material for him but he takes
the ewn instead I'm not such a fan of
this but he still has the same idea in
mind that being said pawns are starting
to disappear and if everything
disappears black will be able to
sacrifice a knight maybe for White's
remaining pawns later but now he's
removing the defender Black's Knight
kicked away and the a PA drops Magnus
Carson in big big trouble White's a PA
is two squares away is going to promote
that is a big pawn and Desperation there
by Magnus he's just trying to create
some chances which white still has to be
careful that KN jumping around there are
checks on the board Fabby needs to get
his King to safety and then the a pawn
wins the game I was surprised he moved
his King up but it goes back around
Knight back to B5 the pawn is
Unstoppable as long as he can bring his
Knight back push A7 The Rook actually
covers the promoting Square I think
Magnus might even just resign here yeah
you look at him and you get the feeling
he's about to give up uh Magnus Carlson
and that's it hand shakes Fabiana Karana
levels the score with a win against the
world number one he was winning in game
one did not finish the job but he gets
it done in game two he's the utmost
belief in himself he just out Magnus
Magnus Carlson he beat him in a
technical end game it looked like there
shouldn't be much hope to win and
Fabiano Carana got the job done he walks
out of the playing Hall a much more
confident man he's proven again that he
can take down Magnus Carlson in any game
yeah absolutely there is so much history
between these two players and today
there's so much glory on the line as
well Fabby Strikes Back not back strikes
back and Kaa caught up with Abdul satov
after his big win against
Wesley here with the comeback kid ndec
you must be just so happy right now yeah
I'm happy um that I managed to come back
and win a game but obviously um I was
also a little bit disappointed because
was first game where you know I had a
Advantage like risk-free um
end game that I managed to lost but yeah
I'm I'm I'm quite happy that I you know
I quickly come back yeah I mean Wesley
so he has hardly lost a game ever how
are you able to beat
him yeah um played an opening um where
which um he played against me and
uh I got a kind of pleasant position and
he spent too much too much time there
but I couldn't find anything and I think
he missed F5 after Knight
E4 after which it's completely lost for
black I think and we're definitely now
going to see this match go to four games
what will be the strategy now in the
final two games just keep
keep keep keep the momentum and uh you
know I'll try my best and yeah it's I'm
I will be not surprised if if we'll head
to our meon right well congratulations
and good luck next one thank you ABDO he
equalizes against Wesley so back to you
guys n back in his cool Puma sweatshirt
playing some really really cool chess
there against Wesley so and levels that
match is it fair to say that so far even
though the match is 1-1 nbec has been
the better player I think in both
matches the player that won game two has
played the better match and it's one to
one because of the defensive tenacity
the resourcefulness of both Wesley so
and Magnus Carlson but I do think Fabio
Carana and NC abdar have played better
in their matches yeah I have to fully
agree and I also have to apologize for
earlier calling that kowana Carlson game
the come after the storm because there's
no calm here there's no chill out in
Toronto there's just Blood on the board
players throwing everything at each
other on every single move every single
game absolutely this is why we watch
chess this is why we believe for moments
like this the comeback moments of
players who are underdogs on paper but
this guy he is the man to beat right now
what a performance in the brown Robin
and it's not be Abdus satra the youngest
ever World rapid champion who has to get
the job
[Music]
done
[Applause]
he
[Music]
oh
n
[Music]
Fabiano caran yeah Fabiano has been a
machine recently well he's done that in
the past of course there was a singfield
cup in 2014 I won s in a row two against
me I think he's a great player but I
still like my chances he calculated
calculates just Brilliance it's weird to
say but he's really On The Rise now he's
maybe the most prepared player in the
world so he's really in a good shape he
won the singfield cup and grandchester
he's been
playing very well in classical chess and
also he's been playing reasonably in in
Rapid and Blitz yeah I don't think it's
likely that he'll that he'll win the
tournament but he has a chance to do
well for sure he has shown uh incredible
results this this year in classical
chess one of the best players of our
time and and one of the you know biggest
favorite of this field well Fabiano
easily is the hottest player at the
moment he's had the best results over
the board in 2023 a very formidable
opponent I think for for him if he gets
his positions out of the open is great
preparation he's he also has a great
chance to win but I mean we'll see what
[Music]
happens
back
[Music]
while it's cold in beautiful beautiful
Toronto the semifinal action is heating
up we have been seeing some dramatic
chess some big turnaround and uh
Precision by players with very less time
on the clock we spoke about how not back
has been the better player so far in the
last two games against Wesley but Fabby
as well does he have the upper hand
against Magnus today does no doubt that
Fabiano woke up stronger than Magnus
Carson today the first game he was on
the brink of Victory just one accurate
move and it would have been lights out
Magnus would have had to resign instead
we saw that last minute turnaround the
second game outplaying Magnus Carlson in
an end game we have to give that the
utmost credit it happens so rarely once
in a blue moon and the way he did it Mak
it look easy Fabiano banging for right
now there's a reason why Magnus Carlson
has always applauded Fabiano and said
this is a serious Contender to the
throne no matter who's up there Fabio
can get it done it's almost a shame that
he's the same generation as Magnus
Carlson because otherwise we might be
talking about Fabi Carana in that light
but he's proving it against him
head-to-head Fabiano he can get it done
he just did it's one to one two games
left today wow Magnus gson definitely
needs to wake up now after that last
game and Fabby just continues continues
to impress Ka got a hold of Fabby after
that spectacular game two
win so I called nordc The Comeback Kid
so I guess I will call you the comeback
man congrats on a great win thank you
how did this go about well I think that
we're both playing rather poorly so far
first game was a disgrace to put it
mildly uh of course okay we were in time
trouble so that can kind of excuse some
of the blunders but I think the blunders
were too massive and second game he got
a very comfortable position slightly
better at some point I mean okay he's
he's definitely not risking he blundered
King F1 already I'm not worse anymore I
think he probably blundered King E3 as
well and he started to get worse he
started to drift into a bad position and
then it was uh kind of difficult to
defend well strong words there about the
way you guys are playing it's definitely
entertaining is there nerves involved
here do you think the reason for those
inaccuracies I don't feel really nervous
I just think that uh yeah the first game
was um I mean okay with time pressure
and these complications of course you
you tend to make some serious mistakes
but like my last mistake also I missed I
think Queen C6 probably just forcing
winning a queen and probably I missed
Checkmate by force at some point uh to
lose that was kind of
um kind of tilting but okay I've I've
been in some unfortunate situations
before so and you have equal equalized
momentum now on your side how can you
use that going into the two final uh
rapid games well now it's like the
familiar situation two two games like
all the previous matches that we played
so um yeah I don't know I I want to try
to improve my play a bit and try to play
a bit more stable but I I am of course
very glad to be to have equalized the
match right well congrats on that one
good luck in the next one thank you all
right this one will be an interesting
one definitely four games in the match
with Magnus and Fa back to you
guys what on Earth was that Fabby I mean
to us it looks like chess from another
planet and he says we guys have been
playing poorly what do you make of that
chess players are always critical of
themselves and that's what helps them
get better as players because when you
analyze your own games you always are in
the search the objective search for the
truth and for the players to get better
at their high level is to be
self-critical to always look for
improvements that's true when I was
working my way through the ranks as a
youngster I came across so many
opponents who said I played great I
dominated I crushed my opponent and
those were the players who never really
kind of make that next step it is that's
why uh we see the top players being
their own harshest critic and Fabiano I
think deep down he'll know he's played
pretty well he was only harsh about
himself because of one or two blunders
in the first game but the general flow
the general momentum is on his side and
uh yeah he if he can uh continue this
form I think he might be the favorite
for the rest of the day and for Magnus
he's of course experiencing this flow
that Fab is bringing on so what do you
think his mindset is uh do you think
he's really waking up now and realizing
that Fabby means business today I think
Magnus has been through it all so this
is is not his first rodeo he's suffered
against opponents who outplay him
including Wesley so has done that very
thing but I think for Magnus what he
needs to do is play one solid game
overall instead of uh this kind of
Shifty games hoping for something he
just needs to stabilize he of course is
the best player of all time so when he
wants to get it done when he feels
settled he can get it done and the other
player who's failed to keep it solid on
the board so far is Wesley David what
was the big turnaround moment in that
game yeah I just want to highlight one
moment because actually Abdu sator
played a great game from start to finish
but the Tactical flurry at the end was
so impressive and actually some really
hidden nuggets some gems in the Tactical
uh sequence at the end that I wanted to
show everyone at home in this position
Black's defenses look like they're
holding up with two Rooks stacked up on
the file keeping their King nice and
safe but White's Queen is so strong this
Rook as well really well placed and this
was the killer blow to overwhelm Black's
defenses Rook to to d8 a shot in the
dark out of nowhere and uh here Wesley
so did collapse very understandable
Wesley had no time on the clock he did
indeed take this Rook he should perhaps
have blocked just tried to cut up into a
ball but uh a good position for white
nonetheless instead Rook takes Rook was
met by a capture threatening Checkmate
in one and Wesley here gave a check this
is very clever forcing the white king to
H2 dropping back his rook and after
white sacrificed the queen pushing
forward his Pawn next move I think
Wesley was banking on the fact he could
played the move G5 hitting the white
Rook if the white Rook moves anywhere
The Black Queen could have given a nasty
check now hence the reason the King was
forced to the square and now it could
have slid back to f8 blocking the white
Pawn but it was this position Wesley
resigned because he'd suddenly realized
after G5 white doesn't promote to a
queen white promotes to a knight a
beautiful Fork here a royal Fork the
king moves the Knight takes the queen
and white ends up and peace to the good
I love it when players unearth these
tactics and we get get to see what's
going on in their brains the wheels are
turning but they are finding these
unbelievable tries and credit to Wesley
for trying to trick not Beck you
couldn't trick him because he's not
going to promote to Queen he knows how
to under promote he's going to get that
KN fork and get the job done Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so boths outplayed in
game two in their own territory their
own style NC Abdu satov with the a
aggressive Suffocation strategy in his
game playing on the king side playing on
the queen side just incredible stuff by
him and then the end game that we saw
the end game technique by Fabiano Karana
the favorites on the paper that start of
Magnus being a 71% having those odds
going into the final I think that's a
bit shaky right now well I think Magnus
is still the favorite just because he's
Magnus Carlson but I will always say
that it's just true but Fabiano is
proving that in this match this is the
day where perhaps Fabio could take him
down Magus completely has to turn around
his gameplay it's not the Magnus we're
custom to seeing but that's all credit
to Fabiano who's forcing him into
uncomfortable
territory and the good news for players
is that where they're playing it's great
territory because they've got great wow
I wasn't expecting that they've got
great air quality and you can win this
very very cool wave plus air things
device and it's signed by the one and
only world number one Magnus Carlson so
get your air things device to keep a
check on your air quality to get those
rating points up to play some of your
best chests yes Robert can I ask a
question does that help me remember
positions like Magnus did when I don't
even have to see them but their air
things devices over there if I get that
cuz it's right there I can take it will
that help me yeah I feel like if we
start playing I mean the bullets and the
blitz that we've been playing before the
show with this air things uh device on
I've already gained like 50 points on
chesc so it might be working and this is
is the one that'll be coming your way so
head over to our social media channels
uh to uh get a chance to win this Magnus
Carlson signed everything quality what
about the quality of play that we're
expecting from the players going into
game three what's going to be the switch
up from Wesley and Magnus I'm curious
about Wesley in particular because he
just was shaken and Wesley is somebody
who's usually very stoic he always is
just playing these calm games he draws
quite regularly so I'm wondering for
Wesley this opponent not bear if he's
particular comfortable for him it does
feel that way just judging by the first
two games uh but then again if Wesley is
able to go back to basics is able to
strip away all of the kind of tactics
the energy out of Abdus tor's position I
still I still do think he should be the
favorite but uh these players they're
going to have to adapt their strategies
on the Fly I think game by game we'll
see players start to kind of switch up
their openings switch up their uh kind
of uh the way they've been playing the
games and here we see Carana back at the
board I can't wait till this third round
yeah Magnus Carlson loves a challenge
and a challenge it is the best version
of Fabiano kwana has shown up to this
semi-finals match Magnus will he start
with one E4 an opening that did get him
into trouble in game one the players are
ready to go are we expecting Magnus to
switch it up on move one maybe the first
game didn't go according to plan for the
world number one but he is quite a loyal
aderant of 1 E4 and I think the big
question is whether we'll see the
Archangel again this variation of the
Spanish it looks that way Magnus Carlson
repeating his opening from the first
game and Bishop where is he goes for it
he sticks to the tri and tested his
scores the archangels which worked to
perfection in game one it was nothing
about the opening that got Fabiano into
trouble but let's remember Magnus did
get an advantage at some point and here
he pushes the pawn up two squares rather
than one so there is a change in this
opening from Magnus Carlson and FAO
quickly darts his Bishop out to G4
pinning that Knight to the queen we have
totally different territory here in the
third game of the match do you think
Magnus in the break he instructed his
second Peter H Nelson to go watch all 43
hours of fabiana's Chess of B course you
know on fast forward and maybe double
speed just to figure out what uh what to
do against this opening honestly not a
bad idea of course we're exaggerating a
bit but to look at specific lines see
what Fabiano himself self recommends uh
maybe Fabiano wasn't completely honest
with all of us maybe he kept some
Novelties to himself but this is
something that you should do if you're a
chess player at this stage uh at this
level where Anish giri Fabiano whoever
it is releasing these video courses you
can actually gain insights into the
repertoire yeah and meanwhile we see uh
both sides Castle it's pretty much the
end of the opening stage now but the top
players they know all the plans in the
ensuing middle game Magnus just playing
a really slow uh kind of setup here with
WH not overly ambitious I think he just
wants to play himself into form
frustrated of course with the first two
games and uh still pressure on Fabiano
to fully equalize his black to either
clarify the center break out in the
center or to just activate the rest of
his pieces uh but I'm excited this is
shaping up to be a really tense middle
game and Fabiano has shown a tendency
just to slide his Rook on over when they
Pawn tension like this but five he's
thinking right now so maybe he is
successfully taken out of all of his
preparation now he's on his own and it's
a good idea to slow down once you've
made these moves you pushed the pawn to
B5 your Bishop has come out to G4 now
there are these little uh little moves
right do you start with the knight jump
to A5 do you side side step with the
Rook to the B file at the right moment
you want to break open on the queen side
with the B Pawn so it's really a good
moment that Fabby has slowed down and it
will decide how this middle game
progresses depending on uh fa's approach
over the next few moves uh Magnus
looking relaxed let's see if Wesley is
looking relaxed as they're about to
start their game three and that classic
n back that's there yeah I don't think
anyone pulls it off in current world
chest just like Abdu satov can and the
deaths over first move on the board
again Pawn to E4 it looks like we're
very much headed towards Kings Pawn
territory in all of these semi finals
today and it is another Spanish opening
yes it is wh Bishop landing on B5
putting some pressure on Black's Knight
will we see copycat with the other game
previously uh no Archangel from abor he
prefers to develop his Bishop just one
square there we go more classical
territory here very interesting how both
players nbec and Fabby have stuck to the
opening that they chose for game one the
thing is they lost those games so
sometimes were results oriented but the
play was good from both of them it was
not their opening fault so it's smart of
both of them to stick to this opening
that did them well in terms of of
equalizing and for nybeck in particular
I think he needs to stay solid you don't
want to play overly risky stuff in the
opening against Wesley so he punishes so
many players he started with six match
wins in a row but now that I think about
it Wesley's most recent match before
this one was a loss to Fabiano Carana
then he just lost his last game to nbec
kataro so if we cut the tournament past
round six when he started with the
Perfect Score there's something when you
are leading the tournament that you
start getting not lazy but you don't
need to win as much he was already
through the semi-finals do you think
that can affect him definitely it feels
like yesterday was a bit of a rest day
for Wesley so yes he lost to Fabiano
early on feels like distant uh kind of
Forgotten history at this point but
Wesley it feels the wind has been taken
out of his sales um yes he was on that
hot streak and normally when you're on a
hot streak you don't want uh kind of an
easier game or a non-important game you
want to keep pushing keep pushing
challenge yourself uh for more and more
and yeah Wesley he hasn't replicated the
form he showed in the first few days uh
just in the last 24 hours but uh this
one in the meantime still a very kind of
typical position for this opening he's
traded off a set of Pawns on the queen
side and white is getting ready to build
a big porn Center um early days of
course uh there we saw the air quality
shout out to air things I wanted to say
great share quality as well in the uh
playing Hall Magnus today with great
hair quality and uh I'm hoping for more
of the same notbe with great stare
quality so yeah we can keep doing this
forever but Wesley something's going on
what is he bothered by right here he's
shaking his head a little bit I know he
doesn't like to look at his opponents or
sometimes he covers his eyes just so he
can focus on the moves but it does seem
like something's bothering him looks
very uncomfortable and I can understand
the uh head and hands to just avoid any
of those noack stairs but it actually
feels like something about the position
Wesley is not pleased he gets up and
leaves maybe he knew we were talking
about him and that's always
uncomfortable when someone's talking
about you but you can't hear but I'm
actually wonder if he's still thinking
about the previous game so far early
stages in this one maybe he's just
thirsty grabs the water but I don't know
something about Wesley seems different
than those first six round robin matches
yeah this body language is sometimes uh
it occurs when the top players kind of
mix up their move order maybe he wanted
to play a different variation this last
move uh it's very provocative and uh
maybe he had another idea in mind but
sometimes the hand kind of Acts before
the brain clicks into gear you play a
move and then you realize oh wait I
didn't actually want to play that one
makes you smile and in general Wesley's
looked in a great mood this whole
tournament so I don't think it will
distract him too much of course he'll be
able to refocus and uh on the bright
side he has surprised NC here really
hard to do that he's so well well
prepared the young uh USC grandmas and
pawn to D4 I should mention there's also
a big threat in the position if White's
Pawn steps up to D5 now Black's Knight
on C6 is trapped so for the first time
in this game there's drama there's
tension and a player sitting in for a
deep think at this stage stage can mean
a couple things either they're out of
their preparation or as you said perhaps
Wesley did something that he moved a
little quickly he didn't start by
pushing his Pawn to H3 to stop any pins
on the diagonal and we see nck takes
this Pawn on D4 and now he can slide his
light sore Bishop out to pin the Knight
to the queen and start asking white some
important questions and maybe that was
uh exactly the questions that uh Wesley
was preempting and he's not sure how he
is going to respond to them the Center
opened up Black's got a nice developing
move move with the bishop we will see
how this one progresses let's jump back
to Magnus playing with the white pieces
similar structure similar setup right
now but Magnus hasn't yet made the move
d4 which for now is under control it's
really all about who gets the central
breaks in in these openings does black
get a successful D5 in is white able to
get a good D4 in with D4 under control
for black the break under control what
are the players fighting for in this one
wow fighting for squares and fighting
for threats apparently kowana look at
the black queen and black d square
Bishop look at how they pierc down this
diagonal towards the white king there
was a big threat on F2 uh Tanya you
mentioned white breaking out in the
center that looks like a distant dream
right now I don't think it's ever going
to become a reality uh Fabiano yet again
showing the Archangel is in great shape
there's only one open file a pair of
Rooks have been traded along that file
black controls it white is not able to
strike in the center white position is
perfectly healthy I don't want to act
like Fabiano has an advantage but no
difficulties whatsoever so I think
Advantage Fabiano from the perspective
this is a game with the black pieces he
just won with white in game two this
looks really stable hard position to
imagine black going wrong but then we're
talking about Magnus Carlson here he's
going to keep the game going for a while
but Fab is doing everything right thus
far wow and look at that Knight it's
rerouted itself to the king side eyeing
that F4 square a White's Knight
meanwhile also trying to get to the
light Square
and uh while these players fight it out
the position strategic strategic battle
we will head down to Toronto where we
are being joined by Levy and he's with
Maxim vagra who's hanging out in Toronto
right now to break the position down for
us what's up
Maxim well that she asked you what's up
Maxim yeah all good I mean you know
there's nothing to be proud of from uh
the past few days so you know I
definitely didn't deserve to to to be at
this place of one of these four players
so my place is here for today at least
well we really appreciate it and um
obviously before we get into the
specifics of this Fabiano Magnus matchup
we just saw what happened there in the
first game we were all sitting watching
and just ooing and a at the screen at
watching this queen versus Rook end game
so my question to you is how do you
bounce back from that psychologically
what does it say to win that second game
with white for
Fabiano well first of all I think it's a
big relief for Fabiano to have won uh we
saw him briefly after he lost and of
course he was very pissed but I think it
helps that it's not a classical game
where you have one day to P to ponder
over uh your thoughts here you just like
came five minutes I have to go again MH
you know just reset mentally sometimes
it's e said than done but like I think
it helps also maybe at least it would
have me that it's not a game where was
particularly dominant he was on the
defensive throughout the game he got
this unexpected
chance um and then yeah he should
definitely have won but let's say draw
could have been some sort of fair result
is
like it's maybe a 0.75 Point difference
not a straight one point difference and
then he was waiting the next game he
could put put pressure definitely played
it safe in the opening so to not to at
least cut the bleeding and then when he
got his chance uh he took it then it
would have been lethal if he actually
didn't hadn't converted his Advantage
cuz at some point it looked like it was
uh going on the right on the wrong track
right and uh this could have been uh
really decisive noise come back and uh
yeah match is one1 again all of fresh no
that's obviously
and and now it's basically back to the
format that it was before the semi-final
now it's just the best of two except
it's two sets yeah yeah yeah right of
course of course yes um what are we
thinking about this position that we
have on the screen it's very reasonable
position like uh I mean Fab is going to
get his Knight to F4 so that's a good
thing I don't think you can go G3
although I would consider it like Bishop
takes um the Knight three back to H2 you
attack this Knight on H5 it's a por
sacrificed
but the problem is then Bishop F2 is
always I mean the pawn on F2 is always
hanging so I don't think it can work
right now so probably you have to let
the Knight come to F4 you're an E4
player your entire career basically you
don't play E4 E5 with black you're
sicilan player so you are you used to
seeing more of these types of positions
when you're on the white side or do you
try to avoid sort like do you not like
that Fabiano has these Queen and Bishop
pointed at f2 and control of the a file
I've had many aangel in my life uh even
the couple with black but like not
really in classical but um yeah it's
very reasonable position for both sides
I think um this of course Queen and
Bishop uh can urge the pawn on F quite
badly but worst case you can drop the
bishop back to E3 just I feel like
Magnus has lost Ops to get an opening
Advantage here so he'll be maybe trying
to outplay one way or another but it's
not going to be easy like this position
is very comfortable to play for for
Fabiano last question before we go over
to our other semifinal I am curious
about the fact that Magnus repeated the
opening for a second time right he
didn't exactly repeat it cuz he went A4
yeah he went A4 but just to you know
just to play into the aranel period just
to play E4 I mean he could have played
D4 C4 Knight F3 so is he just kind of
poking and seeing at different things
that Fabiano wants to do with black I I
don't think it's a bad idea in general
uh I just think it was taken by by the
move Bishop G I think he he recked
briefly um his lines after A4 and didn't
expect what happened next and but yeah I
mean Fabiano is obviously always
extremely well prepared and you know but
Magnus as well so like he's not he
doesn't have to back out from from a
theoretical fight like he played against
me in numerous night ofs on Grandfield
so right uh I think we are going to
bring up our our second semi-final
matchup here um and here we have it on
the screen this was also a also a Ru
Lopez but it is very different yeah and
I thought it had gone well for for
Wesley actually um but it's not that
obvious
like he has control over the
center um so this Knight on e4 you have
to make a decision now it's been
attacked probably you want to sacrifice
a pawn maybe play C5 yeah give up the
pawn and up to um to enter some uh equal
end game at the end like to I mean p
down but you you still get equalities
like I would consider either Rook d8 or
C5 probably C5 right away I don't see
why not right because also it's
important just for viewers Pawn on I was
going to say like Queen on E2 is
attacking the pawn on B5 I don't even
see that okay but C5 is is is well timed
because because Queen B5 maybe even C4
and Rook B8 yeah you can trap the queen
but C5 somehow defends both okay and
there it is we see on the screen so it
defends tactics on e4 and B5 at the same
time which is very unintuitive for most
audience members I think yeah yeah um
yeah I think it should end need a draw
like you take everything and then hook
G8 I think you know also like first game
looked like it was going to end in a
draw sure yeah of course and then I
think not back over Preston then was uh
what exactly what exactly is the idea
like if white takes on e4 with the
Knight right now black is going to take
back white will it trade everything you
take you trade everything you play Rook
d8 and you have and you have ideas of
Knight D3 as well so like because Knight
D3 right away maybe you get Bishop E3
and then D5 is always in here MH so I
think he want hook d8 and if DC even
Bishop C5 CU then you're also Hing at f2
when you play Knight
D3 okay it could be a bit uncomfortable
but I think it it ends in a draw in the
end so nck is looking to offset
potentially a one pwn advantage vage for
Wesley with some active peie play likely
will win the pawn back and I mean we did
see in that first game there was a long
long long game and even if he doesn't
like it's going to be an equal sh game
like and we see that dc5 is even on the
board so looking like this one will head
to a draw we still pretty unclear
situation in the Magnus fby game but uh
thank you Maxim for joining maybe we'll
get another one with you and we're going
to send it back to Oslo yes T and the
guys take it away do your job
guys thanks ly well that was a good
break Max seem so thanks for taking over
and do uh jump in guys whenever you've
got a moment to break this action down
for us that we're witnessing and the
Maxim's take on this is that this is
perhaps going to fiz fizzle out into a
draw would you agree with that uh I'm
never going to doubt Maxim in a Spanish
opening in a Ry Lopez he's been playing
it as long as I've known him since we
were kids uh so I trust his judgment
Maxim there's a chair here if you want
to fly over and give us more of a break
and uh yeah meanwhile it just feels like
everything's being traded off but
there's a threat on the board right the
pawn on F2 is hanging the bishop the
black bishop and the Knight is lined up
against it is it time for Wesley to
start trading off those pieces in the
center yeah just like the first game
between them there's a white Pawn on the
black side of the board in the center
and there's about to be a black Pawn on
the white side of the position but all
these trades should liquidate far enough
where there won't be many pieces
remaining so let's say you take this
Knight on e4 let's say black takes the
bishop and you keep taking and we get
this whole uh thing down where all the
pieces come off on the E4 Square
at this stage the F2 Pawn is under
attack with a knight D3 Fork at the end
so I can take this pawn and once we oh I
blundered apparently cuz maybe my knight
gets trapped down here yeah this looks
natural Robert just to point out your
idea this looks like a very logical
double attack but perhaps the Knight is
running out of squares as you mentioned
uh a bit stuck on C1 uh but maybe just
the same idea different move order uh
would be uh the more accurate way of
doing it we're actually headed in this
direction and uh I do think maybe in
this position Knight D3 first
and just same idea you'll win either uh
the bishop the pawn or this pawn and
most likely this should fizzle out
towards a draw So currently a n back
down a pawn uh in the line that we're
seeing but it looks like the pawn will
be recaptured with the ease again with
which nbec has managed to equalize with
the black pieces is that advantage nbec
in the match well if he can draw this
game then certainly and I you know may
while I overlook certain tactics here
you know Wesley will not and at this
moment he's not actually forced to take
this bishop on e4 I'm wondering if
Wesley's a little bit more ambitious
than just let's settle for a draw Trad
off the pieces because his dark squore
Bishop hasn't moved but as soon as it
does right now his Rook on E1 actually
protects the light squore bishop and
let's not forget that black has these
weak Pawns in the position the queen on
E2 is aiming on over at the pawn on B5
the D5 Pawn is isolated so I do think
that Wesley is considering just
developing his Bishop one square in the
diagonal hitting that Black Knight on B4
and I do believe that Wesley has a
better position yeah we'll learn a lot
about his mindset just in this next move
if he does trade everything off heads
straight for that drawish end game then
it means Wesley isn't quite feeling his
best or maybe he's believing in his
chances if we do get to a ultimate
Armageddon but uh if he keeps the
tension it means he's feeling ambitious
feeling sharp feeling confident um I
like your idea Robert uh I must admit I
thought Bishop takes Bishop was pretty
much forced but you can just defend your
Bishop on B1 move the other Bishop out
the way and yeah the game goes on I saw
Wesley shake his head though he quickly
did a little one of these so I he could
be seeing that no matter what he does it
should be equal but I feel like he
should try this is his game with the
white pieces he should play on wow okay
so this is a moment and we see he does
decide to play on so developing the
bishop defending the other Bishop with
the Rook we'll see how nbec reacts to
this but let's uh jump in and see how
Fabby has been reacting out of the
opening now on this one Maxim said that
it's time for for Magnus to give up all
hope of getting an opening Advantage uh
and we can see why right like the bishop
and the queen lined up attacking that D4
Pawn also x-raying the F2 Pawn the F
line is open blacks managed to get the
knights on the center of the board and
now no doubled pawns as well white needs
to be careful about the Pawns in the
center it does appear as if Fabby once
again proving the archangels hold strong
look at the clock Fabby is up nearly 2
minutes on time the Evo bar in his face
he's the one pressuring not just the
center but also the king side that
Bishop on G5 for white is kind of in no
man's land out there and that Knight on
H2 Knight on F3 those are Superfluous
Knights the late Jeremy Silman wrote
about these in his books they're
fighting for the same squares I think
black can get very active right now
Queen to A4 comes to mind for me because
Bishop A5 becomes a threat and then
white can't successfully play the move
Pawn to B4 I just feel like White's
pieces are Tangled At This stage of the
game easier for fiveon to play and even
though he's going a think right now he's
ahead in the clock yeah this looks
really strong White's position could
fall apart instantly partly due to this
threat of Bishop A5 partly due to
pressure on the D5 Pawn he actually
forces the issue he played H6 uh forcing
white to take on the F4 Square so now
there's an imbalance still very healthy
and uh White has to be really really
careful I mean this diagonal it just
looks like if black gets time to play a
move like E5 in the near future they
could be uh just tremendous tactics and
uh yeah Magnus Carson how does he
improve his Knights that's the big
question one of them uh Robert as uh
mentioned that Superfluous you need to
activate one of them you need to get
your king to safety somehow but you
don't really want to take a time out to
slide your king into the corner Pawn to
H4 he's getting ready to play G3 next
move to boot this Knight out of his half
of the board yeah and you asked the
question how do you actually get rid of
these Superfluous Knights and I think
this move H4 also allows White's Knight
to jump forward uh to the square G4
which earlier would not have been
possible with that pawn on H3 to just
point out a small tactic that stopped
this from happening black can actually
take Knight takes spawn and then the F3
Knight is on pre so the move H4 aiming
at tying down Black's King side but also
freeze up that Knight on H2 that's
really not doing anything and I like
this move that you earlier bought up
Robert Queen to A4 such an active move
not only eyeing again the D4 Pawn taking
away some key squar but Bishop A5 a big
threat on the board not easy for Magnus
to meet he might have to slide his Rook
away from the e file and perhaps he's
doing just enough to hold everything
together but Fabiano he's the one on the
offensive he really is playing a better
match than Magnus Carlson today at this
point I don't think there's any doubt
he's not facing any issues at the
opening with black he outplayed him with
white I think Magnus is feeling
Fabiano's might right now and this is
scary when Fabiano has had the 2023 that
he has winning these classical events
he's over 2,800 again the only player
not named Magnus Carlson to be over
2,800 fet and now we see fiveon
improving his rapid and Blitz game as as
well he won the St Louis rapid and Blitz
before this David I'm liking Fabiano's
chances in this game yeah he's in the
flow Fabiano not just in this game in
the year in general it feels like he's
got half an eye on ding Len's Crown
right now Fabiano he's just been
improving week on week uh month on month
especially with his speed chess and big
threats all angles of the board it's
just one glance here uh our eyes do not
deceive us the black queen so active the
Black Knight so active Black's Bishop
perfectly poised compared to all of
their C Parts clearly Superior here look
at the clock as well double the amount
of time as Magnus Carson Fabby in charge
bossing it can he convert it though
that's the uh big question Magnus needs
to pull the break and just try to hold
this one try to survive this game it's
not going to be easy for White and the
clock keeps sticking away from Magnus as
he now goes under three minutes a threat
on the board he either needs to move the
Rook or SID step with the queen I don't
believe the pawn push to B4 is something
that you really want to make it's so
Kitt ties down that pawn your queen to
defending that which means that for
Magnus it's not a pleasant choice to
make the most the most natural move to
me in this position would be to place
the Rook on the Open Sea line yeah that
is the most natural move but one of the
ideas that we've been talking about for
black is pushing the E Pawn forward
opening unleashing that Bishop on B6 it
looks scary so look at Magnus he's
offering a queen trade he's trying to
establish an endgame where the Queens
are off the board there won't be an
attack but black should still be better
all of White's pieces are his first four
ranks black has this Knight on F4 The
Rook situated on f8 that can slide on
over to the a file I really like this
position for Fabby there's no risk here
and Magnus looking away from the board
we see on the camera I think he's just
uh disgusted by his position right now
he knows that he's on the back foot yes
he should still be okayish with white
but he's the one reacting and uh yeah he
wants to be dictating the pace this is
not going according to plan for the
Norwegian right now Queen to D1 to trade
or not to trade Queen's on the board off
the board what do we think I trade him I
think that black is still better trade
Queens bring your Rook to the open file
there's no risk whatsoever in Black's
position you play with a free hand yeah
that seems uh really something that
Fabby would enjoy it feels like a
position for two results get the Queens
off the boat control the only open a
line get your Rook down the boat to
attack white pawns everything looks
really good and you said things are not
going well for Magnus in this game
things haven't been going well from the
start of the day for Magnus including
the game that he did win with which was
quite a miraculous save by him Fabby for
the second time for the third time
during the match with a better position
but again in the end game will it be
enough or is he going to get more
ambitious trying to keep the Queens on
the board he's thinking for a little too
long when you're playing against Magnus
you have to put the pressure on the
clock as
well okay he allows the quein to come
off but he's saying only on my terms and
he plays this move E5 that we mentioned
earlier it's a very committal move
because longterm for black structure if
you don't land any tactics after a trade
you might be left with some weak pawns
but he is cracking open that diagonal
for the black Bishop very ambitious move
from Fabiano I was going to say it is up
his alley to kind of maximize uh the
advantage to try and keep Queens on
potentially uh to try to play for tricks
but E5 here I'm trying to do some quick
calculation he has to be really careful
Magnus Carlson to hold things together
but now Fabby also needs to be careful
in some ways because if there is a pawn
swap on E5 black a saddle with his
isolated Pawn so longterm that can
become a weakness am all about
minimizing risk in the position I
thought trading the Queens was good but
you see that E5 pawn it doesn't have its
best friend in the Jason fil it's
isolated eventually that Knight on H2
can jump into G4 that E5 Pawn could be a
goner so I'm looking at this position
now with a double-edged lens where I
think Magnus will have some chances not
just to sty the offensive threats of
Fabiano Carana but if Fabiano goes wrong
Magnus can actually a play for a win
down the line a very committal decision
by Fabby without trading the queen means
he goes for the central break I'm
slightly surprised with this one but at
least it makes Magnus go into a thing
and burn some critical critical seconds
on the clock and eventually he does fix
that weakness on E5 and this was Fab's
idea something that nobody in the studio
expected Fabiana Carana with a pawn
sacrifice wow this is dramatic stuff
right now nobody spotted that as you
mentioned Tanya now he keeps the Queens
on but he's broken this diagonal open
watch out for all sorts of night jumps
later into D3 W Magnus Carson he's
holding things together by a thread his
Knight defends his Rook but this
diagonal it feels like there's some
tactics Brewing look at the clock as
well Magnus in big big trouble Fabby
such ambitious play totally different
position from dingly Ren against Yang
neami but it's that moment where the Eva
bar doesn't change and yet it's a sudden
wrench in the plans of you weren't
expecting this let me go for more I
think now Faby can just take this Pawn
E5 he's keeping the Queens on the board
my fear for black was with the Queens
off the board perhaps that E5 Pawn can
be targeted but not here not when black
has all the Firepower aimed at the white
king a really testing move decision from
five caran let's see if Magnus can
handle it this is fighting Fighting
Chess from Fabby objectively maybe it
wasn't the strongest option but he just
plays the most challenging line for f
for Magnus to actually handle and now
with being under a minute the Queens
stay on the board there is pressure on
that Rook on E1 I do like magnus's
defensive move placing the queen on the
second rank defending not only the B2
Pawn the F2 Pawn also the central E Pawn
on the board but it looks like Fabby
he's very ambitious about his chances
right now yeah and rightly so he also
has half a ey on the clock Fabiano
kowana three and a half minutes against
under 1 minute so it's the right thing
to do to randomize it to play
dynamically he captures a Pawn on that
left Board of our screen right now and
Magnus moves the white Rook away so
still in the balance objectively but
black having all the fun uh we see the
other board though Robert right now
between wesle so and Abdu satov on the
right of our screens what do you make of
that one we appreciate those players
they're so phenomenal but right now
there's little separating them on the
right hand side of our screen I think
all attention is on the left hand side
where there's much more tension and for
Fabiano who still has over three minutes
on the clock his time management has
probably been his best attribute today
and look at this move Knight back to
step forward into D4 he's trying to
crack down on White's defenses if you
could start trading some pieces in front
of that white king that F2 Pawn in
particular is especially vulnerable that
Rook on f8 can slide up to F4 that
Knight can go to D4 or to C5 there are
so many questions that Magnus needs to
answer he's got 35 seconds left this is
exceptional combination of being
strategic with the Knight maneuver along
with the sacrifice that we just saw an
ambitious player with the queen move
he's just combining all these different
aspects of the game and playing it to
Perfection once again in driver's seat
Fabiano Karana a queen trade on offer
this time does he go for it or perhaps
step forward with the queen to B3 trying
to maintain the tension the E4 Pawn is
also hanging there's a bunch of options
here for Fabiano I think he'll be really
reluctant to go into any end game so I'm
expecting the black queen to move away
and uh I'm not sure where exactly but
just keep the tension keep the pressure
on Magnus Carson right now the
evaluation bar might say it's kind of
only slightly in Black's favor but I
think in Practical terms big big
Advantage for Fabiano and I think
Fabiano is okay with lack of tension if
it means he's stealing pawns I like
Queen takes Pawn in the center and he
does as well I mentioned earlier he was
snacking on Pawns in game two snack on
one in game three he can just move his
Queen back somewhere that Knight on F3
cannot move the bishop on B6 the dark
Bishop on the left hand side of your
screen that left board that Bishop is
aiming towards the white king that Rook
next to the black king is aiming towards
the white king So Magnus took with his
Rook it was the only option now I think
the Black Knight it's the last piece to
join the party Move That Knight he goes
in it's coming to D3 this looks really
dangerous yeah Magus he's really walking
a tight rope right now he needs to find
super accurate moves just to stay alive
15 seconds for the world number one
fabbiano creating threats Knight to D3
that black knight jumping in further is
a monster threat how to defend against
it and there we see Magnus drops his
Knight back a big blunder according to
the evaluation bar can black just
continue the journey with his Knight can
you continue the journey or is there a
killer blow on the spot are there
sacrifices does Knight take spawn with
the ideaa of Queen sliding over to the
king side it's on the bo if the king
takes the Knight Queen G4 is that the
killer move that's game over that
there's nothing that Magnus can do his
King side isn't shambles he drops not
just a pawn but his defensive resources
and The Rook is going to slide in here
for black as well unless his King
becomes vulnerable Fabiano he's just in
charge he could take that Knight with
his Queen even he's up a pawn at minimum
game over simply no way Magnus Carson
survives this one we saw him lean back
in shock as Knight takes G2 that Knight
sacrifice appeared on the board and it
wasn't a surprise it felt like something
was brewing for a long time the
evaluation B was stubbornly stuck in the
middle but we were saying it momentum
black momentum black he takes with a
queen no risk attached to this at all
he's a pawn up and he's about to cash in
on the second Pawn on F2 three pawns
he's going to take on F2 a queen trade
will happen then his Rook will take the
pawn on B2 as well it's going to be
three extra pawns for five Carana in an
end game completely hopelessly lost for
Magnus and he goes for it uh Magnus is
going to need more of the miracle that
he survived in game one I don't see that
happen happening Fabiano Carana really
bringing his aame today Magnus Carlson
is about to go down in game three going
to go down in flam look at him he looks
away yeah he's devastated Magnus with 14
seconds kowana his clock handling has
been exemplary as well this game he's
just been dominant from start to finish
and magnus's only hope now is to somehow
leap forward with a white knight combine
it with White's rook and create some
counterplay but looks like a dream even
if black just ignores everything pushes
pawns it feels like black is winning uh
just on default here there's a red
carpet rolled out in front of that B
Pawn just push your past pawn and on the
right hand side of our screens we are
seeing some trades on offer there whoa
wait what in the right hand side it
looks like Wesley so just gave up the
pawn next to his King with check and the
Evo bar didn't react so some craziness
happening on the right hand side we'll
get to it but all attention is on
Fabiano Carana just a couple moments
away from beating the world number one
Magnus Carlson look at Magnus on the
camera just frustrated there just
throwing his pieces down the pieces he
was fiddling with he looks ready to get
out of here he looks ready to resign wh
King marching forward but what's the
plan there simply is none Black's B Pawn
is going to soon March down that board
he's not giving any chance to Magnus to
jump in with that Knight to F5 First
kicks The Rook out of the seventh Rank
and now the B Pawn will arrive on B4 he
Fabby playing extremely solid giving
absolutely no hope here and he pins that
Knight oh that's just nasty because the
Knight can't move anymore Rook trade is
completely losing he could push that B
Pawn at long last yeah he's going to do
it and a bit of a mirror image I just
want to say on the boards right now
black in both of the games has a dark
squared Bishop versus a knight black
both games has a Pawn on B5 a pass Pawn
on B5 it's as if the players are kind of
watching each other right now Magnus
coming in with the white King The Other
Board getting dramatic as well very
dramatic there was an E6 that was played
and it was completely ignored that is
high nerves by nbec what an amazing
decision there looks like Pawn on the
right hand side on the right board Pawn
takes Pawn his check but that Queen on
A2 it can actually capture that pawn so
you're not losing the house what a fine
by nbec abusar on the left hand side of
our screen we just saw Fabby he brings
his King to G8 if the white king goes up
diagonally it looks like it's in the
check main net but the black world can
kick the king away so that King Will
Survive and unfortunately for Magnus it
doesn't look like he will survive as the
B Pawn at long last is going up the
board and now the bishop dominates the
White Knight as well and Magnus will not
have enough pie is to fight against the
pawn the bishop defends the B2 Pawn next
and The Rook will go down to C1 to wrap
it up just don't get checkmated the
black king is out on its own the good
thing for well we see resignation that
one is over Fabiano in control from
start to finish Fabiano Gana takes the
second win and the lead in the match
with that backto back performance Magnus
Carlson has to win on demand a must- win
fourth game and we see it on Magnus he
is feeling the pressure he's on the
ropes and Fabiano is a punching Magnus
Carlson is lucky to even have one point
in this match Fabiano's completely
outplayed the world number one and
Fabiano has deserved his 2-1 lead and we
could see another 2-1 lead in this
matchup here because nbec abatar he
escaped the worst he's actually up upon
that pass B Pawn that Fabiano won with
not's trying to do the same but this
Pawn might drop there we go the White
Knight Retreats it's such a mirror image
it's also rook and Knight versus rook
and Bishop also a dark Square Bishop
also a B Pawn but that has disappeared
it's been traded for white H Pawn and
now two versus one in terms of Pawns on
the king side alone Knights are short-
range pieces they really Thrive against
Bishops when it's just one flank they
have to worry about this should be now a
draw looks like Wesley so escaped what
was a really dangerous end game there
Wesley can be feeling very relieved with
that he's under 30 seconds right now but
it shouldn't be too tough to hold it
given the clock situation as well with
such little material on the board uh and
I think what most black can hope for is
a rook Bishop versus rook in this oh but
that would be dangerous if you get that
we saw Magnus Carlson beat ala fuja just
yesterday in that kind of end game but
the good news for Wesley pawns are all
on the same side of the board as David
said Knights being short-range pieces
they are difficult pieces to use to
track down pawns on the other flank so I
think that Wesley's got everything under
control if the Rooks get traded it's
still going to be a draw there are many
ways for him to hold his Half Point yeah
Bishop for Knight trade draw Rook trade
draw everything here uh leading to to a
hold ball position he moves his Bishop
C1 keeping the game alive nybeck he got
to be careful not to push too hard like
he did in an earlier game but uh yeah it
was just the disappearance of that black
bwn that we saw as we jumped in uh that
secured this healthy save for Wesley so
I say save uh presumptuously but it
looks like uh nothing too much to worry
about will nbec trade the bishop for
Knight maybe the best bet right now uh
the only way to keep the game going he
oh he's going to push some pawns he's so
ambitious the youngster he's got this
Champions mentality of just fighting it
out till the very very end keeping as
many pieces on the board as much tension
on the board and making Wesley earn that
half point he's making Wesley sweat he
is and he's just challenging Wesley move
after move Wesley is putting up sturdy
defense and for nirc I've told the story
before but he was in a game where he was
actually down upon and a draw was
offered and he declined it so when he's
up a pawn there's no way he's just going
to give an easy draw to Wesley so he's
rerouting his Bishop watch out for for
Wesley I mean you just can't blunder
anything but all his pieces are defended
and it's always tricky cuz Wesley does
have a knight and it is a nbec who's
touching the 10c mark So NC has to be
just a little careful right now yeah you
don't want to walk into any night Forks
luckily the black king and black Rook
are on different color complexes
therefore cannot be forked by a knight
and now the pawns are rolling now the
pawns are pushing um one thing that you
mentioned another uh game in earlier in
the tournament Robert is that the bishop
and Rooks porn the bishop and black
eight Pawn they do not combine Black's H
Pawn promotes on a light Square
therefore white is able to maybe trade
off Rooks give up the White Knight for
Black's G Pawn later with a draw but
still a while away from that I'm proud
of you for bringing that up though cuz I
always mention and people get tired of
it but it's true that if the Rooks are
off the board all the Knight White
Knight has to do a sacrifice up for the
G pawn and here we see no continuing to
press he wants to push those pawns and
Tanya if we can get that rook and Bishop
versus Rook that does give notb back
legit chances and now that Pawn's on G4
maybe becomes vulnerable that's a big do
Target now and Black's Rook is perfectly
placed to start giving the check and
creating some pressure against that
white G4 Pawn right now you take the
Knight luckily for Wesley it comes in
with a check and the G4 Pawn still hangs
he's doing everything right though Abdu
satov he's putting pressure on White's
Knight and things are collapsing for
Wesley so this is a check oh the black
H6 Pawn is up for grab so he might be
holding but suddenly it's dangerous
suddenly you got to be really really
careful what is this end game magic that
nag always manages to create the white
king is could be an ating net if you're
not careful I thought that black king
was going to go forward up to F4 White
Knight it's trapped almost and you get
to take the PA with check and move your
Rook with check so you're now two full
pawns ahead is nck abaro Wesley so
shakes his head as the second Pawn drops
nck is winning this position but can he
finish the job I think he will finish
the job what has that white knight done
is committed the cardinal sin of placing
itself on the edge of the board and it's
not coming back blacks two pawns now
connected pass pawns should win this
game the black king should go up into
the position he goes back for a turn but
it can go forward and help deliver a
check minting net against the white king
and they two pawns there the Knight is
far away Wesley just making move after
move on the increment it looks like
right now n Beck is all under control
but just 7 seconds for nck the pawns
push forward bites rook and Knight
completely lacking any coordination in
this position and you can see Wy shaky
hands pure determination from nyb it's
just grit his hard work is paying off
one move away from winning that pawn is
about to get to H2 there two of them
black has two of the pawns though and
Wesley resigns n back Abdu satov also
gets the backto back Victory and takes
the lead in his match against Wesley so
the magic of Toronto comes to a stop for
Wesley maybe that script has flipped the
USC Phenom gets a win we saw a brief
smile on his face but ever the
competitor look at that Steely
determination he's going to get get
prepared get set for game four because
he knows Wes is going to give his all
wow amazing amazing stuff two players
who perhaps at the start of the day were
The Underdogs on the paper of course
extremely strong but who would bet
against Magnus Carlson and Wesley so and
right now it is these two names who are
playing catchup to Fabiano kirana and
nbec Abdu satov and that Magnus blunder
of falling retreating back with the
night it wasn't a one move blunder it
was incremental pressure by fav yeah
incremental pressure we were calling it
we were saying momentum black momentum
black things are turning threats are
appearing and that's when human error
Creeps in that's where the blunders
occur and in the end Magnus did slip up
Wesley sorry not Wesley Fabiano pounced
yeah and tough question to answer but
who's impressed you more right now so
far is it not a b or Fabby this is not
just taking the easy way out there's no
way to pick between them they both have
played Super super well with both colors
they've outlasted their opponents and
they continue to increase the pressure
it's as you said it's not a one mve
thing these blunders don't happen at
thin air for them it's just how much
pressure they're applying and their
opponents are not able to keep up they
really are not but they've got one more
rapid game and Magnus Carlson and Wesley
so have to they're in a must-win
situation it's not going to be easy
David two fantastic games excellent
chess played here what stood out to you
I'm just going to pick out Abdu soro's
ice cold moments where he showed no no
nerves at all and in the end crashed
through to win against Wesley so Abdu
sattorov actually had to find a really
cool move just to survive earlier in the
game and it was here that he played uh
after Pawn to E6 the ice called Bishop
C5 just moving out the way this E6 move
by Wesley was genius this Pawn is
Untouchable if you take it with the Rook
this would have landed a nasty back rank
Checkmate if you take with a pawn then
White's Queen jumps in with more mating
threats if you're taking with the queen
meanwhile then Black's Bishop on A7
would have fallen simply moving the
bishop was genius and if Pawn takes Pawn
as happened in the game Black's Queen
now swoops back to save the day and the
pressure on the White Queen meant that
we transitioned into an end game and if
we fast forward just one moment later a
few moves down the line we saw Wesley
eventually crack it was here in The Rook
end game still with a drawn position the
White Knight went in the wrong direction
he first needed to give a check forcing
the black king to make a decision and
then jumping with his Knight going for
the H Pawn instead always remember never
put your Knights on the edge of the
board he went the wrong way Knight C4
and got kicked to the edge of the board
a pawn dropped and Wesley lost and we
keep calling nir beaar the endgame
wizard the whiz kid but he's showing
fine tactical awareness to be able to
sacrifice his Queen the pawn could be
captured three different ways he doesn't
want it he finds the right solution and
he keeps applying that pressure it is
ceaseless it's really impressive so
impressive and just this Universal style
of his he's attacking he's is aggressive
when the position demands and Flawless
endgame technique sheer Brilliance
control of nerves those Steely stairs
this has been some amazing amazing
display of strength by nbec Abdu satro
and Kaa caught up with the man of the
moment the boy of the
moment momentum just seems to be the
word here in Toronto today nordbeck
taking another win congratulations yeah
thank you thank you what did you make
out of this
game yeah um he he prepared um this this
line I guess yeah after A4 B8 is not not
a good reaction but okay I just wanted
to you
know play some some rare move um but I
think he got a an advantage there and
after that I kind of played played well
and you know he he had a opportunity
several times to to go to end game with
Pawn up but um he tried to keep the
pressure but then he messed up and um I
got
um opportunity
to to to you know to win the pawn and
after Bishop C5 I guess he could have
played Rook
D5 which I wasn't sure I I think it's
pretty dangerous for black there like I
know Rook D5 Queen A7 I have to play
like E5 or something yeah it was it was
dangerous but he he didn't see it yeah I
mean yeah I'm quite happy that I managed
to win a you know drawn end game so yeah
it's just going well we've uh talked
about how difficult it is to beat the
solid Wesley so of course but getting
him into some time trouble there uh
playing an incredible end game is that
basically the
secret yeah I mean he's very shaky in
time trouble I
think um so yeah that was um that was
point in this in this game but uh
looking at another match we are doing
exactly same same results that's yeah
yeah that's that's funny actually so
we're going to have two players in must
win situations there in game four for
you a draw is enough to win the first
match so what can we expect from you
heading into game four um just I I'll
try you know to play good chess and yeah
we'll see uh congratulations again good
luck in the last one thank you all right
nbe up to saturo he's uh on a roll this
youngster back to you guys nbe with
quite a hot take there that Wesley saw
is shaky when the clock goes down he's
been fantastic so far it's still a
little early to congratulate nbec
because the job is far from over but we
can congratulate our winners of The L
contest and these vinyl records are
headed your way so big congratulations
to the winners and the records will be
signed by the winner of the Champions
Chester finals lot of
Celebration uh going on in the Champions
Chester final with some unexpected
semi-finals action world number two in
the lead against the world number one
the battle continues in Toronto after
this
[Music]
break
are you up for some puzzles James I hate
puzzles we have some puzzles you did
this last year right how' you do last
year yeah I did very poor I
I right to move 10 seconds yes yes got
another one that I've seen but I don't
remember the solution of course you seen
them all of course um
time um I think it's A4 so A4 is
incorrect okay in game you know you like
those come on you got this one but not
sacrificing three points and then
winning you actually are on something
there what you got a H5 what okay now I
got another 10
seconds I'm going to guess that it is uh
it's
A4 Bishop A3 and then I think it's
Knight C5 there n that's it is you got
to reverse it reverse this flip it
around flip it flip everything you close
A4 is in there so the problem is in my
mind it's like I'm trying recall
something rather than calculate because
like I know seen right correct correct
this one I might actually fail cuz like
I mean it's probably H5 yeah yes and
here of course there's a debate yeah
right yeah G6 take yep E6 got him Bishop
A3 is forced and this is like the only
moment that will trip me up oh wait I
can I can play Knight C5 take no I I'm
not what is it is I think it's uh H5
takes G6 takes E6 Bishop A3 yep and then
white looks totally
lost give away two c for nothing I mean
on the glance I would guess H5 GH G6 E6
then Knight B4 and the pawn queen and
and A4 exactly beautiful beautiful and I
think it's might be G6 F E6 Bishop A3
Knight B4 Bishop B4 A4 hot stop the [__]
stop he keep going that's it that's it
you got it right he
su E6 Bishop A3 let's go Dennis okay
Bishop takes one more let's go let's go
ah let's
go H5 H yeah GH G6 yep takes FG
mm yeah E6
okay Bishop A3 yeah only move yeah
didn't like before fish F before got
them let's
go um wait do I have Knight B4 take A4
that's it there we go dub come on I know
I don't know what it is the problem I
need a fresh one so that my mind is not
actually trying to remember cuz then I
spend like 5 Seconds trying to remember
fresh ones guys we need fresh ones forar
he's seen them all guys he's seen them
all no Taro has seen this one recall
test for him so you seen it
before right white the move 10 seconds I
know
it's I know okay well go ahead
definitely tell the camera we got I'll
just say queen of 5 check oh yeah queen
of FO check in the end yeah yeah it's
probably my least favorite type of
puzzle yeah correct that is 100% correct
I've seen it but like I I don't yeah
it's so annoying because I I don't want
to uh no I would go with Perpetual if I
if I I was playing in BL in bullet yes
we wrote F yeah not that's not the
solution of course yeah I have no idea
yeah
I'm going to guess that it's Bishop
takes E6 nope nope okay Knight F6 or
something Knight F6 baby okay he got the
right move but she got to finish it
though bro he got that chip in his brain
bro he got the chip Knight of six
exactly right throw the iPad like what
is this no no way no way no way no no no
way no I I I would of course I would if
I would think like 1 hour or you
probably find it yeah so Knight of6
Bishop takes C3 E3 F3 and then after
King takes G6 oh there's Queen to F5 and
Bishop H7 there it is toal iPad ah queen
of five oh heat he got it let's go fyro
let's go baby yes sir ah queen of five
come on there it is yeah nice very nice
very nice that's a pretty one a pretty
one very hard it's been very difficult
well I'm interested to see how I guess
hear would be the best here yeah or
maybe F yeah we have to recall kind of
actually seen it one that's seen it
before but I have no chance
congratulations on winning the event in
fact I mean uh getting well I'm I'm just
waiting for the check waiting for the
check but we warmed you up Wesley you
feeling warmed up baby come on man Flex
so here right thank you very much
congratulations on all your success man
we'll see you in the turnament I hope I
can Fu my queen like that please we'll
love to see
it
[Music]
beautiful metal posters and we've got so
many of the chess themed one just for
you you'll find some fantastic holiday
gifts idea is there so head straight to
display.com chess and there's a very
cool 33% off uh use the code chess and
find the perfect holiday gifts for all
the chess lovers around you and for now
all the action is happening in the city
of Toronto and it is heating up in set
one of the semifinals we've had such
unpredictable results Magnus Carlson and
wesle so are playing catch up to Fabiano
Carana and nbec Abdu satro so much
dramatic action turnarounds we've seen
Brillion sees we've seen uh and uh Kaa
caught up with Fabby after his third
round Victory what a
performance here with Fabiano Carana
that's two in a row you take the lead
here Fabby what was that like yeah I
think it was a very interesting game I
was putting a lot of pressure on him at
some point because he misplayed it with
Bishop G5 for sure it's not a good move
and um yeah and then I got this very
beautiful Knight on F4 Bishop on B6 I
felt like I was pressing for an
advantage
um of course once I was already
completely winning I started to make it
messy in time trouble okay probably
never really messy but getting low on
time and and making it a bit too close
but overall very happy with this game
yeah and Magnus even lower on time uh
blundering there in a little bit of um
time trouble so how does it feel to be
able to force him into that time trouble
yeah no I I this was the kind of game I
was hoping for also in the first game I
was hoping for a very double-edged fight
that's why I chose this opening um
because you really had a tough fight
it's very risky for both sides and I
felt like my chances in the match might
lie in in these types of positions um of
course it's still one tough game to go
yeah well uh you're you talk about the
opening here m is with the white pieces
going into something that you made a
chessable course on so you are obviously
very familiar with that so um are you
happy when you see he comes there with
that how do I say
Archangel yeah well the chestful course
is called the dark Archangel and uh yeah
I I made this course but it's not
exactly what I recommend what I played
today so it's I played this line against
Alexander Guk in 2021 and I haven't
really played it since but uh it's a
very interesting line very sharp the
computer doesn't like it for black but
it's not so easy if you don't know it
especially too well then it's really
tricky for both sides so having white in
the final game to win the match how
confident are you feeling right now I
think I'm playing better and I'm feeling
confident but of course these must-win
situations they have their own um yeah
they there specific demands and uh we
saw that Magnus was in the situation
against Ali Resa I hope to do better
than Ali resed good luck in the final
rapid game thank you all right thanks
for joining us Fabiano car he's in the
lead back to you guys he is in the lead
and really interesting insight there by
Fabby how chess is about posing the
biggest practical questions to your
opponent even if it means not making the
best moves David it was quite a game
three by Fabby what impressed you the
most well it was uh the use of the
opening the way he outmaneuvered Magnus
in the middle game started creating
threats and he used the dark Archangel
and it was dark storm clouds gathering
around the white king Fabiano in this
position set up a really sneaky threat
and Magus fell into the Trap Black's
Bishop already perfectly poised aiming
at the F2 Square The Rook indirectly
hitting the square as well Black's Queen
on a Super Active post he asked the
Knight to join the action Knight to F4
trying to come into D3 and this is where
time trouble played its part with one
hour on his clock Magnus might have
found the saving idea of going on the
attack against Black's King a really
difficult one to find though Knight to
G4 with the idea that the tactic that
happened in the game Knight takes G2
would have allowed a Counterattack
Knight takes H6 and actually here white
has his fair share of the chances but of
course no time to spot that extremely
difficult Magnus instead retreated the
Knight and walked into the real trap
Knight takes G2 bang Fabiano spotted his
chance and The Black Queen simply coming
across the white king stripped of its
shelter King takes Knight The Black
Queen gave a check won the material back
and a few moves later black emerged with
a three point Advantage fantastic play
by Fabiano yeah unlike in Harry Potter
there is no defense against the dark
Archangel so Fabio Carana continues to
use that to his success Magnus Carlson
he's been struggling at this stage he is
down by a point and during the rest
period he was all by himself not to
steal a Selene Dion song That's a
classic but for Magnus this is New
Territory being down in the match four
games yeah they say it's Lonely at the
Top but right now it's lonely for Magnus
Carlson in the playing Arena and you can
just tell that this is not the narrative
that he was expecting on day one of the
semi-finals there is of course the big
game four that's coming up for both
Magnus and Wesley they are in a must-win
uh situation to take it to Armageddon
it's not just the score line both nbec
and Fabby have just been been dominating
today yeah two to one doesn't even
really Encompass what we've seen I think
that they could have already won the
match the two of them first at two and a
half points takes the match both Fabby
and ner could almost be upset that they
don't already have that score yeah wow
and what are we expecting because uh it
means that nbec uh sorry Wesley and
Magnus both start with the black pieces
as well and uh they've got to get the
job done with black otherwise it is set
one over and in just a few seconds we
will have the action as the play are
ready to go Wesley with the black pieces
handshakes how does he create his
chances it's not going to be easy it's
not Wesley's style to go all out with
black he normally plays really rock
solid and uh wow Pawn to D6 already that
hints at a pick a pitz uh defense and
this is provocative stuff he's giving
white the center he's uh asking AB St to
come for him I'm going down memory lane
a little bit but didn't Wesley didn't he
need to win with the black piece as
Maxim Vash lra just a couple days ago he
played some kind of dodgy opening line
Maxim was much better according the
engines but pressed a little bit too far
and Wesley was able to win that game and
go through in the arm again so Wesley he
has that experience and while Magnus
waits for his game to start he is
looking for inspiration in this one
watching as the action unfolds it's kind
of like a king's Indian defense setup by
Wesley of course white spawn is still on
C2 right now but it's exactly the
approach we see top level chess players
have whether it's Hikaru or Wesley when
their back is against the wall they
often go for these faneto positions out
of the opening yeah and uh the top
players they borrow ideas from each
other that's maybe why there is this
trend to just kind of occupy the first
two or three ranks allow the opponent to
come for you in these must-win
situations with black and how funny
would it be if Magnus after watching
this game repeats Wesley's opening
copies and uh at least all the pieces
are on the board so uh no forcing Lines
no end games which Abdus sator thrives
in clearly uh Wesley I think he's at
least chosen A wise choice here in the
uh beginning to keep chances of life for
later and happy memories I just checked
I was right he did beat Maxim Vash lra
from the black side of this opening it
wasn't the opening that was able to
secure him that Victory it was down the
line but he has some good fond memories
of playing this from the black side that
said what nbec is doing is the right
thing he's not just playing passively
keeping his pieces on his first few
ranks he in fact brought his Bishop out
and is playing a standard way against
the
PS all right this one is going to be a
battle and this one will also be a war
as the players are getting ready
handshakes will be and there we are we
are about to start big question will
Magnus take similar setups as the one
that we saw with Wesley and I think we
very well could happen on the board
we've seen him employ the hippo where he
develops the pawn on the sixth rank
takes out pieces in a kg way just to
avoid any trades David you know Magnus
best what is going on in his mind about
his opening approach right now he's just
wondering how to throw Fabiano off how
to get out of the books and uh how to
ensure he avoids preparation it was
funny as you were talking there Tanya I
was thinking what would I do I would
probably play B6 and then Magnus played
it he beat me to the punch but uh this
move it's uh very provocative again
doesn't fight directly for the center
but it does allow Black's light squar
Bishop to fear in ketto so um it depends
on how Fabiano approaches this does he
try to punish black for giving away the
center giving away a bunch of central
squares or does he just try to transpose
into better known Waters he plays F3 one
of the most ambitious moves here Robert
trying to build the biggest Pawn Center
possible for white I think it's a good
decision from Fabiano because it does
make your uh diagonals a little bit
loose your dark squares can be taken
advantage of later but you're playing in
a principal manner if your opponent is
playing on the flank you play in the
center so the F3 move to play E4 next I
am interested to know why Fabiana was
thinking at this stage I think he can
even take the Knight to try to bring a
black piece in the center then strike
with E4 to gain a Tempo so far so good
for fabbi but I like the choice for
Magnus nonetheless you have to play
something that's offbeat that does not
allow a force draw and while white is
better at least black will have some
long-term chances yeah both sides get
what they want Fabiano will maybe obtain
a small space Advantage with white very
healthy position Magnus gets a
non-orthodox porn structure and active
pieces of his own as he pauses he's
about to recapture the piece and he's
just deciding how to recapture that
piece but I think either way that he
takes it it's the queen that's coming
out yes I was about to say that the E
Pawn will move forward gaining space
over the center also opening up the path
for the bishop to come into an active
Square perhaps
C4 yeah I like White's position I've got
to say Robert yeah I'm just imagining
Magnus reflecting on Wesley's position
why couldn't I get something like that
and the reason why is that Fabiano
started 1 D4 we didn't really talk about
his first move but he's historically
loved playing E4 the Kings Pawn push on
move one he chose D4 to play a more
solid setup and for Magnus looking at
this position where is he going to
counter what pawns is are he going to
throw forward it looks like white just
has the upper hand because of the
dominance in the center I like white
center White's Knight will happily
develop to the square in front of the
king and it just looks like Harmony in
white pieces meanwhile black still has
to figure out the piece setup that you
want the ideal Square for that Knight
would be for the Black Knight would be
C6 but that comes in the way of magnus's
Bishop right now
what do you think about this surprise
that you mentioned earlier that Fabby
starts with 1 D4 this ambitious approach
of going with the F3 opening we're just
seeing Fabby not back down against
Madness he's declining repetitions in
positions in complicated positions he's
going all out it's like a Fabby 2.0 yeah
I was actually planning to save this for
later to kind of see how the uh kind of
match results panned out first but I
want to say Magnus and Wesley are
victims of their own success yesterday
they pretty much had a day off yes they
had to play some chess but they were
both qualified there was nothing on the
line um so kind of mentally it was easy
to check out and lose momentum whereas
kowana and Abdu satoro they had to do it
the hard way they had to play high
stakes games they had to keep the focus
keep the form keep the momentum and
clearly they're fresher today uh so far
at least and uh Magnus Wesley it feels
like they're taking a bit of time to get
back in the zone and we see this quite
often in sports a team that gets a buy
because of their own success then they
might get off to a sluggish start
because they're well rested but they
don't have that on the field or in this
case on the board experience or Knight
C6 that Knight leaps out it puts
pressure on Fabiano Center even though I
like Fabi Center I also like the
approach from Magnus he is not allowing
a series of Trades he's putting
questions in Fabiano's court and I'm
looking at the clocks as well Magus is a
bit behind but I think Fabiano is going
to have to burn some clock to try to
figure out how to defend the center is
Magnus going to Castle queenside he's
done it before a few times this
tournament just to imbalance it just to
provoke the opponent he has to try
something a bit spicy a bit unorthodox
as we mentioned I think Magnus is going
to go long with his with his King and
ask questions before white has completed
development yeah uh things will
definitely get very interesting in both
these games as Wesley and Magnus have to
create their chances with black to try
to strike back and take the match to
Armageddon and we've been talking so
much about fabby's form his excellent
play and the kind of fighting chest that
he's bringing to the board against the
world number one today and who better to
get further insights Dan a good friend
of Fabby and Levy is in Toronto joined
by grandmas Christian Killa right now
let's head over to
Levy thank you Tanya yes I'm standing
here alongside Christian Cilla
Grandmaster one half of the world famous
soon to be award-winning C squar podcast
chess coach uh director of Chess
programs Christian how are you very good
very good great to be here with you uh
Gotham chess Levy how should I call you
just call me Levy call me leevy or
Gotham you could call me you can you can
call me either or uh how's your
experience been in Toronto what are you
uh what's your role here as you're
traveling with Fabiano oh it's been
amazing uh I live in Columbia Missouri
which is a very small college town so
it's always nice to visit the big cities
I'm having good time uh as of my role
here it's mostly just content creator
I'm Fab's friend I'm not helping him at
all he usually doesn't um travel with
trainers when he plays rap and Blitz
okay classical it's a completely
different story but rap and Blitz you
just simply don't have the time uh to do
uh the preparation in between games yeah
I was going to ask you speaking of the
preparation big storyline today is that
he had two games on the black side in
the arhangel or the Archangel which we
have now completely changed and stolen
that name which is totally not what that
name is but the Archangel of uh opening
which was his chessable course uh what
are your impressions of those two games
was it a surprise that Magnus entered
something that had just made a course on
or was it a statement he was trying to
make cuz it did kind of backfire well I
actually told him uh last night to play
his course um just to advertise with oh
okay I mean's he's been uh looking at
this particular opening for a very long
time he definitely has the extra
experience compared to everybody else
and I I don't know for sure but I don't
think Magnus checked his course all I
can say is by the course okay by the
course and it was an experiment gone
right because what if Fabiano played it
twice and went o02 right that's then he
would have said well I didn't have my
lines down or you know Magnus then the
sales go down yes then so I mean but it
but it was a good business decision so
you are kind of here like trainer I mean
you know you got to I'm just giving him
a random advice random advice basically
What It Is Well it paid off in the black
games we have a game up here on the
screen uh most of it is just the two of
them having a staring contest M um but
uh must-win situation for Magnus who now
has to win with black you're impress
question how's the game looking I
actually cannot see the game very well
but from my understanding obviously
Magnus is going to try to imbalance the
position which makes perfect sense uh
and he did that actually in uh the
playoffs at the beginning of the
tournament and he got a good position
with the black pieces he managed to
outplay Faby in that one so definitely
Magnus has some good experience wants to
win knows what the result that he's
seeking is in this particular game so he
not going to be easy why is Fabby not
playing Knight to E2 defending the pawn
what else is there in this position is
he thinking maybe bishop B5 to trade the
bishop to completely neutralize the
pressure on the side Bishop B5 D5 maybe
uh but generally you don't want to play
D5 in this part particular position you
want to keep the pawn on D4 maybe go
Knight D2 Castle Queen D2 Rook to D1
defend that Central structure and play
it as it is play for space Advantage
last thing before we throw it back to
Oslo Fabiano himself I'm pretty sure has
said that in this exact situation it's a
little bit of a struggle for him
sometimes where he's up one game he has
to not like you you just have to not
lose you can play for a draw you can
play for a win and he he has this exact
situation right now so any thoughts
about that especially against Magnus
especially against Magnus because
against Magnus you know that he plays on
a regular basis these type of very
imbalanced positions you know he has the
experience and generally you know as the
player with the white pieces you don't
experience these type of situations very
often but at the same time he's a
professional player he's one of the best
CH players on the planet he knows what
he needs to do and he will have to
execute yeah Christian thank you so much
for joining us we're going to go back
out there eat some uh hummus eat some
chips we'll throw it back to you guys in
Oso Tanya take it away always a pleasure
thanks Levy Fabby does uh need to
execute and right now he needs to
execute his next move because he's been
on a bit of a long think already he's
touching the 4minute mark on a move that
at least in my eyes looks like something
that you need to make in about 2 minutes
time you want to develop that Knight to
the center of the board the D4 Pawn
which is currently attacked by three of
black pieces defended by two of white
species why is he thinking so much right
now what's going on in Fab's head I
think he's calculating a bit too much
sometimes these positions you just have
to play on fi whether it's uh just
Knight to E2 as Levy said you can play
that move in two seconds de with the
consequences later uh whether it's the
other moves that Christian there
suggested D5 Bishop B5 at some point you
just have to make a decision no no move
kind of sticks out and uh Magnus will be
able to create some complications either
way but burning four five minutes giving
Magnus four five minutes there as well
to think has resulted in this position
he could have played knight2 first may
maybe made Magnus pause and thought on
magnus's clock um it does feel like the
nerves are creeping in here Robert maybe
it's a position where I think many
people would want to trade the Queens
let me take this Pawn on E5 and trade
the Queens but black dark Square Bishop
is ready to go out and give a check to
the white king I think this would be
very bad for white taking on E5 allowing
Bishop B4 check first when the king
slides out to F2 let's say that E5 Pawn
can be gobbled up at any moment and the
white king is not safe a queen trade
doesn't mean that we're getting a draw
necessarily huge Advantage for black I
would say huge Advantage for black and
uh in the match this could be a decisive
turn so do not get tempted the problem
is if you don't take this Pawn your
other options aren't too appealing for
example stepping forward maybe the most
natural move in the position would allow
a forcing variation the Knight will come
attack the bishop only one safe Square
for it it will have to drop back and uh
black would then break open the white
structure this beautiful connect for
structure will be broken down from the
front due to a pin on the defile so
Fabiano's gone a different direction
he's first pinned that black knight this
is what he was thinking about all that
time and uh the big question is after
Pawn takes Pawn Knight takes can Magnus
profit from the tension on the defile
feels really shaky you cannot take this
Knight though due to a pin on this
diagonal as well it's getting tactical
hence why Fabby spent the time but uh
Magnus now with a clock advantage and a
really imbalanced position to work with
yeah and Magnus is the player who takes
advantage of even the most minute
details in the position and the fact
that Fabby on move number 11 went into a
4 and 1 half minute think that shakiness
that hesitancy in the opening it's got
to be making Magnus feel more confident
about his uh outcome here I think the
board is just a state of affairs where
Magnus should be feeling good about
having winning chances it's still a
level position we see the eval bar off
the side but it's not just a symmetrical
structure there's still so many pieces
on the board but I like Fabiano's
decision because this challenges black
setup as well it's not all fun for
Magnus he doesn't get to initiate the
pawn breaks now there's a lack of
clarity and he can slide a rook to the
SE file apply more pressure I don't
think that fabi's in trouble but I don't
like his clock management that's been
his key to success his X Factor has been
leading Magnus on the clock yeah we've
been talking about that Fab's not only
been putting pressure on the board but
also on the clock but this one feels
like a different narrative from the very
start and while we're checking out uh
two of our favorite players in the world
don't forget to check out some of your
favorite TW T twins Tunes as the LOI
girl and chess.com partnership continues
and we've got some great music it's the
one that you've been listening to at the
start of the stream at the end of the
stream and hopefully while you're
playing chess as well and you can find
it on your favorite streaming platform
on YouTube on Spotify and on Soundcloud
hopefully the players have also been
listening to some lowy music to get into
the Mind Zone to play some chaotic chess
as well because this position is quite
chaotic that Bishop on B5 played right
now white also wants to try to get the
Deep on moving forward if mag was to
give a check on B4 how is white reacting
yeah it's getting sharp it's getting
concrete black can steal White's
castling rights bless you Fabby with
that sneeze there black can give a check
making sure that the white king will not
Castle the white king will be obliged to
step away I'm assuming this Square
because you want to connect Rooks as
quickly as possible and uh the problem
is again after a capture you still
cannot take this Knight due to this pin
so have you helped white this is the big
question the white looks like it's out
in the open cannot Castle but maybe
accelerates White's development Black's
Bishop on B4 might at some point have to
step back um the move I'm looking at is
actually a capture and then just trying
to get out of the way of this pin maybe
moving the black queen out the way for
example and the reason I like this for
black is because White's King is a bit
of a Target there's a nasty check in the
air you've also opened up the rook and
uh White here would be forced to trade
off the beautiful Bishop pair and uh in
this position yes white can Castle yes
white can get out the way but there are
enough imbalances for black to work with
also still this pin which could be quite
annoying long term for example if black
moves out the way Bishop coming out to
C5 Fabby would have some serious answers
uh serious questions questions even to
answer uh so sharp stuff right now
Narrow Path maybe for black to kind of
keep the tension keep playing
aggressively but Magnus surely he'll
find a continuation that he likes Magnus
Carlson uh undoubtedly the most
dangerous player on the planet and he
gets even more dangerous when his back
is against the wall and he's managed to
create Chances with black in this one we
will check in with Wesley so who is in
the same matth situation as a Magnus
with the black pieces in a must win and
to me it looks like he's managed to do
the same that Bishop from F5 is eyeing
the C2 pawn and uh I mean I just want to
ask you can he start getting greedy
already can he pick up that pawn he can
definitely capture that pawn on C2 and
Wesley will go up material but what
nybeck is aiming for is a potential
attack against the black king there is
this annoying pin from that Queen on E3
towards that Queen on B6 the Knight
can't easily move so Bishop takes Pawn
on C2 Pawn to E6 sure black can sidp all
this with Pawn push to F5 but now your
Bishop on C2 maybe it's a little bit too
deep in enemy territory your knight on
C5 is tender as I mentioned your king
it's a bit more exposed now you're
pushing Pawns in front of it so even
though black is better objectively
speaking the evaluation Bar says that
the players don't know that so it's a
risky Pawn for Wesley to grab that's the
thing Bishop takes Pawn uh from a human
point of view it's either very good or
it's very bad so Wesley's weighing up
those options if he can survive and
remain a pawn up later in the middle
game he's he will go for it and uh if
not if he thinks this bishop might get
trapped he cannot touch that pawn and
white would then get time to plant a
knight on D4 kick the bishop protect C2
and the game would continue so this
might be a once uh in a game opportunity
to take this Pawn to take a big risk I
think the match situation kind of
suggests you should take this pawn and
go for it ask Abdu sator to prove the
compensation but it does take nerves of
Steel and it's not normally Wesley style
to be greedy and to kind of allow an
attack he wants to keep more control so
big moment I'm not sure even if I need
the computer evaluation that I would
take this spawn because it looks so
dangerous for black yeah and that move
E6 definitely has nightmares for Wesley
from their second game in which nag just
exploded blacks King side and it has
been stopped Wesley doesn't want to see
another E6 in this match it's a great
practical decision from Wesley because
in order to play Bishop takes T2 you
would have to invest so much time and
you look at the clocks nyck he's up
about 40 seconds but to be sure to be
absolutely certain that you can get away
with Bishop takes C2 you need to spend a
few more minutes so E6 now you've taken
that out of Whit hands the E5 Pawn is a
long-term weakness cemented in place B2
is loose C2 is loose and I feel like
Wesley made a very very good decision
right here and look at narck he goes
Knight to D4 and Eva bar still prefers
black some simple moves yeah some simple
moves now trying to make use of the
tension between the queens and uh before
I could highlight it the Queens are off
the board endgames favor Black now
because of the weakness of White's E5
pawn and Wesley can he outmaneuver the
endgame mro himself now Abdu sattorov
that's the big question Advantage black
but is it enough he still needs to be
really accurate to prove that he has any
winning chances whatsoever White Knight
threatening to jump into C5 still
anyone's game and we've been talking so
much about nbec and his end game play
and just how good he is once the Queens
get traded off and that's usually at
least traditionally conventionally
thought of as a trait that the
youngsters it's not their Forte it's not
the kind of positions that they like to
enjoy but nck has been on his top game
once the Queens are off the board is it
reminiscent of how good Magnus is in end
games that is a huge standard to live up
to I think Noir backck with Contin play
we'll see if he can handle it but he is
the youngest World rapid champion in
history so when you're comparing to a
historic player like Magnus Carlson no
derck himself has had an historic
achievement so he you know is amazing
endgame player we also saw during the
break those tactics that he was Finding
with James kanty that was a lot of fun
but right now he's not going to have fun
because he's got this eyes sore a
backwards deep on and Wesley's targeting
it and I'm also thinking about those NB
back stairs that we've been seeing it
reminds me of a young Magnus cson
sitting across Gary CASRO with his
stairs not backing down of course it's a
far way off but uh really fascinating to
see the parallels the universal style
between these two players we do have the
end game the dwn has moved forward so at
least defending the E5 but now David the
base comes Under Fire with an open D
line yeah open D line blacks pieces as
well creeping in big attack now against
White's B2 Pawn the Black Knight jumping
Black's Bishop will rot itself will come
to a better diagonal in the next few
moves it's definitely Advantage black I
think we would uh well at least I would
choose black here I think you can speak
for me David it's it's nod for him
Robert and uh it is just about whether
Abdus can keep control yes he has ugly
pawns especially the base Pawn on D4 but
one weakness you might be able to hold
and whoa C5 Wesley doesn't want to play
the long game he wants the tension Here
and Now lashing out I kind of like it
because he probably felt that given time
no deck would be able to save off the
pressure and keep everything under
control but right now that's a free pawn
two different white pieces can take it
and just like a game ago where no deck
won with black and Wesley gave away a
pawn that couldn't be captured here it
can but you take with the pawn you lose
your E5 Pawn if you take with your
knight you lose your D4 pawn and maybe
E5 next so we are seeing the position
change completely still chances for
Wesley to over overtake I should say and
outplay nir
B wow all right so Wesley so with the
black pieces has managed to create a
dynamic end game we will keep our eye
out on this one let's head over to our
other fight and wow there is a lot going
on I'm taking it all in Black's Bishop
looks like it's hanging but let's point
out the pin along the defile so you
really can't go for Knight takes Bishop
cuz Rook takes Queen comes in with a
check you don't have time to capture
Black's Queen the first question that
I'm going to throw to you guys is white
really wants to get the king to safety
there's also a threat of the queen
jumping into B4 he does it but the
evalar reacts because the D4 Knight
comes Under Fire yeah I don't want to
boast but I did predict this whole
variation of earlier I showed it on the
board and I think castling was just a
bit premature um Whit King needs to get
to safety yes but actually it could have
been okay in the center for a move or
two longer it was more important to uh
Evacuate the White Queen from this
defile pin the White Queen if it had
moved would have freed up the White's
Knight to pounce and suddenly Fabiano
he's pinned left right and Center
Black's Bishop is threatening to come
out to C5 that would be the end of the
game on the spot and it might be
collapsing Here and Now Queen F6 Magnus
the speed with which he pounced and
played it I think he suddenly realized
this is a golden opportunity yeah and
he's got a double the amount of time on
the clock as well a Fabby a very
difficult position to defend in under
four minutes he's looking at a second
rank defense wants to slide over the
rook in front of the queen yeah but he's
going to defend but Black's going to do
the same you first bring your Bishop out
to pin that Knight some more The Rook
comes to D2 then you just slide your
Rook up for black I mean white is
defending for now but black can increase
the Firepower and white can't bring
another piece to defend so I believe the
knight at this stage would have to step
back to the C2 Square I want to point
out that Knight F5 I don't think will
work out either but the B2 Pawn is loose
in so many's position I was going to go
for this queen sacrifice David you got
me there uh that if you take you take on
E3 with check and then Rook takes D2 at
the end you have a rook and two Bishops
for a queen that's too much material we
do a quick count 11 points for black
just nine for the queen for white so I
think that five have to step back to C2
but then the B2 Pawn is loose in many of
these positions is no fun I think that
Fabiano even after Rook to d8 he just is
under immense pressure too much pressure
as you say Robert it's uh not just this
diagonal it's the defile it's all about
this Knight and wow this is all
happening if Magnus moves his Rook it
looks like he has a decisive decisive
Advantage bring the final piece to the
party it's this Rook on h8 it wants to
be on the defile stack them up double
them up and white is collapsing Fabiano
in big big trouble in the next few moves
it looks like Fabby is about to lose
material in the position literally
pinned from Left Right and Center in
this one
big big pressure I think Magnus we saw
him there reach out and he has moved the
Rook forward does Fabby have any time
any hope at all to try to unpin with
that Knight jumping on to either F5 or
falling back to C2 same tactics I think
if you move the White Knight to F5 as we
show The Black Queen can sacrifice black
would emerge with extra pieces extra
material the White Knight drops back
maybe the best bet right now uh White's
oh it's really hanging by a thread I
don't think Fabiano uh is going to be
able to escape this one simply 3 minutes
on the clock yes but so much to
calculate there's so much tension so
many Alternatives too many tactics I
think for Fabian on the left hand side
of our screen he can also move his King
to the corner that way some pieces
aren't captured with check but you see
the Eva bar still in Black's favor
there's way too much to work through
maybe the computer can find some kind of
wild defense but for Fabiano he's just a
mere mortal it's not going to be simple
and I see Wesley I just saw him in the
right hand side of our screen his night
jumped into E3 watch out there may be
some check meting ideas against the
white king if that Knight can jump over
to the king side Knight G4 do not lift
your Rook off the first rank if you're
noar back up dusar that could actually
end badly wow and White's Knight
Retreats backward Knight moves of the
hardest to spot Abdu satov on the right
Board of our screens I think he can
force a draw right now the other white
knight can start retreating Black's Rook
is tied down to the defense of his own
Knight and look at what he's doing he
drops his Knight back into the center
Black's Rook forced away White's Knight
continues to harass this black rook and
position repeats itself the only way to
keep Black's Knight alive is to repeat
and draw and handshake Abdu satov takes
it it's handshakes Abdu satov wins set
one of the semi-finals against Wesley so
he was the underdog on paper but he
shows why he is absolutely at the top of
his game and here to stay and fight for
this Championship West so has to win
second set to keep it going and ever the
chess player n Bea bisar he looks at
what's happening between Fabiano Carana
and Magnus Carlson he's not looking
ahead to a potential final matchup he
just loves chess he wants to see the
best of the best play and he is one of
the best players so he's right there
with them but right now we do have this
other game going Tanya and Fabby he's in
trouble where nybeck was not and I'm
just thinking nck was the chosen one
Wesley chose to play against nck is that
a decision he's got to be regretting
that right now yeah he had to choose
between two evils he chose his own
poison Wesley so and it looks like
that's backfiring but another chance
tomorrow it's the best of three sets
tomorrow's second set will be vital so
uh still chances for Wesley so to fight
back Magnus kson trying to fight back in
this game I like the simple approach
that you mentioned earlier Robert just
bring that final piece in Blacks rook in
the corner slide it to the center back
up double your Rooks and uh still
pressure on fabian's position but for
now uh he is holding things together
Knight back to C2 was an important move
to find and it's hard to fault Wesley so
for picking n dearbeck because when you
look at what Fabiano's done in three
games against Magnus Carlson not much
easier of an opponent not easier at all
so we are going to focus in on this game
here the Knight did Retreat to C2 the B2
Pawn is loose because that Queen on F6
is staring that direction and Magnus I
mean he's been like this all day I don't
know if he's uh you know feeling under
the weather or if he's just bored but
even Bor Magnus is great at the board
and he just slides his Bishop back so no
trades allowed to Fabiano okay I didn't
actually have this move on my radar I
was looking at the forcing lines the
direct routs tradeoff pieces go for
pawns uh try to capture stuff try to
turn your advantage into something
material uh but he's simply dropping
back saying the bishop pair is good
enough the white king not entirely safe
no Defenders around it and uh we know
the bishop pair how strong they are
Black's other Rook will join Black's
pawns on the king side might throw
themselves forward still a big Advantage
long term and uh big advantage on the
clock more importantly and things are
just starting to get messy things are
just starting to get complicated for
white here we can imagine the bishop and
the queen lining up on the diagonal
hitting that H2 Pawn a Defender key
defender on the king side for White's
King right now another question for
Fabby the B2 Pawn is hanging I like this
approach by Magnus he wants to keep the
tension on the bishop PA is not allowing
any trade Fabby ignoring any threats on
the B2 Pawn lining up against magnus's
King
yeah a good move activating his final
piece I was talking about the black Rook
joining the party that white Rook was
fast asleep snoring in the corner and uh
at least it's staring down the black
king but I don't see any direct threats
and that that means Magnus does have the
luxury of time to activate his piece
look at the centralization for Black's
Rooks right now feels like something is
brewing something is in the air there's
going to be some kind of Bishop takes
Pawn on H2 with sha I don't know when
it's going to happen but it looks like
with all of these pieces staring down
the defile black is going to win that
ble you usually do when there's a queen
in line with a rook Queen E1 play I
actually think you can take this Pawn
with check I think Magnus can grab it
and then take on The Rook on D2 and at
the end he's got this queen check that
will pick up his sacrifice Bishop but I
would be a little bit nervous if I were
Magnus because that Rook on C1 it stares
through the Knight towards the black
Bishop on C6 there will be things to
work out but I do believe Magnus can
snag that pawn on H2 and there he goes
wow Greek gift sacrifice normally we
would say when it comes to sacrificing
on this type of square but this one is
based on double attacks geometry we see
forcing moves the king had to recapture
a trade of Rooks and uh Robert The Sting
in the tail as you mentioned the black
queen sliding to D6 Fabiano pauses does
he have any other option he's currently
Down The Exchange Rook for Knight he has
to Simply take back and allow this check
to come black will win back the
sacrificed piece here we go double
attack check and black will profit porn
up in the end game yeah and playing
Magnus Carlson down upon the rook and
Bishop combining and that pawn isn't any
pawn there is a potential of the H Pawn
marching down the board in the end game
creating a rook Pawn passer which are
the hardest to fight for Knights on the
board and Fabiano Karana has to do this
uphill defensive task under 30 seconds
no chance I don't like to call games
over before they're over but he's also
passive his Knight can hardly move
because the pawns behind it will be
under attack if the Queens come off the
board he's just down a pawn in an end
game and the bishop is stronger than
Knight because their pawns on both sides
of the board Bishops being longrange
pieces is yeah we know it's Magnus
Carson anyone else you might stand a
chance but here the Queens are off we're
in the end game now and Black's Rooks
coming in so many Targets on that second
rank that's where all of White's pawns
are an attack against the black bishops
slows down Magnus here Black's Bishops
could simply move though he can be
defended by the king what will he go for
Magnus Carlson he's done the hard work
he's up a porn he just needs to slow
down consolidate and uh he should get
the job done eventually good move there
from Fabiano challenging the bishop he
also wants to bring his Knight four to
C4 which he can now do because that Rook
can't stay on the second rank so the
black Rook it's fine moving backwards
but it is just a pawn so perhaps I was
calling it a moment too soon I was
looking at fabi's clock I was looking at
magnus's confidence and you see Magnus I
mean he's perked up he's ready to take
this game he's ready to take this game
look at the nerves though on Fabiano
he's got half an eye on the clock he
played that move with three seconds left
now he's been forced to put all of
White's pawns on light squares easy
targets for Black's Bishop look at the
White Knight though contorting
retreating to ugly posts on the edge of
the board there's a threat of Knight
coming to B5 but this can be prevented
and then White's Knight will be offside
really not good news for kowana fans
right now yeah and fabby's played such
fabulous chest today but this game from
start to finish getting out of the
opening Magnus really put the pressure
on he put the pressure on the moment he
went alongside Castle saying that he's
going all out on the defile eventually
won that D4 Pawn he's up upon it's a
matter of technique magn scon up on the
clock Fabby down to 7 seconds he wants
to avoid these complications which often
happen with a knight jumping forward A6
would be a move that I would Blitz out
what else is Magnus thinking about here
he can also move his Rook forward back
into the second rank to go after White's
pawns A6 is a great choice though Tanya
because in that circumstance you take
away the knight's forward jumps and you
look at Magnus he's just being extra
careful he doesn't want to fall into any
night Forks any tactics so A6 would be a
good choice by that standard yeah I'm in
your boat Tanya play A6 in one second
think later you've done the hard work
you've pocketed a pawn kill all
counterplay but Magnus he wants a more
direct route to the victory he doesn't
want to allow Carana any chance long
term but there we go A6 eventually does
appear and black Rook trying to come
down to the second rank that's been
prevented Fabby made that move again
with 3 seconds and a clear visible win
there as he made it Black's Aon coming
down the board targets it's a majority
attack three versus two on the Queen's
side can Magnus just keep pushing he
keeps rolling down the board creating a
second weakness on the queen side
attacking the pawns but right now he
first needs to keep that Rook solid in
the center if Fabby was to take on A4
the A2 pick Pawn becomes a huge Target
for black and the problem for Fabby is
that Magnus is play on both sides of the
board he pushes a pawn why not push your
other Rook Pawn he can push that one
forward a bunch and just take up space
but he gets his King involved how could
you blame him Fabby goes to semiopen
line and as long as Magnus doesn't
blender any pawns he will keep this
advantage that's a scary Magnus when he
makes these chill moves on the board in
this relaxed State you don't want to be
sitting across that guy yeah that's
literally the worst thing in chess when
Magnus gets an endgame advantage and
grinds you down he's got an extra porn
as well here he just creates a safe
haven for the black Bishop to retreat to
Fabby zigzagging back and forth with his
rook and the black king surely is going
to come in soon Magnus first ties down
White's pieces to the defense of the B
Pawn and the king is coming and there's
nothing that white can do because if the
Knight moves or The Rook moves you lose
that B3 pwn and you cannot give black a
two on none on that side of the board
but if the King goes forward some more
maybe the white Rook will start gaining
access to key squares to go after the
black king side so you don't want to go
all in but Magnus he's down under 40
seconds himself everything under control
thus far but if he drops another 20
seconds perhaps fabbi will have a chance
Fabby gets rid of another set of Pawns
suddenly some counterplay potentially
getting his Rook active the black Bishop
drops back though what a nice move move
there from Magnus to keep control to
remind white of the weakness the white B
Pawn the isolated Pawn on the queen side
it's tying down White's pieces and now
the board is even more open that uh
really plays to The Bishop's skills here
The Bishop's abilities compared to the
Knight dominating this white knight
really nice there but pawns have been
traded off and we see the evalar but is
it as easy as the evalar seems to imply
well white just has these two moves that
you're seeing the Rook going back and
forth and now can be freed because the
B3 Pawn is defended so Magnus he's
bringing his King forward every single
piece for him is doing its job it kind
of reminds of the end game with Ali Rea
fua where he had rook and Bishop ala had
rook and Knight and now he just
targeting that weakness and Fab he has
to passively
defend and now he clamps down on the
king side as well taking away more moves
more freedom from Fabiano kwana the
night and The Rook all tied down to
defend B3 Zang Tanya white just can't
move white can't move the Rook or the
Knight because the B Pawn would drop if
white moves the king black might even
play a move like eight H4 Pawn to H4
here we go we see it and white kingside
falls apart now full board awareness
Black's Bishop controls both flanks The
Rook is so dextrous right now attacking
the White Knight and Rook to D3 coming
in King coming in White's remaining porn
will drop and Magnus will win just
unbelievable how easy he made this look
he just completely took away all squares
from Fab's pieces and then all of his
pieces marching forward taking away the
moves wins that extra Pawn is he just
going to capture on B3 next I don't see
why not it looks like a free pawn and
then he can Rumble forward with his
other pawns and he takes it Fabby is
going to try to get active with his Rook
but even if he gains one Pawn there's
still the other to deal with oh Charlie
the C Pawn marching down the board now
this C Pawn will cost white his night
long term it's coming towards promotion
an attack on The Rook first of all
Magnus slides away and Fabiano he keep
playing no fight left here no resources
left and he resigns he doesn't and how
many times have we seen this Magnus
Carlson with with his back against the
wall Rises to the occasion he delivers
and takes it to Armageddon and I think I
saw a slight smile from Magnus he's not
going to be happy with this play overall
but that was a great game from the world
number one he outplayed Fabby from this
offbeat opening and Fabby he's going to
be kicking himself because he had this
match seemingly in the bag but when
you're playing Magnus Carlson Never Say
Never and it does go down to the wire as
the players are about to give their hair
uh Magnus struggling there a little bit
with the pen he hasn't struggled in game
four at all the first game of their set
one the first game of this match where
really we saw Magnus at his best getting
his positions then just out playing once
he got that strategic Advantage he
immediately writes the bid leaves it
comes down to Armageddon we've seen
Magnus with his unpredictable bids here
for Fabby what does he want right now I
think both players should bid high for
white right now we've had no draws so
far in the match between these two draws
overrated play for the win and uh you
might be rewarded for your
courage and this is our bracket there is
still action left on day one of the
semi-finals as we move to Armageddon and
it will be between Magnus Carlson and
Fabiano Carana meanwhile Wes Leo goes
down in set one to nck up to satov nck
played such a great match he really
deserved it and so he is able to
stabilize in game four make that draw
win set one Fabiano he was not able to
do the just that he wasn't able to keep
it under control and now he has to do it
all over again in the Armageddon David
where did it all go wrong for Fabby for
Fabiano Carana it went wrong early
unfortunately he was caught out in the
opening burnt a lot of time on the clock
and was not able to fight back but it
was here that objectively the first real
mistake was made white is in an awkward
pin this pin on the White Knight is
really terrifying you cannot move it for
example to capture a bishop because
because this move comes with check and
uh Black's Queen will save itself next
turn here very naturally Fabiano carled
his King but this allowed the black
queen to step out the way the pin
persists due to pressure on this Knight
and the black Bishop comes out now with
Force instead if he had taken a Karma
approach maybe realized he had the
luxury of time and just moved his Queen
out the way suddenly the White Knight is
threatening to take this bishop white
will be able to Castle next move and
Black's Advantage is kept to a minimum
here Fabiano would have at least
survived the opening and been able to
play a balanced game it's difficult to
recover from a loss when all you need is
a draw to win a set however you could
summarize that game as just awful chess
right there from Fabiano that's not
meant to be insulting but I think when
you look back you're like I just am so
much better than that what happened to
me if he's able to just forget about it
because it was just a bad game then
maybe he can recover in time for this
upcoming Armageddon yeah this is shot
down memory is a chess player's best
friend and right now Fabby needs that he
has to let go of what just happened with
the white pieces because this is Rea
time as we go into Armageddon and that
is a world number two who has to do it
all over again against Magnus Carlson
after this
[Music]
break new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things hey everyone it's Ka roing
reporter for the CCT finals I'm going to
give you guys a venue tour so coming out
of the elevator that's where the players
will be entering all their games every
day heading straight into the player
Lounge so they can sit here relax if
they want coming in here this is
everyone's favorite place this is where
we have the catering and the catering KY
is awesome oh oh yeah as you can see
back part of J store is just right
here's the food it's amazing I'm having
an egg burrito I'm about to be so
energized for today time the food is
amazing okay enjoy your breakfast
burrito going to take you guys in here
so I'm actually going to say this is
where the magic happens first of all in
the corner here that's where I have my
mixone when I get to interview all the
players in between games and take a look
at the take a look at all the screens
all the equipment a lot of fantastic
people are here to make this event
happen I did say that's where the magic
happens well actually this is where the
magic happens this is the venue you guys
a huge room actually and so much
equipment in here I actually heard we
have 20 cameras rolling here every day
to show you guys what's happening on the
boards should I try a chair not sure if
I'm allowed though but okay loving this
CCT finals and thank you for joining
this venue
[Music]
tour
St
[Music]
to
well number one Magnus Carlson he does
it when it matters the most he gets that
comeback win in the final rapid game and
takes it to our
mageddon Armageddon it is the sudden
death of Chess that will decide the
winner of set one in this match and you
ask what it is take a look welcome to
the most exciting format in chess
Armageddon the ultimate tiebreaker
Armageddon grants white more time on the
clock but in return white must win a
draw secures black the match point white
starts with 15 minutes and each player
submits a confidential bid with an
amount of time they are willing to start
with lowest bid gets to choose their
color usually black and those coveted
draw odds let the Armageddon
[Music]
commence it's going to be the ultimate
mind games and Kaa is with the players
to find out their bids and their colors
there will be armagedon to decide the
winner of this first semi-final match so
you guys go ahead and turn those boards
and let's see the bids I see 101 for
Fabby 856 Magnus you will play with the
black pieces you did Circle but I I
assume yeah yeah sure what was the
thinking behind this bit um I didn't
think too much it seemed normal to me
you have had success with the white
pieces in the armagedon so far though so
um want to try something new here well I
I think Armageddon like this is fairly
fairly balanced so I don't know we'll
see and Fabby 101 are you happy with the
white pieces oh there's no way I would
go as low as 856 so whatever I bid it
anyway I was going to get white all
right well it's going to be exciting
thank you for placing your bids back to
you
guys thanks gu Magnus with an 8 minute
5050c bid gets the black pieces Fabby
will start with a six minute advantage
on the clock this is the lowest we've
seen Magnus go down so far well Magnus
believes in having the draw odds which
is interesting because we've had zero
draws thus far in the match I'll have to
say I would give a slight advantage to
Fabiano just because that's a huge lead
in the clock but the look on Fabiano's
face there he did not seem like a happy
chess player he seemed a bit deflated
we'll see if he can bring his best in
Armageddon that's exactly what they need
to do it all comes down to sudden that
it's all about Armageddon and before the
games get going let's check in with the
crew in Toronto guys predictions for the
big
one thank you Tanya yeah James I mean
856 is a 856 a low bid now I will say I
do think it matters less that it's a
six-minute Time Advantage for white I
think it's mostly how much time do I
personally have to equalize the game and
not lose so I think Magnus thinks 856 is
enough is enough 856 is very very low he
really wanted the black pieces there of
course I mean he says hey you know what
look we're going to he says balance is
what he said that's the the terminology
he used fairly balanced so he was like
yeah we want to imbalance it here by
having low time no increment and the
black pieces so this is going to be wild
here yeah I mean this is uh but he did
just have a really successful game with
the black pieces he imbalanced things
exactly like he does and he won on
demand now he doesn't need to win on
demand but I think my prediction is he's
going to go again for imbalance rather
than stability stability white can play
Forever yeah but who knows who knows
yeah who knows he might just
play being in a stable opening yeah how
he just said you know he I think he gave
us a little bit of hint there he was
like yeah it's fairly balanced so I
chose 856 to really tear it up and un
imbalance it and also take black cuz I
got the draw odds so not only am I
imbalancing and with of time you know
see what we do I also have the black
pieces as well so we really trying to
win this and knock it out right now this
is a crazy balanced game so far so we
going to see what happens in this
Armageddon what you think going to
happen here oh I don't know I don't know
and and and the good news is you don't
care about us so let's throw it back to
Oslo and let's get these boys rolling
Armageddon semifinals day one starting
right now oh wow it's going to be a lot
of fun ly by the way great shirt as well
David what do you think about these bids
and Magnus playing with black I've got
to admit I'm surprised it does feel
extremely low I'm on fabby's side here I
think online you can get away with 856
over the board it's going to be tough
physically to make that number of moves
but we'll see who's rewarded ah yes
Magnus with a fantastic game for win
which he made look easy with the black
pieces can he get those earlier opening
imbalance and we are about to find out
but this time Fabby starts with the
Kings Pawn opening we've got a sicilian
on the board and Fab and a one in game
two the white side of a sicilian but we
don't have the Rosal liimo that we saw
them playing 2018 World Chess
Championship we say we have a con
Sicilian a different line and for
Fabiano he's played this for the white
side he's played it from the black side
we'll see what variation he goes down
can he win yes he can the Sicilian Khan
It's a risky choice I must say for
Magnus Carlson so definitely not playing
forced to
definitely not kind of trying to lock
down this game playing straight for the
draw keeping all options open but you're
walking up against one of the best
prepared players out there and look at
this last move Queen to E2 from Fabiano
has forced Magnus to pause Magnus
prevents the white eor from stepping up
even further but this one is guaranteed
to get a bit wild now and Fabby throws
pawns forward this is the ideal position
in a must-win situation for white Fabby
with 15 minutes has to win a draw means
Magnus wins a set one and with that last
move Fabby reinforcing the threat that
was previously stopped by magnus's D6 E5
always in the board in these positions
white is often looking at even the gwn
marching up the board and we can expect
some early fireworks I just feel like
these are difficult positions to figure
out so you need time on the clock and
after KN bd7 I'm surely thinking about
playing G4 and Fabiano had bad clock
Management in that fourth game here he's
playing at a much quicker pace and look
at that pawn go he's not holding
anything back right now yeah all the
pawns storming forward and Fabiano he
has pretty much said the white king is
going Queen side he's going to Castle uh
To the Left Flank so why not develop the
bishop keep the pace going keep the
speed Magnus he's cramped he's kind of
having to contort his pieces and uh the
clock time still in White's favor
actually Fabiano has spent way less time
than Magnus right now still with a over
six-minute time
Advantage oh I really fear for Magnus
this position I feel like Faby can
continue pushing up on the king side use
your Rook Pawn now keep throwing those
pawns forward prevent the black king
from castling and that famous game that
Magnus lost to Andre yeno I remember
pawns were going up the board and Magnus
maybe bid off a little bit more than he
can shoot tactically speaking for fabbi
this is the exact type of position you
want in a must-win game in Armageddon
yeah but he needs to keep up on the
clock he really cannot afford to start
taking so much time so early on in the
game now on the queen side yeah playing
on all flanks this is greedy from hi
from not Hikari from Fabiano even and I
love it pushing all the pawns forward
trying to gain space on the Queen's side
now that he's pretty much conquered the
king side with his pawns and it's really
tough finding counterplay here for
Magnus Carson where the black bishops
going where's the black king going so
many questions to answer so little time
I wouldn't have played it myself but I
actually really like to move A4 because
one of Black's Big Ideas is to push that
B Pawn forward get counterplay of your
own look at how cramped Black's position
is that Bishop Bishop on C8 that light
Square Bishop for Magnus it can't get
out your Bishop on E7 staring into that
G5 Pawn that wall of Pawns and here
comes another Pawn where is the black
king going I hear you guys Fabby playing
on the right side of the board on the
left side of the board but to me that
begs the question where is Fab's King
going to find safety is not going to
head to the king side with the H and the
g Pawn up the board do you really want
to Castle Queen side after you've
committed a A4 maybe it's going to stay
maybe both sides are going to play a
guessing game they both have commitment
issues these Kings right now neither
side wants to kind of declare their
intentions and here we go Fabiano yeah
he's not holding back it's all about
pushing pawns and it's such natural easy
straightforward play for white throw
pawns forward until there are no more
pawns to throw forward for black it
might be decision time where to put that
King and if black castles Queen side
right to the left hand side of our
screen here white can continue throwing
up pawns on that side of the board you
first have to cover your bases make sure
you don't drop any pieces along the way
but you have to watch out for all sorts
of sacrifices and pawn pushes the black
king is going to be exposed no matter
which direction it goes in if you Castle
King side I worry for you there as well
Magnus by the way he's down to 6 minutes
45 seconds no easy choices ahead I'm
going to predict a queenside castle for
white I don't know where magnus's King
find safety definitely Under Fire but I
think for white I would want to get that
King all the way to B1 oh maybe not
anymore yeah at least we know Magnus
won't Castle quein side now he's pretty
much taken that option off the table for
himself the black king is rooted to the
center of the board for now can still
Castle King side but that feels like it
would be castling into the eye of the
storm and for Fabiano it's just about
improving pieces right now does he
Castle it feels a bit risky lining up
against the black queen and Rook how
does he prepare the further advance of
his pawns Rook to G1 there we go I like
it he's just waiting for Magnus to make
a big decision and Magnus is kind of
running out of waiting moves he has all
of his pieces on pretty much ideal
squares can he really push a pawn I
don't think so white on the other hand
can initiate a pawn break maybe Pawn G6
maybe Pawn F5 maybe Pawn H6 you have all
sorts of options and wo after G6 maybe
the white Rook should slide back to
where it came from waiting for that open
file quick call there Robert once The
Rook has done its job on one side on one
file it moves on to the other one
preempting an opening up off the hline
and Magnus first strikes with G6 and now
in the center forcing a decision do you
capture that E5 Pawn because that gives
black a really nice nice hold with the
Knight jumping on to E5 I'm mainly
wondering if white can take on G6 right
now because black can't take towards the
center like you typically want to
because your Rook is loose at the end of
the file and you take have to take away
from the center you cannot touch that
Knight on D4 that's just giving white a
huge attack and a pass Pawn so Fabiano
goes for it and nagas takes away froment
David what do you make of this yeah it's
not ideal for black longterm now black
is suffering on the H file a really
passive Rook here a big Target in front
of it this backward Pawn that being said
fighting for squares as tan mentioned
and it might be important in the next
few turns to capture on F4 as he has
just done and at least carve out one
square for his pieces black is so
cramped there's a traffic jam of pieces
over on this flank so it's time Drop
That Knight into E5 maybe even trade off
on D3 first and black is alive black is
breathing whose King is weaker that's
the key question right now and it's a
question I don't have the answer to it
just looks like uh both Kings will come
under heavy fire in the near future but
this is exactly the kind of crazy
position that 1 in an Armageddon playing
with the white pieces Magnus Carlson now
under 6 minutes no increment uh the game
for all three results the position where
anything can happen uh and as this one
heats up take a look at what's happening
in Toronto it's all eyes on the
Armageddon as everyone's there Wesley as
well watching the game we got Danny and
the crew there give us a wave everyone
if you can hear us hey guys can you see
us the answer is no they're not
listening they're following the action
because this game is really heating up
in the center of the board I think
Magnus did the right thing though when
he pushed that pawn to E5 it was just
the right moment we see look how
intensity they're all looking I think
James is looking with the computer
engine is this the best choice the
engine says it's about level but that
means nothing right now so who can find
the accurate continuations Knight E5 a
very good choice to Magnus he hasn't
committed his King over to G8 because
you Castle King side that white Rook on
H1 is going to barrel down the H file
and cause some pressure against the
black king so I like how Magnus is
handling this and the clock times is
still dramatic whose position do you
feel is easier more instinctive to play
it's just under 11 minutes against five
minutes and a half here I'm liking
Black's position right now but I'm not
liking his clock situation right now and
I think it's still got some questions to
be answer for Fabby this Knight that
you're pointing out that Magnus has
planted on E5 there's really no happy
way to capture it if you take it with
your own Knight Black's Bishop suddenly
opens up and finds itself on a nice
diagonal if you give up the bishop for
it you've given up a key Bishop bear in
an open position with a big G5 weakness
I'm wondering if Fab's in a castle Queen
side at some point that Rook on A1 if
that were in the game we might be
talking an advantage for white but if he
castles Queen side you're walking into
the eye of an attack so instead he
backtracks with his Bishop to E3 maybe
he also rerouted some more the B6 Pawn a
little bit tender I like that move it
actually forces Magnus to come up with a
choice and wow he castles in the line of
fire that shows Supreme Confidence from
Magnus Carlson castling on a side looked
like he was getting attacked on but now
suddenly the seventh rank has cleared
and the one weakness the black H7 Pawn
can easily be defended by the black Rook
or even the black queen and uh it's all
about the white king first there's a
threat Knight takes Knight you need to
resolve that tension and uh Fabiano
needs to get his King to safety as
quickly as possible he's really
regretting putting his white Pawn on A4
if that was back on A2 you castle
queenside with impunity you just Castle
get your king into the corner but it's
the white king stranded in the middle
right now and Fab do take a decision he
doesn't trade on E5 opening up that
black Bishop jumps in the center and he
castles into the line of fire wow even
giving up the A4 Pawn black can even go
and take it now the black queen can
slide over due to a pin on the C file
White's Knight on C3 not really
protecting that pawn but Fabby doesn't
care a pawn is a pawn as they say but
right now it's more important to get the
king to safety white will just park the
King on B1 and say you're not going to
Checkmate me and he plays B5 does Magnus
he doesn't want the pawn he wants to
continue the attack and one thing that
Magnus needs to keep an eye a rook takes
Pawn on H7 it's a whole Rook sacrifice
you seem to be very careful about ideas
like that because the White Queen
sliding over the next Rook coming in
there could be the makings of a
checkmating net but for now B5 it looks
like the white Kings in more danger yeah
big move from Magnus Carlson not
materialistic at all as I mentioned he
could have won a pawn but who cares
about pawns it's more important to
attack throw pawns forward throw pieces
forward and actually Fabian is
hesitating trading off a set of Pawns
because suddenly the a line would come
open uh available for blacks Rooks long
term
I would not envy Fabiano's decision
right now it looks really really
difficult to whip up an attack against
the black king you're basically relying
on those tricks you mentioned Robert
just some tactics something Landing but
if it doesn't land you might just be
collapsing on the other flank and he
does trade off pawns that is a
surprising decision I thought he would
start with King to B1 but maybe he's
saying to Magnus I don't see your
Checkmate just yet that Knight on C3 is
no longer pinned it can jump forward
into D5 and Magnus presses forward oh if
Fabiano's dropping back with his pieces
I'm not liking his chances now black can
double up on the open a line and start
targeting that Knight on A2 two obvious
moves to me Queen A4 followed by The
Rook lining up with that Queen hitting
that Knight that had just moved
backwards to me it just feels like all
the attack is Advantage Magnus right now
yeah retreating in this type of position
in any open Sicilian taking a step back
is like falling off a bicycle it means
you stop pedaling you will get punished
you will be in for a world of hurt and
opening up lines even further for his
Bishops this is really instructive by
black but that Rook sacrifice that I was
saying you need to keep an eye on can
Fabiano go for it his position is
getting really bad it's actually on the
verge of getting out of hand Rook takes
H S the king takes back I'm looking at
Queen H2 check the Knight on E5 is loose
over here as well so you know if we go
King G7 I get to take the Knight with
check I'm bringing my Rook over maybe
I'm playing a little bit of that what
they call cough me house chess I'm
playing for tricks but I need to do
something right yeah you need to try
something and now might be the final
moment Fabiano is able to create any
counterplay at all the evaluation bar
still says good for black but it's not
entirely winning you're setting traps
you're forcing Magnus to burn clock and
uh here big threat if you aren't able to
run into the center which I don't think
is too appealing because this Knight
drops suddenly your King's still under
heavy fire from all angles uh then uh
yeah what else to do with Magnus uh
magnus's King here maybe you move the
bishop out the way in that position to
guard across the seventh rank but uh
it's really really difficult it might be
now or never for Fabiano to muddy the
waters take this Pawn before it's too
late you need to try something I'll just
mention that Queen to H2 is not good
enough looks like a double attack but
this way round the move order doesn't
work black just simply defends the
Knight defends the pawn and everything
is controlled and Fabby pauses he's
having a think and I think this is
exactly the line that's running through
his head Rook into Pawn to try to muddy
the waters will Fabby go for this
because if he doesn't it feels like
Magnus just gets a free hand to execute
his attack hiar now you said it before I
was going compliment him but I was going
to say that Fabiano and hikara said this
doesn't like speculative sacrifices he's
not somebody who just says oh let me go
for something and hope that it works
he's a calculator and he's a calculating
machine and he's looking at Rook takes
H7 he's trying to prove that it works we
saw the eval bar it says it shouldn't
work out for white but shouldn't doesn't
mean that it can't and it is going to be
a Scramble for Magnus a lot of pressure
around his King and how many times have
we seen that it's all about making these
practical POS decisions in these
positions it's not about what is
objectively the best move right now he
needs to pose questions to Magnus give
him the opportunity to go wrong in
complicated position under 5 minutes on
the clock no increment but the more
Fabby thinks the more time for Magnus to
think yeah and we saw Magnus on the
camera I don't know if you missed it
there but he I mean as soon as we
mentioned Hikaru he was doing the head
Bob he looked like he was dancing he had
something going on in his head maybe he
was just confirming with this long
variation this kind of complicated line
Rook takes ball and he was thinking oh
maybe I am surviving yes I'm calculating
on your time Fabiano and the longer he
waits the less likely this trick is to
work takes H7 if not then yeah blacks
light Square Bishop comes to life the
white king will be doomed long term
you're playing without a white knight on
A2 you have to do it Fabiano you have to
try something you have to gamble he's
invested three minutes already so right
now his time Advantage it's almost out
the window so for Fabiano it's one of
these situations where if you're playing
a bullet game and you're playing online
you just go for it and you hope that it
works out but Fabiano if he doesn't go
for it his position is falling apart
Magnus just plays move D5 he's trying to
break open the position even more the a
file is open the C file is open white
king does not have too many defenders in
front of it so this is going to be a
situation where as we were talking about
now or never for Fabiano I think you
just have to go for it and if you pray
and it works so be it on the board bang
and who has calculated better it's a
check Magnus has worked this all out in
Fabiano's time big threat of Checkmate
on the board Queen to H7 would end the
game Magnus needs to guard against it
but was Magnus only expecting Queen
takes Knight because after Rook H1 with
this idea had he Tau this true he would
Blitz out his next move it kind of
reminds me of his game against Wesley so
where Wesley beat him in Armageddon he
threw a ton of pieces at Magnus Magnus
defends the seventh Rank and defensive
KN but Queen H H check oh wow Bishop F4
I was not expecting that move maybe
Magnus wasn't either I thought he could
continue checking against the black king
and pick up that 95 this is really
complicated really really messy Let's
ignore the evaluation bar which is
misleading right now with best play
Black defends black has an extra rook
and will win the game but that black
king is about to come under heavy fire
threats against the Black Knight too
this is far from Easy with just 3
minutes on the clock Magnus makes a
mistake he gives up his Queen
potentially but he's counterattacking
against the White Queen is this a
mistake or is this genius to try and
save this game and Armageddon draw would
be enough at this point the players are
just making moves they're not thinking
about what is the best move it is about
saving the position move by move Knight
jumps in White's Queen is attacked black
Black's Queen is attacked you really
can't trade off Queens in this position
you crazy tactics here Robert yeah the
black Queen's kind of trapped right if
white just moves the queen one step
forward where's that black queen going
but black will make a draw I think black
can just take the white Bishop give up
the black queen and black has Knight D2
check the white King's forced to the
corner Knight B3 check and there's a
Perpetual check Black Knight Will trap
this white king Magnus has spotted it
all and I think Fabby has just spotted
it all that is brilliant it's one of
those decisions where it's given a
blunder symbol because the evaluation
gone to the middle but all Magnus
Carlson needs is a draw and he's about
to force the draw this is unbelievable
recognition we just saw that video
during the break of them doing tactics
Magnus he's been doing his tactics and
just Uncorked a beautiful four straw
sequence youve got to break this down so
white cannot take Black's Queen because
the end game after all the trades favors
Magnus Carlson if white was to get out
of the queen trade with the queen move
David explain it one more time the
Perpetual yeah if the White Queen steps
away from the second rank then all black
needs to do is remove White's Bishop
first of all if for example Queen to H3
black will take the bishop in either
direction Rook takes Bishop as soon as
the White Knight goes and captures The
Black Queen on G7 there's a Perpetual
check Black's Knight comes down to D2
Fabiano allows the Queens to disappear
instead he's fighting for the win but
with lack of Queens with this will mean
lack of attack as well and Magnus trades
off Rooks this is just over it could
have been a draw that would have ended
in the same result Magnus is going to
win this arm again and it's not because
Fabby missed that Perpetual check it's
because it's the same he has to fight
this out till the end a draw is a loss
at this point for Fabiano Karana he had
to choose the Lesser evil in this
position which is going into a busted
end game but the game goes on yeah but
fabby's head was in his hands I mean
he's down an entire Rook he's just
playing on for the sake of it he could
just throw in the towel Magnus Carlson
brilliant tactical awareness to take
this arm
again yeah it's a surprise this game is
still ongoing 3 minutes for Magnus is
more than sufficient but Fabiano just
frustrated he got so close he tried what
he had to but in the end handshake
Magnus wins it is match over as Magnus
Carlson with the brilliant tactics on
the ball that he spotted in seconds and
it was all over takes the win in the
Armageddon that is set one to Magnus set
to Fabby will have to strike back and
that's something that Magnus should be
proud of I know he's been upset about
his play it was shaky earlier on but to
defend that position and to just end it
on the spot he did not even allow a
semblance of Hope to Fabian o caran in
the Armageddon ridiculously good game
from Magnus and once again Magnus shows
it even when he is off F even on a bad
day Magnus even as off is actually on
and you just cannot write him off uh and
we see him getting that big dub in David
I think it all comes down to that moment
that you were pointing out which was the
tactics that Magnus spotted that decided
the armagen let's break it down Tanya
let's do a proper action replay of that
tactical flurry just genius by both
players but especially on the side of
Magnus Carson to guide the game towards
safely uh safety there and it was here
where Fabiano correctly chose to gamble
to risk it maybe playing this same move
quicker would have been better but he
decided Rook takes H7 before it's too
late before there's no sance of at all
of an attack Rook takes H7 dragging the
black king out and a check forcing the
black king back now threatening
Checkmate Magnus found the key defense
this square is the mating Square he
simply played Bishop D6 defending his
Knight covering this post yes Fabiano
could have given a check yes he might
have been able to give other checks for
example but unfortunately for him his
Queen here in the corner would have been
trapped a queen exchange black would
emerge with extra material he instead
chose the very clever the very sneaky
Bishop F4 move but Magnus had worked it
all out instead of delve even deeper
deeper into the complications he played
Queen to G7 the computer says it's a
blunder but this is a genius move now
the queen looks trapped Knight to E6
Magnus though counterattacks against the
White Queen and if the White Queen moves
this was the Crux of the matter Queen to
H3 would have left the D2 Square
undefended by all other than the bishop
so remove that piece Rook takes bishop
and after the black queen disappears a
beautiful drawing Motif check the white
king is forced into the corner another
check the king is forced back and the
position would have repeated itself
instead Fabiano gave up more material
but was not able to save the game puzzle
Rush on display live just to see that
all the way back when why had two pieces
covered the D2 Square wasn't on our
radar but Magnus Carlson he proves why
he's the number one rated player in the
world even when his back is against the
wall he can come out on top that was
really brilliant stuff from him that was
a stunning stunning find there by Magnus
and played out in seconds and Fabby had
no option but to go into the lost to end
game and this is where we are after set
one of the semi-finals we started with
eight players four were knocked out
going into the semis and uh this
tomorrow we continue with set two as
wesle so has to strike back against nbec
Abdus satov Fabiano Carana who did take
the lead in the rapid Magnus took it
back in game four equalized the score
and then one in the Armageddon wow that
was uh that was thrilling especially
considering that Magnus got the black
pieces he bid for the black pieces it
got really messy at the start and then
finding Tac taks with just no increment
yeah thrilling for Magnus I can't Heap
enough Praise on his play but
heartbreaking for five Carana throughout
the first three games of the match it
could have been over in Fab's favor he
was up a queen in the first game and
still lost in that bullet scramble so
for fabbi there is no consolation prize
right now he lost today's set one he
needs to come back tomorrow and win set
two and then if he gets there to a third
and final set but I you know he's going
to just be heartbroken after today's
Affairs yeah that's the beauty of the
format we always find winner but it's
also the downside nobody deserved to
lose today they were trading punches
both at the top of their game Fabby in
the end it was just such small margins
in the end it was Magnus Madness that
got it through and uh yeah I'm still
recovering from all of that action it
was really really entertaining to watch
yeah really entertaining especially that
line that you pointed out with the
Perpetual at the end the Knight jumping
from D2 to B3 to just find that kind of
chest this is the beauty that we love
when the very best player in the world
now for Fabi it's been heart break but
he doesn't have that much recovery time
and there's big action coming up for all
four players tomorrow and for more
breakdown on everything that we've just
seen we're going to head over to our
gang in Toronto Danny what a day of
Chess once
again what a day of Chess this has just
been wild I I agree with what David just
said guys it felt like nobody deserved
to lose but somebody had to win in the
end
it's Magnus again I guess that happens a
lot yeah it happens a lot it's really
interesting I'm I'm kind of uh I guess I
kind of expected it when James and I
talked about the Armageddon time choice
and even though you're down 6 minutes
you still have enough time to think
being down 856 versus 15 is not the same
thing as being down 556 versus 12 like
the time Gap is the same but you you
yourself have enough time to create an
imbalance in a Sicilian Defense which is
what he went for and he just timed it
perfectly and ultimately that's what it
comes down to I mean Magnus is either
going to beat everybody over the course
of a game from start to finish or in
just two or three critical moments and
that's what he did there against Fabiano
I think it was important what he said
about the timing there the timing was
really nice is uh you have black right I
chose to go with the 8 minutes 836 or
whatever he chose there I chose to get
that time I chose to imbalance it I knew
you were going to come at me him being
Fabby you're going to be aggressive try
to win here I'm going to choose
something that's going to give me some
chances and if I find that draw then I
win the game which he was able to do it
was amazing how he found that draw cuz
he played a line was objectively of
course not the right way to defend but
Force liquidation
although I'm going to kind of disagree
in that the way this one started he goes
into a con Sicilian Fabiano Carana is as
dangerous as anyone we're sitting there
with Maxim bash lra who's been on the
black side of some sharp open Sicilians
against Fabiano right and it felt like
it felt like things were going his way
right and then and then the gloves came
off but because of what you said because
of well-timed counterattacking moves by
Magnus G6 and then E5 obviously this was
this was crazy I think we're about to be
joined by the Champs let's just scoot
over and get him in here
um Magnus it's uh I don't know where you
want to be you can be in between all of
us or on the edge or call
but you you've now won two must-win
games as black to force Armageddon but
uh take us through your thoughts on
today's match this felt like one that
neither of you really deserved to lose
but in the end somehow you snatched a
victory I could look at it both ways
like we kind of also Both Deserve to
lose cuz we made a lot of mistakes um to
be fair I think the first two games were
quite poor um I mean I just made a
really really childish mistake in the
second game cuz I can only like ever
trade Queens if his King doesn't get to
the center and I noticed immediately
after I made the move that he gets his
trick with King F1 and then it's quite
unpleasant for me already yeah at least
then I have to Cease the moment to force
his Knight to D2 but I was so pissed at
myself and after that I think he played
flawlessly but
um uh yeah um I think third game he just
outplayed me I mean I didn't even feel
that I played that badly but I was just
crushed um and uh you know losing two
games in a row of course I didn't have I
didn't have a lot of hopes but these
Armageddon sorry not Armageddon games
but these must win games with black they
they never seem to be quite as
straightforward as they as they should
be um and um yeah
um I I wouldn't say that I particularly
believed in it but I thought let's give
it give it a shot like
remember uh you know complicate the game
don't be too desperate and so on and
yeah the opening was a dream for me and
from there on it worked quite well
Magnus I have a question um obviously
game four of rapid you have to create
imbalance to play for a win because it's
two to one but when you're playing
Armageddon I mean some people play E4 E5
they just try to hold with black I mean
you played Sicilian it was a cons
Sicilian it was complicated everybody
sitting out there looking at all the
Tactical possibilities do you have to
make a conscious effort to play a
sicilian or an E4 E5 versus the opponent
or I mean are we overanalyzing as
commentators I think it was more about
my moods um I didn't want want to get
back in sort of a defensive mindset so I
was trying to treat it more more like a
must-win game or at least at least one
where I should not
um um you
know not try and avoid the fight
so I I also felt like trying to provoke
a crisis in the game earlier might be
okay for me since I have less time okay
uh I just didn't want to be in a
situation where I get ground ground down
I mean I didn't have the energy or the
nerves at that point to to play like a
long um long game at all so I just
wanted
to get a quick fight and see see what
happens and it also felt to me that he
would be he would be shaky after the the
last game he probably wouldn't expect
anything particularly sharp in the
opening so I I I hope that I could
surprise him but I mean I mean of course
it's um it's extremely risky especially
considering that my position from is
objectively I think pretty dubious
there's still chest of course you have
one more match so uh you know say we win
and we go to the final who are we
looking to face or you want would you
rather Abu aor off or Wesley so a strong
as they are right now I think it's far
too early for for for that okay um I
mean the way that I'm playing the way
that Fabi play mean game three
especially um I wouldn't we wouldn't
take anything for for granted I mean I
think that's fair what would you say
your mindset then is because I mean game
one you kind of got away with one right
fobby was two moves away from winning
and then even though maybe it was back
and forth games two and three goes go
his way what are you doing tonight to
maybe feel like hey like I don't know
that I played my best yest today
tomorrow bring yeah I guess I got to do
something else before the game because
like the
last three days really I've just turned
up and felt horrible so that's that's
the yeah that's the thing really um I've
just not been not been ready from the
start at all just feeling super sluggish
so I think that's that's where it is I
know of course that I can play that I
can play good chess but um the way that
it's been the last few days I feel like
I'm on the back heel um on the back foot
from from from the GetGo and yeah that's
um you can't yeah you can't rely on
swindling your way through matches like
I I was going to say though but the
content is great so maybe you can I mean
obviously I'm making jokes about the but
Ser it's amazing cuz you did have to
come back but you know good good honest
thoughts that you want to show up a
little bit more ready right out of the
gate tomorrow no no I mean of course it
feels great to win on even on days that
I'm that I don't feel so so great and
know that I don't play so well but um
yeah I don't think you can can rely on
it yeah well whe you can rely on it or
not you did put on quite a show that was
amazing to watch and so we wish you the
best of luck tomorrow and uh I guess
we'll see you again yeah thank you thank
you no no other no other last
thoughts no I didn't hear any
predictions okay you were about to I
haven't uh you know I haven't felt
slighted in any way so you gave me a
smile that made me think you had
something else to say but anyway we
appreciate it man good luck enjoy the
night we'll see you tomorrow thank you
see you all right and that was the guy
that's the man Magnus he gets the job
done in crazy crazy fashion today a
comeback Victory as we said he wins with
black to force Armageddon for the second
time here in Toronto and ultimately gets
the job
done oh man it was crazy but okay he
wasn't the only winner in this
semi-finals matchup the youngster the
19-year-old that dude didn't even need
Armageddon tie breaks guys he didn't
even need anything but three you know
four I guess he needed four games cuz he
lost the first one but he took two and a
half points and ultimately defeated
Wesley so and Kaa caught up with him
right after his
victory it's a massive nck ABD saturo
takes the first match in the semi-finals
congrats nck thank you how are you
feeling right now after managing to beat
the unbeatable Wesley so in an entire
match yeah it's it's done quite an
achievement for
me um yeah I this is my first um match
win against Wesley so yeah it feels
great and yeah but but it's uh it will
be um it will be decided tomorrow yeah
so he's going to reach finals so yeah
we'll see but let's first look back so
what are you the most happy about with
the way you played today yeah I'm quite
happy um I got um I played good chess in
every
game um yeah I'm just satisfied with my
result today
and also I think
Wesley Wesley was
a um was in not like good shape today so
I think he will he will get give me a
tough fight tomorrow yeah and what will
it be about tomorrow then to be able to
actually win the semi-finals here and go
to the
finals yeah I
mean um there is you know there is a
match ahead of me and so I need to
first um win that match so it's quite a
long way say yeah what what will you do
the rest of the day here in Toronto
today um just rest you know just have a
walk
and just um enjoy the time here who who
do you have with you here in Toronto I
have my mother with me so actually we
are we are going to the like shopping
center every day so we are just um yeah
we have we have we are having a great
time here is he dragging you to the
Shopping Center or are you actually
enjoying
that I mean both like you know I just
want to forget about games and just uh
just rest all right well can you reveal
any great finds have you bought anything
uh you're really happy with um yeah we
have about
um we have about uh perfumes so so yeah
we are I'm I'm happy yeah all right so
are you going to so it seems like a
recipe for success for you uh will you
go to the shopping mall today as well
then um we'll see I think she's already
there
so fantastic n um go enjoy the mall
enjoy your Victory and good luck
tomorrow thank you all right well you
guys that seems to be the recipe for a
success just go relax at the mall back
to you
guys well maybe that's how you deal with
your nerves as a mom instead of watching
your son win the most important chest
match of his career maybe you go
shopping but that's what he did guys
95.5% accuracy he beats Wesley so
without even needing Armageddon and uh
all right guys let's let's talk about
this one a little bit cuz obviously
Magnus and Fabby steal the show usually
but let's not let Notre Beck get away
without some big compliments or whatever
we want to say Levy I'm going to start
with you what can you say about the
young man from usbekistan it started
literally the worst way possible he was
playing with black he gets outplayed in
a super super long drawn he over pushes
and then loses I mean he loses it's okay
it's back back to back to business
Wesley so 6 and0 in
Toronto and then you know then he loses
he loses to Fabiano but like Wesley
could have won seven and0 I mean he you
just lost to Fabby and the armag again
and so we're like all right great you
know back to business and then he Notre
gets white no problem then wins with
black and then and and then absolutely
no problems in the fourth game either so
really impressive really really
impressive Danny dubbed it the NY the
magical iCal everything go Dragon he is
I mean that
man you know I'm going to get
confirmation from him on the nickname I
think that's fair while we're just
called him that the whole show I've been
calling him that I think since he was 15
years old okay so the mythical dragon I
like it the Magic Dragon the Magic
Dragon okay that's what it is you know I
don't know how it started but frankly it
started with me thinking there was an R
before the D which there's not nor so I
don't I'm going to get permission to
continue using it but jokes aside I do
want to go back CU Levy you and I you
and I were in the mix Zone and Fabby
loses in heartbreaking fashion right but
Notre Beck also lost in kind of
heartbreaking fashion he over pushed Y
and and then Wesley so punishes him and
yet he turns it around that's the type
of makeup the type of mental makeup
we're watching of someone who's a future
champion because that takes guts yeah
yeah he's he's ice cold water in his
veins uh time is ticking and the first
game didn't go his way but to just come
right back and the first game didn't go
his way exactly in the style of that
matchup no you're back the aggressor the
Young Gun right the magical dragon uh
you can say it he likes it Wesley is is
cool common collected defense you know
defensive resources like through the
roof and no to come back to win the
second and the third game two in a row
from a defeat is uh is massive so what
can you say that's beautiful I mean you
got to know that also Notre backck a lot
of times we forget this he is a rapid
Champion so playing this
format
Champion it's really fair and you know I
was sitting with with Wesley out there
and he was having fun which again just
shout out to Wesley and his
General demeanor who he is I guess his
wholesome demeanor because he sits down
with me and he goes yeah after I won the
first game he uh he turned it on and he
just outplayed me after that I'm like
yeah he goes I guess I got to play
better tomorrow I'm like I think you
will he's like okay but it was just like
like no part of him that was you know
backing down from the fact that Notre
Beck outplayed him and we'll see what
kind of mindset Wesley has going into
tomorrow cuz he is facing a world rapid
Champion despite how good Wesley is in
this format he did also talk to Kaa
right after the loss Wesley so telling
me just before we came on that life is
good you can't win every time so are you
okay even if you lost a match today
Wesley no no I'm very much okay I mean
first of all my opponent played like
perfect chess I mean I look I had a few
minutes I look briefly in between the
match and he basically gave me no
chances okay I shouldn't have lost game
three like that was very stupid but at
the same time it happens when you get
low on the clock just things explode
becomes unpredictable so I think he
played really well well I mean I think I
didn't play that poorly today it's just
he played better so it is what it is I
mean you can't you can't win every day
as they say uh so it's not what I was
hoping for but the same time it's it's a
good day I got another chance tomorrow
no I think I'm going to make a shout out
to my boy Anish giri for holding the
fort and Twitter you mean yeah and for
watching the games on sit guest on the
on the Spain yeah yeah because I saw
that ler Drew against a 2350 I mean ler
is a good friend of mine but at the same
time uh you know we're we're competing
so so uh yeah and and then tomorrow
another another day I'll give my atmost
most best and the very least I'll get
some practice I'm not going to bother
you too much with what happened today
but in an interview here nard did say
that he felt you were a little bit shaky
uh when you came into time trouble so
that was part of his tactics did you
feel shaky in time trouble today yeah
for sure he was always ahead on the
clock but again I didn't think I played
that poorly maybe my time management
wasn't the best like in the openings I
was spending a lot of
time uh so that could be improved like
I'm always down on the CL and then later
he would catch up and then we'd get
even um and in time scrambles you know
he's a young kid so he's he's very good
and what will you do today now to just
forget about this and get ready for
making a comeback tomorrow well I'll
watch the Armageddon game uh I'll just
uh relax try to find some ideas uh and
uh TR to sleep well not to be too
stressed and and uh hopefully I can come
up in very good form tomorrow and and
then we'll get a match best of luck
tomorrow Wesley thank you for stopping
by yes anytime all right Wesley so he's
going to make a comeback tomorrow that's
the plan for him back to you
guys well do you think he makes a
comeback tomorrow Levy I mean I have no
idea I guess it's too late to change my
my pick I chose uh Carlson and I chose
so that has nothing to do with no I just
thought Wesley was in great for but this
is actually Wesley's worst situation
that he's been in in the two years of
events in Toronto last year he won the
entire event and this year he's on the
verge of elimination so tomorrow he is
fighting to win the set to force a tie
break and then ultimately to make it to
the finals um I mean I can't just change
my pick knowing the result of today's
match so I'm I'm sticking with Carlson
and so we'll see if he can make a
comeback and if no wins listen that's
the future yeah he is the future so I I
am sticking with my pick of Carlson and
so but I as a Jedi I do feel a
disturbance in the force here with uh
with Abdus satoro the way that he's
playing right now so it definitely is a
shake up of course W is coming from
behind but Abdus satov is not going to
slow down so it's scary but I'm still
taking you know my piics there so you
said shake up before we go I want to
give you both a chance to react to that
because I think the most critical
takeaway of both players being honest
there was that nottock said he felt like
Wesley was shaky yeah that's not
something we normally see right and
Wesley kind of acknowledged it so what
what's going on with that I think nerb
just speaks his mind maybe maybe there's
a little bit of spice on there maybe
there's a little bit of trash talk but I
think he's just young hungry confident
like we have to remember nck is the
pride of his country like usbekistan
where he's from is fully on board with
his chess career he's like meeting the
president they're naming Academy he's
getting cars they bought him a Chevrolet
what about a
BMW no disrespect but next time when he
wins this get him a BMW this show is not
sponsored by Chevrolet if Chevrolet
wants to sponsor it they can there you
go or BMW go ahead my point is also like
I keep saying this but he's the only guy
up here not named Magnus Carlson who is
a world champion he's the 2021 World
rapid Champion he knows what it takes to
win a world championship title and this
year after this event he's got a you
know he has a chance to win one again
over there in usbekistan so he he knows
what it's like to perform at the highest
level at the age of 17 only correction
Wesley so did win a world F random
Championship yeah we need like a few of
those to make it really I know I know no
no but your point is very well taken and
and I'll even double down on it he won a
World rapid Championship that's what
we're doing here we're playing rabbit
that was 1510 this is 15 it's the same
it's basically the same um so he he
knows what it takes and yeah he he might
make us all put our foot in our mouth
and maybe he wins the whole damn thing
yeah and then they get him they get him
a statue and a BMW and a BM if he wins
the whole damn thing here you're getting
him a statue and a
BMW
ABD
get it engraved on the side too guys
this was incredible we we the stage has
been set for tomorrow Notre Beck OB do
to tur off the underd the underdog is up
the Underdog's on top right now and he's
going to shine until the chest stops
maybe we'll see the uh other matchup of
course the underdog is not on top Magnus
Carlson is leading but he didn't play
his best chest today we'll see if Magnus
can finally figure out his slow start
that we've all been talking about for a
while but all right for the crew for
Levy for KY for everyone crushing
working super hard there's a lot of
people here bringing this thing to you
everybody in Oslo we love you we know
it's late hope you're going to enjoy
your evening the first day of the
semi-finals here at the 2023 Champions
chess tour finals is in the books we're
going to take a very very quick break
tonight but we'll see you bright and
early for the second day of the semis
here from
[Music]
Toronto stop but he give check he just
blundered the poem with check Magnus
Carson does the unbelievable he wins
down a queen oh he's training off all
the bishop brilliant and NY back he's
resigned ABD SRA The Comeback K strikes
again leveling the game and in what
style amazing performance Fabiano Carana
are really bringing his aame today n
Abdu satov also gets the backto back
Victory Fabiano just frustrated he got
so close he tried what he had to but in
the end handshake Magnus
wins
[Music]